[Musique]
Sarfo, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Tout à fait.
Alors, je m'appelle Sarah Knafo, j'ai 32
ans. Je suis députée européenne depuis
quelques mois maintenant. Sinon, j'ai
grandi en scène Saint-Denis dans une
petite commune entre Bondi et Holné
Soubois. J'ai commencé mes études par de
l'économie à la Sorbonne, puis j'ai fait
Science Pu, j'ai fait LENA.
Quand j'étais à Lena, j'ai travaillé
pendant quelques mois à l'ambassade de
France en Libye.
J'ai travaillé à la préfecture des
Pyrénées Atlantiques, c'était au moment
du G7 de Biaritz. J'ai aussi passé
quelques mois chez Publicis au sein de
la Holding. C'était mon dernier stage de
LENA. Après, je suis sortie de l'ENA, je
suis devenue magistrate à la Cour des
comptes. J'y ai acquis quelques
réflexes. Euh, ça m'a donné le goût de
la chose, le devoir aussi sans doute,
mais peut-être qu'on en reparlera, de
protéger les deniers publics, de
vérifier quel était leur emploi et
d'essayer de contribuer à ma manière à
faire respecter le fruit du travail de
de chacun d'entre nous. C'est euh sans
doute l'un des éléments qui m'a aussi
conduit à sauter le pas. et à passer euh
en politique. J'expliquerai peut-être
pourquoi tout à l'heure il y avait un
côté aussi frustrant euh dans mon métier
de magistrat à la Cour des comptes. Euh
quand j'y étais encore euh j'ai enseigné
j'ai enseigné à Science Poau et dans
d'autres prépas euh qui préparaient les
les concours administratifs et notamment
l'ENAT, j'ai enseigné le droit public,
le droit constitutionnel,
l'économie, la culture générale comme on
dit pompeusement. J'ai adoré enseigner.
Je crois que ça aurait pu être une
vocation. J'essaie de continuer d'aider
plein de jeunes gens qui veulent
présenter des concours à à ne pas
s'autocensurer et j'essaie de de
contribuer à ma manière. Et ensuite donc
j'ai j'ai franchi le pas en 2022 en
fondant le parti au conquête au côté
d'Éric Zemour. C'était une grande
aventure. Je pense qu'on n pas fini d'en
sentir les effets politiquement sur la
France. Euh en 2024, je suis devenue
députée européenne et ça me conduit euh
devant vous aujourd'hui. Et ben,
bienvenue. Aujourd'hui, on va parler
géopolitique, finances, économie, emploi
des deniers publics et tout un tas de
sujets.
Première question, Sarah Knafo, où va la
France ? Bah, c'est sans doute la
question la plus importante et euh c'est
quand je me suis répondu dans le mur que
j'ai décidé de m'engager. Euh je pense
qu'on a si on regarde la situation de
manière statique aujourd'hui, on a
presque tous les voyants qui sont au
rouge. C'est pas décliniste ou
pessimiste de dire ça, populiste, ni
populiste. Au contraire, je pense que
c'est une constatation assez clinique,
assez froide. Euh, ça veut pas dire
qu'on peut pas s'en sortir. Ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas d'autres moments de
notre histoire où on avait presque tous
les voyants au rouge. Ça veut pas dire
qu'on peut pas trouver 1000 exemples
d'autres pays dans le monde qui avaient
eux aussi une situation catastrophique.
Les autres les juger perdus, certains
s'en réjouissaient et puis on voit que
soudain une flamme s'allume, un peuple
se réveille, des dirigeants sont soudain
honnête, ont de la une probité, une
forme de vision pour leur pays et
soudain, un pays s'en sort et s'en
remet. Donc moi, le premier constat que
j'ai fait euh je pense que c'est toute
ma vie qui m'a qui m'a conduit à le
faire. Je vous ai dit que j'avais grandi
en scène Saint-Denis. Donc d'un certain
point de vue, je dirais presque charnel,
du point de vue de mon vécu, j'avais
déjà pu voir ce qui ne marchait pas. Euh
quand on est une jeune femme dans les
entre les années 90, je suis né en 1993
et les années 2000 et qu'on passe son
adolescence entre Bondi et Hnez sous, je
pense qu'on comprend déjà ce qui ne
fonctionne pas. On voit les limites de
l'État euh ce qui est quelque chose
d'assez fort en France parce que vous
savez que la nation française a toujours
beaucoup compté sur l'État. Ce sorte
d'État tout-puissant qui devait nous
sauver, nous protéger, nous assurer la
sécurité, la prospérité et puis parfois
ça vole en éclat et on se dit bah
finalement personne n'est là pour me
protéger. On est seul livré à nous-même.
Pour ceux qui veulent se défendre, ils
sont punis presque plus sévèrement que
que ceux qui les attaquent. Donc une
sorte de remise en question euh non
seulement de la la puissance française,
l'image qu'on en avait, je vais y
revenir de manière un peu plus concrète,
mais en plus remise en question de cette
grande institution censée nous protéger,
l'État français. Euh je disais que
j'allais revenir plus concrètement sur
les sujets. Je vais essayer de parler de
de thèmes que sur lesquels tout le monde
voit bien pourquoi on a décliné. Si on
prend la santé, on se rappelle tous
années 2000 quand on se dit on a le
meilleur système de santé du monde. À
l'époque, l'OMS nous flatte dans ce
travers très très chauvin et on se dit
on a le meilleur système de santé du
monde. Tout le monde nous l'envie et
cetera. Une forme de chauvinisme sur ce
ce système de santé. On fait pas un
dessin, arrive le Covid, on s'aperçoit
qu'on a pas assez de lit, qu'on manque
de tout. Quelques années plus tard,
l'hôpital George Pompidou, c'est pas le
pire hôpital de France he, c'est
peut-être même l'un qui est l'un de ceux
qui sont les mieux lotis, l'hôpital
George Pompido est obligé de faire un
appel au don pour financer des scanners.
Là, on se dit, on a on marche quand même
sur la tête, on est en train de faire
des appels au dons, donc on appelle à la
générosité publique comme si on payait
pas suffisamment d'impôts pour financer
un appareil aussi simple dans un hôpital
que des scanners. On marche sur la tête
parce queon nous a caché les choses. On
marche sur la tête parce que on a
enveloppé notre système de santé avec
des lunettes rose, un beau papier, que
tout allait bien, mais il fallait pas
regarder sous le tapis. On marche sur la
tête parce qu'il y a une allocation
totalement irrationnelle de nos
ressources. C'est-à-dire qu'on est à la
fois le peuple le plus taxé du monde et
je pense l'un des peuples de de l'Europe
de l'Ouest ou de l'OCDE qui se sent le
plus mal en matière de service public.
Alors, on aurait pu dire c'est les
Français qui sont qui rechinent, qui
sont capricieux. On a aussi cette
réputation. et puis arrive le Covid et
donc là je reviens à à cette à cette
première prise de conscience et on se
dit mais non finalement il y a d'autres
pays qui s'en sortent mieux et nous
alors même qu'on paye une fortune qu'on
a les dépenses sociales les plus élevées
de tout le monde occidental et sans
doute même du monde mais d'autres ont
des systèmes de de comptabilité
tellement différents des nôtres que
c'est difficile à à affirmer avec
certitude. En tout cas les dépenses
sociales les plus élevées de tout le
monde occidental et pour autant ce
sentiment qu'on manque de tout. On a
même pas de masque, on n pas de
défibrillateur, on a pas de casac, on a
un pays qui est devenu un désert
médical. Quand vous regardez les
chiffres, 77 % du territoire français
est considéré comme un désert médical.
C'est-à-dire que euh enfin, j'ai pas
dermato, pas d'ofthtalmo, pas chico.
Exactement. Exactement. Vous attendez 6
he urgences pour la moindre chose.
Cardio, pas de cardio. Euh si vous
voulez, alors quand en plus c'est de la
médecine spécialisé, vous devez attendre
1 an et demi. J'entends des cas parfois
quand les gens en ont les moyens, on
parle de petites classes moyennes, on
parle pas de gens richissime et qu'ils
ont absolument besoin d'aller voir un
dentiste parce qu'ils souffrent trop.
Vous savez que les douleurs dentaires,
c'est ce qu'il y a ce qu'il y a de pire.
En tout cas, pour ceux qui en ont subi,
ils savent que c'est très difficilement
supportable. Il y a des gens qui
prennent un avion et qui partent d'un
bout de la France à l'autre, par exemple
à Nice sans vouloir donner un tuyau,
mais qui se disent "Là-bas, il y a plus
de disponibilité, ils l'ont vu sur
Doctolib et" et ils prennent carrément
un avion pour aller trouver un médecin
plus rapidement. C'est-à-dire un système
qui est totalement fou où on se targuit
d'avoir le meilleur système de santé. Et
puis soudain, il y a un événement comme
le Covid qui révèle nos failles et les
Français se disent finalement peut-être
que ceux qu'on qualifié à tort de
décliniste ou de populistes étaient ceux
qui étaient les plus lucides. Il y a
moi, enfin sur sur cette questionlà,
donc là j'ai parlé de la santé, on peut
aussi parler de l'école. Vous vous
souvenez comme moi des articles dans le
journal Le Monde pour ne pas les citer
de tous ces sociologues qui disaient "Le
niveau monte, c'est faux. Le niveau
scolaire ne baisse pas. Les élèves sont
1000 fois meilleurs qu'il ne l'était de
notre temps, disaient certains
sociologues. Euh quand on veut chercher
des contrevérités, je pense que c'est
typiquement le genre de de document
qu'il faut lire, ce qui ce qui ressort
aujourd'hui de la sociologie française
parfois. Euh et donc je me souviens d'un
article du monde titré "Le niveau monte,
preuve à l'appui." Tous ceux qui disent
le contraire sont des déclinistes, des
populistes. Je sais pas si on disait
déjà d'extrême droite pour disqualifier
tous ceux qui portaient une parole un
peu contestataire ou qui voulaient aller
dans un autre sens. Et donc les
arguments c'étaient contrairement à
nous, ils savent utiliser d'autres
outils numériques
comme si si on avait donné aux enfants
des années 70 des iPhones, ils auraient
pas su les utiliser en de temps trois
mouvements comme le font les enfants de
2 ans aujourd'hui. Enfin, c'est quand
même des choses assez intuitives. Et
donc, on trouvait toutes sortes de
moyens pour nous dire que le niveau à
l'école finalement ne baissait pas.
Aujourd'hui, on voit des chiffres. Je
vous ai dit, moi j'aime j'aime bien
j'aime bien les chiffres. Donc quand on
regarde les chiffres, on remarque que le
niveau de mathématique des Français est
inférieur à celui des élèves d'Albanie.
Pizza. Ouais. Dans les tests PISA. Et
là, on se dit "Mais attendez, donc on
est la France, on est un pays
d'ingénieur, un pays magnifique. Quand
on regarde les réalisations, que ce soit
sous de Gaul, sous Pompidou, quand on
regarde toutes ces générations de
polytechniciens qui ont vraiment
construit la France telle qu'on la voit
aujourd'hui. Des générations
d'ingénieurs, j'ai cité polytechnique,
je veux pas être élitiste, il y a un
million d'autres écoles d' un million,
il y a des centaines d'autres écoles
d'ingénieurs qui sont excellentes sur le
territoire français qui ont contribué à
bâtir les ponts, les infrastructures
telles qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui, le
nucléaire, joyau français. On embrasse
d'ailleurs Bernard Ezambert. Bernard
Zemberbert, magnifique quand vous quand
vous lisez ce qu'il a écrit, ce qu'il a
laissé, la manière dont il a conseillé
Pompido, enfin en tout cas, c'est des
modèles, des modèles d'ingénieurs, de
serviteurs de l'État tel qu'on en fait
plus et qui ont existé. C'est une
génération, on voit, vous le citez, dans
les années 70. C'est magnifique de voir
cette bah je disais tout à l'heure
probité cette vision pour la France à à
à échéance très très longue. Ce qui ce
que ce qu' Zamber nous laisse, on en
bénéficie jusqu'à aujourd'hui. Et quand
on voit moi ça ça fait partie des choses
qui me touchent aussi de voir des hommes
qui ont mis 30 ans, 40 ans et eux et
leurs disciples à la suite pour bâtir
des bijoux, des joyaux et nous parfois
il nous faut 2 ans pour les détruire.
Quand on voit certaines qui nous nous
contemporain c'est pas nous j'imagine et
j'espère pas ceux qui nous écoutent ni
moi ni vous quand on voit nos
contemporains dans ce sens-là nous un
Emmanuel Macron un François Hollande
alors là on parle on parle des armes
donc parlons pour le coup du nucléaire
puisque ça fait partie aussi des des
sujets de déclin pour nous si on prend
notre politique énergétique on a donc
des hommes qui avaient une très grande
vision d'avenir pour la France qui qui
reposaient à la fois sur leur fine
connaissance
technique qui savait ce que c'était
l'énergie, qui comprenait ce que ça
voulait dire, qui savait sur quoi
reposer l'industrie, la géopolitique, de
la guerre économique, absolument tout ça
en plus. Qui savait sur quoi reposer la
croissance, qui comprenaient bien
l'intérêt d'avoir une énergie souveraine
parce qu'il se disait donc après on aura
une économie souveraine puisque tout
repose sur ça, sur ce joyau. Donc ils
construisent le nucléaire, ils mettent
des années, c'est des investissements
lourds et on voit qu'à cette époque de
Gaul le décide, Pompidou continue et met
en œuvre. D'ailleurs, c'est même lui qui
met en œuvre. Giscar continue, il fait
partie même de celui qui enfin de ceux
qui qui réalisent ce projet et puis euh
tous les autres vivent un peu sur euh la
Ouais, ils vivent sur le leg. Donc
euh bon, après tout c'est pas si mal. Il
y a des gens qui ont été des grands
penseurs, des grands visionnaires qui
nous ont légué à un héritage.
Si encore on s'était contenté de faire
fructifier cet héritage, de le garder,
je dis même pas d'être des génies et et
d'inventer d'inventer la suite. Mais
non, nos contemporains, donc pas nous,
nos contemporains se sont échinés à
détruire ce qui nous avait été légué. Et
quand on regarde pourquoi, et je pense
vraiment que l'histoire les jugera, j'ai
pas envie d'être grandocante ni lyrique,
mais je pense que l'histoire les jugera.
Quand on regarde les raisons pour
lesquelles ils ont abandonné ce
nucléaire, soyons concret. François
Hollande
de vote écologiste. Exactement. Non mais
si vous faites toutes les réponses, mais
c'est exactement ça. François Hollande
franchement pas stupide, c'est un bon
élève, il réussissait les concours assez
malin pour devenir président de la
République. Donc manifestement pas un
homme malin ou intriguant. Intrigant
sans doute. Il a beaucoup d'humour. Je
pense que le fait d'avoir de l'humour,
c'est aussi une des caractéristiques des
gens intelligents. Donc franchement, je
l'insulte pas. Pas qu' pas un homme où
on peut dire il est stupide.
Et pourtant, cet homme qui doit bien
voir ce que nous apporte le nucléaire,
énergie peu chère, décarbonée,
souveraine, qui nous donne un avantage
compétitif énorme vis-à-vis du reste de
l'Europe, vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne. Il
comprend bien, on en est économiquement.
Il arrive après les réformes Shroder, il
voit que la France décroche. En tout
cas, il a toutes les raisons du monde de
se dire "Je vais garder cet avantage."
Mais que veut-il faire ? un accord avec
les écologistes, le parti Europe
écologie les verts pour cet accord, donc
pour quelques sièges, pour quelques
visages dans ces ministères pour montrer
une forme, c'est toujours euh le la la
grande aspiration, le grand mythe de la
gauche pour montrer une forme d'union,
il veut faire venir des verres dans son
gouvernement et pour cet accord, il leur
donne le nucléaire. C'est le grand
sacrifice. Il leur offre sur un plateau
le nucléaire français donc bâti par des
générations de visionnaires. On a parlé
d'hommes qui étaient des grands
serviteurs de l'État à la tête de
l'État, mais il y a pas que des
ouvriers, des techniciens, des des
armées de volontaires, des grands
serviteurs du du grand dessin français.
un savoir-faire mis à la poubelle par un
homme, par une décision pour vous
montrer le le comment dire la l'aspect
concret de ce que cette parole
présidentielle a causé. Donc d'une part,
il dit il annonce le premier qu'on va
réduire la part du nucléaire dans le
mixe énergétique français. Si on
remontait un peu en amont, bien sûr,
Jospin avait déjà pris de mauvaise
décisions sur Super Phonix en matière de
fermeture, c'est clair. Mais là,
Hollande, on voit à mon sens une rupture
claire. Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que j'avais eu dans une autre vie, un
passé de de haut fonctionnaire. Il m'est
arrivé dans cette autre vie d'auditer le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique.
Et je m'apercevais lors de cette audit
qu'il y avait une sorte de de trou
générationnel parmi les ingénieurs qui y
travaillaient. Il y avait beaucoup de
gens de 40 ans, de 50 ans, même de 60
ans, très fort d'ailleurs, très
compétents. Mais très peu de mon âge, je
devais avoir 25 26 ans, très peu de gens
de 30 ans. Il faut pas réfléchir
longtemps pour comprendre pourquoi ce
tron. Imaginez, vous êtes ingénieur,
vous avez 23 ans, vous êtes dans votre
école d'anger, vous venez de réussir
polytechnique centrale, que sais-je,
vous êtes ingénieur, vous entendez le
président de la République dire que
l'objectif de la France, c'est de
réduire le nucléaire de x % à horizon 10
ans, 20 ans, de faire passer la la
production de nucléaire euh sous la
production de d'énergie euh dites
renouvelable.
Si vous entendez ça, vous êtes quelqu'un
de rationnel, vous voulez gagner votre
vie, vous voulez nourrir votre famille
dans 10 ans, vous voulez avoir un emploi
qui va pas être enfin qui va pas devenir
obsolète où il y aura un déboucher à la
fin de vos études. Donc vous vous dites
bah je veux pas être ingénieur en
nucléaire, il y a il n'y a aucun intérêt
à à prendre cette filière là. Et donc
part à l'étranger,
pire encore, ce serait pire mais
malheureusement on a plutôt formé des
générations d'ingénieurs spécialisés
dans la transition énergétique, les
énergies renouvelables. Alors, ce qu'il
y a peut-être de malheureux, c'est que
j'espère si on fait les bons choix en
France,
si les Français
et je pense que c'est en train d'être le
d'être le cas, sont qu'ils sont de plus
en plus lucides sur ces questions là, si
on fait les bons choix et qu'on prend la
bonne direction, ce sera plutôt eux qui
ont qui auront fait le mauvais choix par
la faute de politique intéressé, je le
répète, exclusivement par des accords
électoraux. Donc ces jeunes-là qui ne
sont pas devenus ingénieurs, on a toute
une génération perdue, toute une
génération sacrifiée. Donc quand vous
regardez dans les grandes boîtes qui
cherchent euh de l'ingénierie nucléaire
en fait même du soudeur hein. Exactement
des métiers les plus simples. Là j'ai
parlé des écoles d'ingé, on aurait pu
parler, c'est pour ça que je vous disais
toute une armée en fait. Il y a pas que
les ingénieurs et les polytechniciens,
il y a toute une armée de gens qui qui
répondent à tous les petits métiers
grâce au grâce auxquels le nucléaire
vit. Et donc quand vous regardez ce gâi,
il est dû à une seule chose, la parole
présidentielle qui a jeté à la poubelle
des dizaines d'années de travail.
Emmanuel Macron, il arrive que fait-il ?
Alors là, on aurait pu se dire
intelligent, inspecteur des finances,
après tout, il se target d'avoir une
grande vision Mozart de la finance, une
grande vision économique, stratégique.
Que fait-il ? Alors lui même chose, il
veut faire venir, vous vous souvenez,
Nicolas Hul à son gouvernement. Pourquoi
? Parce que comme tous les politiciens,
ce qu'il regarde, c'est les courbes de
popularité des politiques. Il regardent
pas autre chose. Il se dit pas "Est-ce
que Nicolas Ho est un homme de dossier ?
Est-ce qu'il va réussir à faire inventer
tel ou tel projet ?" Non, non, non.
Nicolas Ho super populaire, les Français
l'adorent, il le trouvent beau gosse,
ils aiment bien choya. Ouais, ils aiment
bien choya le shampoing ou l'émission ?
L'émission. Bon, je me fais la l'avocat
du diable. Il y a eu Fukushima,
des problèmes pour stocker euh la flotte
qui était censée refroidir le réacteur
qui avait cramé,
des retombé un peu partout, un choc à la
Tchernobyl. Euh, il s'est peut-être dit
que c'était intéressant d'avoir
quelqu'un qui pensait différemment.
Alors, quand c'est François Hollande, on
peut se dire ça, il est élu en 2012,
Fukushima, c'est 2011. Quand c'est
Emmanuel Macron, toutes les études par
la suite ont montré qu'au contraire,
c'était une situation pas délocalisable,
une situation géographique du Japon qui
est qui pouvait pas du tout être la même
en France sur une faille. Sur une faille
et que il y a des failles en France,
faut faire gaffe hein. Ouais, il y a des
failles en France. Je pense que c'est
pas précisément les endroits où on a mis
nos réacteurs. Donc on a montré, il y a
eu énormément d'études, il y a c'est
vrai, il y a eu une peur panique à ce
moment. D'ailleurs très intéressant sur
la manière, je fais une digression sur
la manière dont les politiques prennent
leur décision.
On est en 2011, vous l'avez dit, il y a
Fukushima, les instituts de sondage se
jettent dessus et il demandent aux
français pour ou contre la sortie du
nucléaire. Les Français ont peur. Ils
viennent de voir un événement atroce à
l'autre bout du monde. Il y a déjà des
chaînes d'information, on voit des
images, on se dit "Ah donc ça peut
arriver un tel accident et cetera". Les
Français se prononcent majoritairement
pour la sortie du nucléaire.
Et là, vous avez deux sortes de
politiques ou deux sortes de de de gens
qui réfléchissent au bien commun, au
bien public. Je me souviens à cette
époque pour parler de quelqu'un que je
connais, Éric Zemour dit "Si je puis me
permettre, il y a une erreur d'analyse.
Les médias ont mis dans la tête des
Français que c'était de la faute du
nucléaire alors que c'est de la faute de
de circonstances géologiques qu'on ne
retrouve pas en France. Et chez nous,
les centrales sont sûres. Ce n'est pas
un événement qui peut être dupliqué, qui
n'arrivera pas chez nous. Donc, il ne
faut pas sortir du nucléaire. ça n'est
pas une raison. Cette émotion vive du
moment ne doit pas nous conduire à faire
un mauvais choix qui va nous engager sur
les 100 prochaines années. Et je me
souviens de tout le reste de la classe
politique et notamment cette image avait
beaucoup tourné. C'était Marine Le Pen
qui était interrogée, je crois par
France Interre à l'époque et elle dit
"Bien sûr, il faut sortir du nucléaire,
il faut une sortie progressive du
nucléaire. On est en 2011 et à ce
moment-là que se dit-elle ? Je pense pas
qu'elle soit antinucléaire au fond
d'elle, mais elle se dit puisque les
Français se sont positionnés contre hier
dans tel institut de sondage, il faut
accompagner l'émotion. C'est de la
suputation là. Et très souvent, oui,
tout à fait. C'est de la supputation. Je
pense qu'elle n'est pas antinucléaire.
Après, il y en l'un ou l'autre, hein.
Soit on pense qu'elle était sincère et
donc elle est elle est en fait
antinucléaire cachée, elle est
redevenue, soit on pense que c'était
plutôt un réflexe politicien, c'est ma
supputation et qu'elle a réagi en
fonction du sondage. Et ça me fait
penser à à je pense un travers qui est
trop partagé dans la classe politique,
c'est le fait de prendre ces décisions
exclusivement par rapport au sondage du
moment. Gestionné, hein. Ouais.
Évidemment, le peuple a toujours le
dernier mot. Évidemment, c'est le peuple
qui décide. Mais si on prend la
politique comme à comme ayant pour
simple objectif de lire des sondages et
de savoir quoi dire après, tous les
partis se ressemblent. On est tous les
mêmes, on est tous des perroquets et
personne ne se dit que son objectif
c'est de convaincre les gens. Moi, je
vois exactement la politique comme un
sens inverse. Je peux parfois sur
certains sujets avoir l'air en décalage
avec l'opinion publique. Prenez des
choses qui vont pas être tout de suite
populaires, qui vont pas me valoir les
bravos et les ourats de la foule, mais
me dire que mon objectif, c'est de faire
pencher l'opinion publique vers une
position que moi j'estime être la plus
favorable au bien public, au bien
commun. Je peux vous couper ? Je vous en
prie. Merci. Vous avez une clé de
lecture sur le déroulement du monde.
Quelle est votre clé de lecture ? Votre
clé de voûte ? pour analyser tout ce qui
se passe, tout ce qui est connecté à
l'énergie, à l'économie.
Quelle est votre clé de voûte qui vous
permet de faire de la prospective, de
l'anticipation pour déterminer un cap ?
C'est une question qui est qui est très
très large. Je dirais que j'en aurais
j'en ai plusieurs selon les sujets. Une
clé de voûte, c'est tout petit. La
première réponse, ce serait l'intérêt de
la France, c'est-à-dire avec quel prisme
je regarde l'actualité, le le le sens où
vous disait où vous disiez où va la
France, où va le monde. La première
manière dont je le regarde, c'est
l'intérêt du pays, du pays pris dans son
ensemble. C'est-à-dire que ce que je
refuse, c'est euh si j'essaie de
regarder les autres grilles de lecture,
les manières dont les autres étudient
tout ça. Ce que je refuse, c'est
l'intérêt politicien du moment, ce que
j'étais en train de dire. Ce que je
refuse, c'est la lutte des classes. Je
déteste cette vision des choses et cette
grille de lecture. Je m'y reconnais
absolument pas. Je pense que ça existe
un peu quand même. Ça veut pas dire que
ça n'existe pas. De dire qu'on ne veut
pas étudier le monde entier et prendre
ses décisions en fonction de la lutte
des classes, c'est-à-dire qu'on refuse
d'opposer les Français les uns aux
autres sur cette grille-là. En revanche,
ce serait faux de dire que ça n'existe
pas. Ça existe. Mais je crois qu'il faut
pas flatter les gens dans cet instinct
là. Il faut pas ni flatter les riches
dans la sécession qu'il pourrait avoir
envie de faire, ni flatter les classes
plus populaires dans la détestation de
gens qui ont réussi. C'est ce que je
refuse. C'est-à-dire que je pense que
c'est une tension qui est toujours
latente dans toute société à toute
époque et qu'il faut s'efforcer quand on
fait de la politique, quand on réfléchit
au bien commun. Ça c'est pas forcément
dans la politique, ça peut être dans les
médias, ça peut être dans l'écriture ou
peu importe quand on enseigne. Il faut
s'efforcer
d'essayer de faire sortir les gens de ce
seul travers là parce qu'à mon avis, il
ne conduit à rien de bien à la fin pour
le pays. Si je reviens sur l'aspect
sondage, comment on prend ces décisions,
ça me fait penser à une phrase de
condorsé qui disait "Les gens ne votent
pas pour moi pour que je dise ce qu'ils
pensent, mais pour que je dise ce que je
pense". Et c'est exactement ce que
j'essaie d'appliquer, c'est-à-dire sur
chaque sujet de me dire qu'est-ce que
moi j'en pense si les Français sont
totalement aligné, c'est les Français
d'aujourd'hui tel qu'exprimé dans un
sondage, donc déjà avec les biaiss qu'on
qu'on peut connaître. Mais si les
Français d'aujourd'hui sont parfaitement
alignés, c'est parfait. J'ai le
sentiment d'être en osmose, on pense la
même chose et c'est très bien. C'est pas
pour autant que je vais pas me remettre
en question sur tel ou tel sujet. On
peut tous se tromper en même temps. CF
le nucléaire.
Si à l'inverse, je vois que je suis en
décalage avec l'opinion publique du
moment, je vais me dire "Bah, il faut
convaincre. L'objectif c'est de
convaincre." Donc en 2011, je pense que
la classe politique, pour refermer ce
sujet, la classe politique n'a pas
souhaité faire ce travail, ne s'est pas
dit, "Nous, on a quelques données qui
pourraient nous permettre de dire qu'en
France, il y a pas les mêmes risques,
que le nucléaire est un joyau, qu'il
faut continuer parce que c'est l'avenir
qui se joue." Ils ont eu au contraire
des réflexes politiciens. Ils ont surfé
sur cette émotion du moment pour
satisfaire les verres qui eux avaient un
objectif. de décroissance un objectif
politique personnel contre le nucléaire
qui leur était propre et donc ils ont
saordé la filière François Hollande le
1er Emmanuel Macron a suivi il aurait pu
revenir sur l'engagement de François
Hollande de fermer Faenheim c'est lui
qui l'a fait Édouard Philippe qui se
présente aujourd'hui comme quelqu'un là
encore qui a une grande vision gauliste
et cetera et qui disait à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est facile de
retrouver les images je suis fière
d'être celui qui ferme la centrale de
Fessenheim centrale d'ailleurs quand on
la visite on voit à quel point tout
était neuf, rénové, à quel point ils
avaient fait attention précisément aux
enjeux de de sécurité civile. ce sont
eux qui la ferment et puis Patatra
soudain ils se rendent compte s'est
passé la même chose aux États-Unis avec
Biden d'ailleurs qui s'était soumis au
désidérat des écolos en disant on va
arrêter le nucléaire et puis soudain
l'actualité montre de plus en plus que
l'avenir repose sur l'énergie que
quanden matière d'énergie c'est le
nucléaire qui peut nous permettre d'être
les plus compétitifs de continuer à
créer de la croissance ce qui n'est plus
donné dans notre univers et vu la rareté
de ressources et cetera et Donc Biden
décide en prenant compte des des de la
nécessité pour les États-Unis d'être à
la pointe en matière d'intelligence
artificielle, c'est déjà ça le sujet,
décide de remiser sur le nucléaire.
Emmanuel Macron, vous vous souvenez, on
est au début de la présidentielle 2022,
fait un
enfin c'est un revirement total un
retournement de veste. Exactement. Et
soudain, c'est euh le plus pronucléaire
des des pronuclires. Vous l'avez entendu
quand il a fait son sommet de l'IA dire
plug baby plug en essayant de reprendre
la blague américaine en parlant du
nucléaire. Ça veut dire quoi plug ?
Connect. Donc euh il essae de se
rattraper. Je pense qu'il y a un truc
assez énervant pour parler trivialement
pour ceux qui regardent. C'est cette
impression qui retourne sa veste de
manière spectaculaire mais sans sans
sans aucune transition et sans le
moindre à coupa. Moi, j'aurais aimé en
tant que citoyens conduite
introspective.
Ah, bonne question. Je sais pas dire à
sa place. Je suis pas son son
confesseur. Je sais pas s'il se confesse
mais je sais pas dire à sa place. Dieu
Oui, un dieu. Dieu ou un autre ou euh Ah
non, un dieu. Dieu le seul et l'unique.
Tu n'auras pas d'autres dieux que moi,
dit le premier commandement. Le seul le
seul et l'unique. C'est OK.
Euh et donc vous avez un Macron qui fait
un revirement spectaculaire et qui à
aucun moment ne donne cette minuscule
satisfaction au peuple français de dire
"J'avoue, je me suis trompée." Voilà, il
y a 4 ans, il y a 5 ans, je suis arrivée
à l'Élysée,
je parlais avec Nicolas Huld, certains
m'avaient convaincu, on essayait de me
dire que et cetera, je me suis trompée.
Ça n'était pas l'intérêt du pays. Donc
je change d'avis. Je vous Imaginez s'il
nous avait juste dit ça. Franchement, ni
vous ni moi n'aurions pu dire quoi que
ce soit. On se serait dit, il nous a
fait perdre du temps. Bon, c'est du
gâchi, il a perdu 5 ans, quel dommage et
cetera. Il a poursuivi les erreurs de
son prédécesseur. Ça va nous coûter des
milliards. Ça ça nous coûte des
milliards. Et le pire, c'est qu'on
continue parce que là, je vous dis qu'il
a fait un revirement spectaculaire dans
la parole, mais dans les faits, on
continue. Les 110 milliards d'euros par
an pour la transition écologique, pour
financer des éoliennes, pour pas enfin
pour pour c'est c'est les les batteries
qu'on veut maintenant enfouir et cetera.
Ça nous coûte 110 milliards d'euros par
an tout simplement. Quand on regarde
l'ADEM, donc la fameuse agence pour la
transition écologique qui veut nous
apprendre à tous à à vivre et respirer,
je dis ça parce que vous vous souvenez
que quand on a eu la grande crainte de
ne pas passer l'hiver, vous vous
rappelez, on croyait qu'il y aurait des
blackout et cetera en en 2023, euh
Emmanuel Macron avait dit "Les Français
n'auront", parfois il y a des choses
tellement folles qu'on les oublie un peu
après. Il avait dit "Les Français ne
doivent pas mettre leur chauffage à plus
de 19°gr chez eux." Éteindre le wifi met
un col roulé. Vous vous rappelez ? et
Bruno Lemer s'était pointé en colle
roulé à la télévision. Incroyable l'état
qui se prend pour notre père et notre
mère en même temps. Et donc Emmanuel
Macron, lui, il sait mieux que tout le
monde. Lui, il sait que c'est 19°gr.
C'était comme au moment du Covid, il
savait quel commerce était essentiel et
lesquels ne l'était pas. Il sait mieux
que nous. Donc lui, c'est 19°gr, pas 1
degré de plus, pas un degré de moins.
Invraisemblable. Donc cette l'ADEM,
c'est la définition de cet état nounou
qui vous fait remplir des documents
administratifs de 19 pages pour vous
offrir une aide. au reprisage des
chaussettes, à la rénovation de vos
objets. C'est pas plus mal ça. Il faut
envoyer les stages en entreprise à
Madagascar, ils vont en prendre plein de
trucs. Ah bah c'est pas plus mal. Ça
fait une fraude terrible. Et vous pour
vous offrir ça fait une fraude ?
Pourquoi ça fait une fraude ? parce que
le contrôle est fait qu'à postériori.
Donc vous par exemple, vous allez
envoyer un document où vous allez dire
"Vous me vous me devez 50 € parce que
selon votre recommandation au lieu
d'acheter de nouvelles chaussettes, je
les ai fait repriser." Ça en fait l'idée
enfin la l'idée derrière pour essayer
quand même d'expliquer ce qu'ils font.
C'est des chaussettes françaises qu'on
peut faire repriser ou c'est des
chaussettes allemandes ? Ah mais
n'importe quoi. En fait la la seule idée
derrière c'est de dire il faut pas
pousser à la consommation. Donc on est
dans un monde où euh les objets se se
enfin il y a une obsolescence des
objets. Donc vous allez être poussé à
acheter un nouvel objet. Et on se dit
c'est pas écologique d'acheter un nouvel
objet. Donc puisque ça n'est pas
écologique d'acheter un nouvel objet, on
va essayer de vous inciter à plutôt
réparer ce que vous avez qu'à en acheter
un nouveau. C'est pas plus mal. Mais par
comment on va vous y aider ? Comment on
va vous y inciter ? On va vous y inciter
par des primes. C'estàd le pire
mécanisme si on va un tout petit peu sur
les finances publiques, la prime, la
subvention, je pense que c'est le pire
mécanisme. L'État français en est tout à
fait friant. C'est ce qu'ils appellent
une politique de pouvoir d'achat qui n'a
jamais renforcé le pouvoir d'achat de
quiconque. Et pourquoi c'est n'importe
quoi ? c'est qu'on va vous prendre votre
argent dans une poche et on va vous dire
qu'on vous le rend dans une autre poche.
Donc vous, on va vous taxer énormément
et après on va vous dire "Mais
attention, si vous refaites faire vos
chaussettes, au lieu d'acheter de
nouvelles chaussettes, on va vous donner
un petit billet." Mais entre-temps,
l'argent qu'on vous aura pris dans une
poche, on pourra jamais vous le rendre
de manière équivalente puisqu'il faut
des fonctionnaires pour vérifier si vous
y avez droit. Il faut des fonctionnaires
pour lire la déclaration que vous avez
envoyée. Il faut des fonctionnaires pour
vérifier si vous avez fraudé. Ensuite,
il faudra des juges pour vous condamner
si vous avez effectivement fraudé et
cetera et cetera. Donc tout un cycle par
lequel en réalité votre argent se
détruit. Il y a pas de c'est pas c'est
pas un jeu à somme nulle. On vous prend
pas 5 € pour vous rendre 5 €. On va vous
prendre 5 €. Il y a 2 € qui seront
détruits. Je dis un chiffre au hasard,
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un calcul
que je viens de faire. Il y a 2 € qui
seront détruits par la puissance
publique et ensuite on vous on vous en
fera semblant de vous en offrir trois.
Donc en réalité on vous achète avec
votre argent. Vous êtes trop vous êtes
trop bon. Mon bon état. Vous êtes trop
magianime avec nous. Exactement. On vous
achète avec votre propre argent, ce qui
pour moi est en réalité la la pire
manière possible de faire croire au
peuple que l'État est bon comme vous le
disiez et magnanime et maganime alors
qu'en réalité on est le peuple le plus
taxé du monde. On le répétera jamais
assez. Faut quand même dire aux gens que
chaque année on paye 1300 milliards de
prélèvement obligatoire. 1300 milliards
de prélèvement obligatoires.
C'est-à-dire que là, au bout de 20
minutes de cette interview, les gens
auront payé 50 millions d'euros
d'impôts. Quel sont quels sont le quel
est le volume d'intérêt de la dette
française ? Le volume d'intérêt de la
dette française, ça doit être à hauteur
de 300 milliards. C'est ce qui va
dépasser tout budget confondu, tous les
budgets de toutes les administrations
publiques. Vous jouez aux échecs un
petit peu. J'apprends de plus en plus.
Jou au jeux de go ? Vous êtes classé aux
échecs ? Non, pas du tout. Je commence.
Vous jouez au jeu de GO ? Non. Quelle
est quelle est votre clé de voûte, votre
prisme de lecture pour l'avenir de la
France ? C'est l'énergie. Pourquoi
l'énergie ? Si c'est l'énergie et les
ressources, où on en est, où on va ?
Quels vont être les jeux de prédation
des États ? La course à l'échalotte en
Europe, la course à l'échalotte entre la
Chine et les États-Unis et nous au
milieu énormément de question. On rentre
un peu dans les sujets économiques et
géopolitiques et guerre économique. OK.
Clé de voû énormément de questions. Euh
ma clé de voûte, alors je dirais pas que
c'est exclusivement l'énergie. Je vous
ai parlé de l'intérêt de la France,
d'une vision du bien public. Je pense
que c'est l'énergie, c'est essentiel
parce que c'est ce quoi, à mon sens,
notre prospérité repose. Euh notre
croissance, le fait de pouvoir continuer
de faire tourner une industrie, sujet
qu'on a beaucoup abandonné en France. Je
crois que c'est sur l'industrie que
repose la majeure partie de la valeur
ajoutée d'une nation, que c'est quand
quand on a commencé à voir la France
désindustrialisée, qu'on a beaucoup
perdu en croissance. Si on regarde
d'autres effets catastrophiques de la
désindustrialisation,
on observe que c'est en général dans les
territoires les plus désindustrialisés
que l'emploi dans la fonction publique
territoriale a le plus explosé.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu une
corrélation entre des gens qui ont perdu
leur emploi dans des emplois vraiment
productifs. Je dis pas que tous les
fonctionnaires sont improductifs. Dans
des emplois pour le coup vraiment
productif dans l'industrie. C'est les
emplois qui ont la plus forte valeur
ajoutée qui en plus permettent la plus
forte ascension sociale. On commence
ouvrier en bas de l'échelle. On peut
évoluer d'année en année. Donc si c'est
ce qui permettait de se réaliser dans
son travail en réalité avec parfois de
très très beaux pas. on a parlé du
nucléaire à une économie qui repose
beaucoup sur l'État, beaucoup sur
l'emploi public et donc cette très forte
corrélation entre territoire
désindustrialisé et collectivité
publique qui se mettent à embaucher
énormément euh parfois à la discrétion
des élus donc qui embauche parce qu'il
en a besoin, parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
chômage et cetera et pour le coup ce qui
n'est pas une économie vraiment
productive. Donc ça l'énergie pourquoi
c'est important pour ces raisons-là.
J'ai évidemment euh beaucoup d'autres
sujets que je considère être essentiel
pour l'avenir de la France. Alors, on
s'arrête juste. Ouais. En gigaw,
la France, elle produit combien à
l'année ou elle est capable de produire
combien à l'année ? Je peux pas, j'ai
pas envie de dire de bêtises. Dites-moi.
Non, non, non. Je pose des questions,
j'y réponds pas. Ah, dommage. Au moins,
je l'aurais mémorisé. L'Europe, non,
désolé. 600 1800, j'ai pas le chiffre.
La Chine,
le double.
Les États-Unis, pareil.
En terme de projet, l'Europe, elle en
est où ? En terme de projet économique,
projet énergétique. Ah, en terme de
projet énergétique, on en a beaucoup
parlé. Énorme erreur de l'Allemagne
d'abord d'avoir fait le choix des
centrales à charbon, d'avoir fait le
choix de la dénucléarisation sur Angela
Merkel. Je pense que là aussi, elle sera
comptable au regard de l'histoire, que
de plus en plus, on est en train de
sortir du myth Merkel. Il y a eu un
grand mythe Merkel au sein de l'Union
européenne et je pense qu'on en est
revenu en s'apercevant des conséquences
de ces actes. Donc énorme erreur de
l'Allemagne et comme souvent l'Allemagne
nous a fait payer nous ses propres
erreurs. C'est-à-dire que parce que elle
s'était privée de cet avantage
compétitif, elle a joué
stratégiquement au sein des instances
européennes pour empêcher que la France
puisse elle bénéficier de son atout
nucléaire. Donc la France, l'Allemagne a
voulu faire payer à la France. Très dans
le détail. D'accord. Donc si vous prenez
le lobbying antinucléaire allemand, le
lobbying antinucléire allemand. Donc si
vous prenez, moi je vais essayer de
faire de vous donner des exemples
concrets d'histoire qui se passent au
sein de l'Union européenne. Donc déjà au
Parlement européen, je siège au sein
d'une commission qui s'appelle ITRE,
donc c'est industrie, nouvelle
technologie, recherche et énergie. Et au
sein de cette commission, vous vous
apercevez déjà qu'elle est euh trustée
par les Allemands. Ils y sont euh
trustés en français, ils y sont presque
majoritaires, noyautés. Donc ils y sont
ils enfin il y a il y a énormément il y
a énormément d'allemands au sein de
cette commission. Ils investissent
énormément le sujet. Euh ils comprennent
forcément parfaitement les enjeux
industriels là où les Français ont été
très idéalistes, ont cru à la fin des
usines, ont cru à l'économie de service
et cetera. Arrêtez de dire les français,
dites plutôt la upper classe ou la
classe supérieure qui a été envoyée là.
Les français en général, ils ont du pif.
Ouais. Ouais. Quand quand je dis les
Français dans ce contexte là, c'est pour
dire au sein des institutions, vous avez
les Allemands d'un côté, c'est pas le
peuple allemand qui nous fait payer,
c'est les Allemands de la même manière,
la classe dirigeante. Et donc ceux qui
représentaient les Français au sein de
ces institutions européennes se sont
beaucoup laissés faire. Donc à mon
échelle au Parlement européen, je le
vois, les Allemands sont très mobilisés,
mobilisés aussi pour rester les leaders
économiques du continent. Il voi qu'ils
sont très mal emploi. Depuis la guerre
en Ukraine. Les enjeux énergétiques sont
pour eux colossaux. Il dépendent
énormément du gaz russe. On a vu ce que
ça avait euh suscité chez eux comme
explosion des factures d'électricité euh
des factures d'énergie au sens large
pour leur industrie. Euh ce qui les met
dans le rouge. Et donc ils comprennent
qu'ils sont en train de payer les
conséquences de leur mauvais choix. Ils
se sont mis eux-mêmes dans la main des
Russes pour le gaz. Ils ont abandonné
leur atout nucléaire. Ils nous ont
presque forcé et ils auraient pu arriver
à abandonner le nôtre. On s'est repris
en main récemment. Ça prendra du temps à
produire ses effets mais on s'est repris
en main récemment. Pour vous donner euh
un exemple de euh de de comment ce
lobbying peut se jouer au sein de
l'Union européenne, on va citer le nom
de la présidente de la Commission
européenne, il parle il parle de
lui-même. Ursula Van Derleyen euh
allemande euh qui qui était une très
bonne ministre de la défense, je crois
bien. Non. Ouais, en plus bonne qui a
laissé un très très bon souvenir. Euh
donc allemande qui on peut le regarder
dans plusieurs décisions, on pourra
rentrer dans le détail si vous voulez ou
s'il y a besoin d'étayer ça, mais qui
défend les intérêts allemands, on peut
le voir dans presque chacune de ces
décisions et pas l'intérêt général
européen comme ils disent. Euh et donc à
la tête de cette commission par le
passé, vous avez un homme qui s'appelle
José Emmanuel Barroso et qui parce qu'il
était à ce poste-là, bah par définition
presque, défendait les intérêts
allemands parce qu'ils sont les plus
organisés. Il faut comprendre que
l'Allemagne a une politique de
ressources humaines au sein de l'Union
européenne qui est pour le coup vraiment
intelligente. Quand ils font des choses
bien, il faut le dire, ils envoient leur
meilleur. Donc ils vont envoyer les
meilleurs avocats, les meilleurs
négociateurs, ceux qui ont l'intérêt
national allemand le plus chevillé au
corps et qui vont aller au sein des
institutions vraiment pour se bagarer.
Les Italiens font la même chose. Très
malin, très fort. Ils ont inventé la
politique he vous me direz c'est maavel
c'est c'est c'est eux qui nous qui ont
séjourné c'est la classe. Voilà c'est
exactement c'est exactement ça. J'allais
y venir. Les italiens font la même
chose. Plus étonnant peut-être pour nous
les Danois font la même chose. Très fort
extrêmement fort. Ils négocient tout
pied à pied. Encore une fois ils
envoient leurs meilleurs négociateurs.
Des armées d'avocats, des types qui ont
été pour le coup dans le privé pendant
longtemps qui ont de très très bons
réflexes. Des des haut fonctionnaires en
plus des haut fonctionnaires vraiment.
former cortiquer là pour défendre le
Danemark. Et pour vous donner quelques
exemples, ils arrivent à négocier sur
chacun des traités ce qu'on appelle des
optout. Donc le fait de dire on dérogera
à tel ou tel article parce que cet
article met en cause tel intérêt
national parce que je sais pas par
exemple si on si on sort de lieu et
qu'on va sur la CEDH, ils arrivent à
négocier que tel article de la CEDH
contrevient à leurs intérêts ou à leur
politique migratoire et que par
conséquent ils veulent pas le respecter.
Ils négocient ça et tout le monde le
leur accorde. les Italiens de la même
manière, les meilleurs, les meilleurs au
fonctionnaires qui vont aller négocier
par exemple sur tel texte, ils vont dire
"Bah vous avez écrit que ça devait
entrer en vigueur en 2027 mais pour nous
2027 c'est beaucoup trop tôt. On on le
signe que si ça sera en 2030." Et ils
ont des moyens de pression. Pas
vraiment. En fait, c'est le simple fait
de demander et c'est là où j'allais en
venir, c'est qu'en réalité nous, on est
une victime consentante, nous les
Français. Pourquoi ? Qui est-ce qu'on
envoie nous ? Quels sont les
fonctionnaires que les Français envoient
? Bah tout simplement ceux qui le
veulent, ceux qui sont le plus
européistes parce que ce sont eux qui le
veulent, qui se passionnent pour vivre à
Bruxelles en réalité, à part des gens
passionnés par la matière et cetera. Ça
par le pognon, non ? Ouais, c'est c'est
ce sont des postes aussi qui sont bien
payés mais vous pouviez vous pourriez
trouver d'autres postes bien payés et
parfois même à à compéten égal, vous
pourriez aller dans le privé faire autre
chose. Donc il y a il y a quelque chose,
il y a une filière en France. En France,
les fonctionnaires qui vont représenter
nos intérêts à Bruxelles sont les plus
idéologues, les plus européistes qui en
arrivant et ils sont sincères parfois
dans leur dans leur démarche ont un seul
but, construire l'Europe. Donc si vous
leur dites il faut défendre les intérêts
français, il faut dire bah non si on
défend la France on narrivera pas à
trouver de compromis. Il faut qu'on soit
tous d'accord. Il faut faire avancer
l'Europe fédérale. Oui, tout à fait.
C'est sont vraiment des gens qui sont
européistes et qui qui y croient parfois
de bonne foi. D'ailleurs, vous vous
parliez d'argent, il y a sans doute des
gens qui ont un enterré mais je pense
que beaucoup sont de bonne foi, très
idéologues. C'est comme ça qu'on les a
formé. Et donc s'ils veulent aller
travailler au sein des institutions
européennes, pour eux c'est pour un
grand dessin construire l'Europe. Et
donc quand on leur dit mais là ça c'est
c'est pas totalement dans l'intérêt
français. Ils vont se dire bah peut-être
mais on doit être capable de faire un
compromis, il faut qu'on fasse une
concession aux autres et cetera. Et donc
malheureusement, on en vient à la
situation qu'on connaît chez nous. On
applique le droit européen de la manière
la plus stricte avec les contrôleurs les
plus les plus, j'allais dire virulents
mais les gardons le mot les plus
stricts. Euh que ce soit en matière de
droit de la PAC, donc sur l'agriculture,
que ce soit en matière industrielle, que
ce soit en matière énergétique, on en
parlait, on sur écologique en matière
écologique. Tout à fait.
Il y a ce ce mot qu'on a beaucoup
utilisé ces derniers temps et qui est
une réalité dramatique. On surtranspose
tous les textes. Donc la
surtransposition, alors là pour vous
donner un exemple pour connaître la
haute fonction publique,
vous avez l'Union européenne qui va
faire un texte sur tel ou tel sujet,
mettons l'interdiction des produits
phytosanitaires ou le Green Deal, peu
importe. Sur un sujet en particulier,
l'Union européenne va décider de sortir
une directive, un règlement. Que vont
faire les ministères ? Vous avez dans
tous les ministères une armée de haut
fonctionnaires
qui se sent investie de la mission de
rédiger chaque jour plus de normes. Si
vous voulez, on y reviendra parce que
c'est un faut bien justifier son
salaire. On y reviendra. C'est vraiment
un drame français. Donc vous avez ces
gens dans les ministères qui ont déjà
prêt en magasin si je puis dire des
centaines de normes prêtes à être sorti.
Donc quand il voit qu'un sujet arrive
que c'est l'Union européenne qui a
décidé de faire une directive bah ils
vont charger la barque. Ils vont se dire
alors ça arrive au Parlement pour être
transposé. Donc la transposition c'est
quand ça arrive du droit européen pour
être transposé dans le droit national.
Et à ce moment-là la plupart des pays
que je vous ai cité, l'Allemagne,
l'Italie, le Danemark, qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont faire ? Ils vont être malins, ils
vont se dire "Bon, en principe, ça
devrait être pour 2026, nous on va le
faire en 202 en 2027, on dira que nos
entreprises vont mettre du temps à
s'adapter, qu'on a pas envie de les
brusquer et cetera. Ou alors, ils vont
aller demander non mais tel produit
phytosanitaire, nous on a une
alternative qui nous paraît plutôt
acceptable sur le plan de la santé
publique. Est-ce qu'on peut pas plutôt
faire ceci et cela et cetera ?" Souvent,
très souvent, on va leur dire "Oui, a
même pas besoin de vous demandiez tout à
l'heure est-ce qu'ils ont des moyens de
pression ?" Très souvent, il y en a même
pas besoin. Il suffit de demander et en
France, qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
Bah pour vous citer des cas qui sont
déjà arrivés sur un produit
phytosanitaire, on va dire nous on
interdit non seulement lui mais toutes
ses alternatives pour montrer l'exemple.
Exactement. Pour être le bon élève de
l'Union européenne. Alors et ces bon
élèves ou c'est vous on les connaît
ceux-là, c'est le bon élève ou celui qui
suit la maîtresse en disant "Oh, tu es
belle maîtresse, tu es belle, je veux la
meilleure note". Ouais, c'est ça. Il y a
il y a ça, c'est exactement ça. Le
faillot si vous voulez. parle en terme
trivial, le faillot et il y avait une
phrase d'un ministre britannique qui
disait "Quand vous devez choisir une
personne à mettre à la tête d'une
institution internationale, choisissez
toujours un français parce que c'est le
seul qui ne défendra pas son intérêt
national."
Il dit ça, on est dans les années 30 je
dirais. Et à l'époque l'image c'est
Aristite Brand, vous savez très
universaliste, très idéaliste. La paix,
la paix et même si des gens devaient
nous attaquer, nous on demanderait quand
même la paix et cetera. Cet aspect très
idéaliste jusqu'au bout dans les idées.
Il y a une part de ça chez nous, c'est
on a c'est nous qui avons inventé les
lumières et cetera. Il y a une part
d'idéalisme qui parfois peut être
magnifique, conduire à des choses
magnifiques, mais qui parfois peut aussi
conduire à un effacement de soi, un
effacement de nos propres intérêts et
une vision qui qui se décorrelle des
intérêts en se disant finalement ce qui
compte c'est les idées et pas nos
intérêts nationaux. Et donc c'est ça ce
qui se joue en France, la
surtransposition en permanence, le fait
qu'on ajoute des contraintes aux
contraintes, qu'on les contrôle beaucoup
plus rigoureusement que les autres. Je
vous donne un dernier un dernier exemple
sur ce sujet. Euh je vous ai dit que
j'avais travaillé à la préfecture des
Pyrénées Atlantiques. J'étais dans le
Bern. On embrasse Jean la salle avec
Oui, tout à fait. J'étais avec Jean La
que que j'aime beaucoup, que j'ai vu à
l'action, à l'œuvre dans sa ville de
Lourd aussi. Euh et donc bah c'était
tout près d'ici, c'était tout près de
Lourd Josicher. On est en pleine
ruralité de montagne. Vous avez des
éleveurs de montagne à qui d'ailleurs on
avait imposé la réintroduction de l'ours
parce que monsieur Nicolas Hul voulait
caprise personnel qu'il y ait un ours
dans les Pyrénées. Donc ça le rassurait
d'imaginer qu'il y avait encore une
sorte de sauvagerie qui existait de ils
appellent ça biodiversité. Ce qui ce qui
contribue d'ailleurs à tuer et ce qui
contribue toujours malheureusement
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à tuer des centaines
de brebis, donc parfois à faire
disparaître ce qui fait vivre un
éleveur. Mais bon, je close ce sujet.
ruralité de montagne euh ruralité de
montagne à quelques mètres de l'Espagne.
Il a pas de frontière, c'est une
montagne donc ils sont collés à
l'Espagne. Et ces agriculteurs là qui
donc bénéficient de la Pâque parce
qu'ils sont en pleine ruralité de
montagne, territoire difficiles et
cetera, doivent remplir, vous
l'imaginez, des centaines de paperes.
Donc eux qui sont agriculteurs, qui se
réveillent déjà à 5h du matin parce
qu'ils sont éleveurs, qui se couchent à
minuit, qui ne peuvent pas prendre de
vacances parce que quand on a un
troupeau, on décide pas à quel moment il
va pas il va manger ou pas manger. On
doit être là toute la journée. C'est
difficile de se faire remplacer. C'est
quasiment impossible. C'est même pas en
fait en vérité, c'est même impossible de
payer des salaires parfois quand on a
cette vie-là. Et qui veut aller vivre en
pleine montagne ? Exactement. Qui veut
aller vivre en pleine montagne alors que
le RSA est supérieur au chiffres que
vous venez de dire ?
Donc une vie une vie une vie très
difficile mais en plus on fait deux
fonctionnaires, des avocats, des
fiscalistes puisqu'on leur demande de
d'être à même de remplir des dizaines et
des dizaines de pages eux-mêmes. Et le
pire, c'est la manière dont la France
voit la France, les haut fonctionnaires
qui se trouvent dans les ministères,
l'OFB, l'Office donc de la faune et de
la biodiversité,
la manière dont ils vont aller contrôler
le respect ou le non respect de ces
kilomètres de paperas qu'ils doivent
remplir. Pourquoi je vous disais qu'ils
étaient mitoyens à l'Espagne ? Parce que
c'est ce qui revenait à chaque fois que
je leur parlais. Il me disait quand en
Espagne, il y a des contrôleurs qui vont
pour parce qu'ils sont obligés, ils sont
dans l'Union européenne qui vont pour
vérifier le bien fondé des aides reçues,
ils vont dire aux agriculteurs "Ah
mince, fais gaffe là, tu as mis une
croix ici, c'est pas là que tu devais la
mettre. Euh remplis plutôt comme ça
parce que sinon ils vont te retirer ton
aide." Forme d'appui, ils se
comprennent, ils habitent dans les mêmes
villages, ils se connaissent, ils
connaissent la famille et cetera. En
France, c'est tout le contraire. Ils
arrivent armés. Vous avez entendu sans
doute ces ces ces ces histoires de
d'agents de l'OFB qui arrivent en arme
sur des exploitations agricoles devant
des fermiers qui se disent "Mais on va
être traité comme des délinquants".
Alors donc ils arrivent en arme et alors
là c'est telle case n'a pas été remplie.
L'autre va dire "Mais c'est un oubli. Ah
bah désolé, on va devoir vous couper
l'aide." Et puis après c'est des mois à
vivre sans aide, sans trésorerie et
cetera. Et donc un des agriculteurs
m'avait dit cette phrase. Il m'avait dit
"En Espagne, les contrôleurs sont
espagnols avant d'être contrôleur. En
France, ils sont contrôleur avant d'être
français." Je clôture sur ce sujet.
Je peux vous poser une question plus ?
Guerre économique ? Ouais, bien sûr. Là,
on voit que nos amis allemands, ce
fameux couple franco-allemand, donc nos
nos amis allemands
vont émettre 1000 milliards pour se
réarmer.
Ils vont aller sur les marchés.
À votre avis, la dette française, elle
va faire quoi face à de la dette
allemande sur les marchés ?
Elle va monter, elle va descendre, elle
sera aussi appréciée et aimée qu'elle
nit à l'heure actuelle. Est-ce que la
dette allemande va être moins chère et
la dette française plus chère ? Comment
ça va se passer ? C'est une très bonne
question. Si vous me l'aviez si vous me
l'aviez posé il y a il y a 4 ans, je
vous aurais dit c'est clair les
Allemands vont se rarmer faire la plus
grande armée d'Europe c'est ça ? Non, si
vous m'aviez demandé la valeur de la
dette allemande il y a 4 ans, je vous
aurais dit c'est un pays sûr où les
investissements sont sûrs. Les gens sont
sûrs du modèle économique allemand. Ils
le sont de moins en moins. Ils le sont
de moins en moins. Je vous ai parlé tout
à l'heure d'un des facteurs qui à mon
avis le facteur essentiel, c'est
l'énergie. Dépend du gaz russe. On voit
pas encore de perspective de sortie. On
se demande lequel des dirigeants
allemands dira "On continue avec le gaz
russe, on lève toutes les sanctions, on
veut faire repartir notre industrie." Je
sais pas si on le verra de notre vivant.
Peut-être, peut-être, qui sait ? Moi, je
sais pas. Euh le modèle économique
allemand est en train d'être euh sapé
dans ses fondements, euh y reposer en
grande partie sur une énergie
globalement abordable qui faisait
tourner leur industrie, de bonnes
réformes économiques entreprises déjà
dans les années 2000 alors que tout le
monde faisait l'inverse. Nous, on allait
au 35h et cetera. Tout le monde faisait
l'inverse. Ils ont fait de bonnes
réformes économiques et ils reposaient
surtout sur de l'exportation en Chine et
aux États-Unis. Et là quand il est passé
à l'euro c'était bien. C'était 11 1 1 et
1 € é= 1. Donc c'est ils étaient
parfaitement favorisés. Point pour eux
c'était génial. L'Europe c'était génial.
Enfin ils bénéficiaient de tout ça. Ils
étaient dans la meilleure zone
économique possible pour eux et ils
inondaient le marché chinois naissant.
la classe moyenne, la bourgeoisie
chinoise montante, il les inondai de
voitures allemandes. Vous vous rappelez
que les gens se moquaient d'angela
Merkel en disant "En fait ça est c'est
la VRP de Mercedes, elle passe sa vie en
Chine pour aller vendre ses voitures
allemandes. Il les vendait aussi sur le
marché américain. Et là, soudain, on
voit sous nos yeux tout ce modèle
s'effondrer, c'est-à-dire un marché
chinois qui va sans doute se fermer
parce qu'on les a laissé grandir. On les
a laissé grandir. On a fait des
transferts de technologie dans tous les
sens. Ils sont en train de fonder leur
propre industrie automobile. Je crois
pas qu'ils auront besoin de Mercedes
dans quelques années. Les Américains de
Donald Trump, que ça nous plaise ou non,
ont décidé de défendre leur propre
économie. Donald Trump, ce qui constate,
si on essaie de penser un tout petit peu
à sa place, il se dit "Dans mon pays,
c'est dur, il se dit "Dans mon pays, je
vois des Mercedes partout. Vous allez à
Berlin, bah vous voyez pas de voitures
américaines." Ça c'est rarissime.
Pourquoi ? Parce que nous, se dit-il, on
a globalement un marché de l'automobile
ouvert, peu de droits de douane ou assez
faible, alors que l'Union européenne se
cache derrière des droits tarifaires
faibles, donc une moyenne en chiffre
faible, mais met des barrières non
tarifaires extrêmement élevées en terme
de sécurité, en terme de normes à
respecter et cetera. Et donc lui se dit
en réalité on est arnaqué dans ce modèle
parce que on n'exporte pas de voitures
américaines chez eux mais on importe
énormément de voitures allemandes chez
nous. Donc en réalité son véritable
problème avec l'Europe c'est pas le
Bourbon, c'est pas nos viticulteurs,
c'est pas les spirituel, c'est pas le
beaujelet, c'est exactement c'est c'est
les voitures allemandes. C'est le
Camemberber, c'est ça ? Ouais, c'est pas
le Camemberber, c'est c'est les voitures
allemandes. Tout à l'heure, je vous ai
dit si vous voulez, je vous donnerai un
exemple concret de là où on voit que
Merkel est vraiment Merkel Vlen lapsus,
que Vlen est vraiment une allemande et
qu'elle prend ses ordres à Berlin et
qu'elle les prend pas ni à Bruxelles, ni
pour défendre l'intérêt général
européen. Quand Trump me dit je vais
mettre 25 % de droits de douane sur le
continent européen.
À ce moment-là, je me souviens, j'étais
au salon de l'agriculture et j'étais
avec les la filière des spiritu
et il me dis normal salon de
l'agriculture direct, j'ai une excuse et
il me disait intéressant surtout ne
parlez pas de nous quand vous parlez de
Trump et de guerre commerciale, ne
parlez pas de nous. Nous on pense qu'on
va passer derrière les mailles du filet.
Pourquoi ? Trump a pas intérêt à nous
faire la guerre. On est le premier
marché d'exportation du bourbon
américain. Il a pas envie d'engager le
bras de fer sur ce terrain. S'il
commence à dire "Je mets des taxes sur
les spiritueux français", bah nous on va
riposter de manière très classique en
disant "Bah, on double la taxe et on va
les mettre sur les spiritueux américains
et son secteur des spiritueux va dire
"Mais vous faites n'importe quoi,
c'était vraiment pas nous qui fallait
toucher. On ils sont notre premier
marché d'exportation."
Donc quand Trump dit 25 %, il donne une
moyenne. Il dit pas sur quel secteur, il
dit pas comment, il dit pas pourquoi.
Lui ce qu'il veut en réalité, je pense
qu'on a un peu compris, il veut tester
les limites. Il lance un chiffre, il
voit comment les gens viennent négocier,
ce qu'ils vont céder avant même qu'il
ait imposé quoi que ce soit. C'est ce
qu'il essaie de faire. Pareil avec la
Chine, les médias disent il recule, il
recule. Non, il teste les limites, il
teste le marché, il voit comment les
marchés des actions et des obligations
réagissent à ces décisions et puis après
il se dit "Le jour où je le feraiit
vraiment, il y aura une accoutumance et
il y aura peut-être des réactions un peu
moins dramatiques que la chute du marché
des actions et cetera." Donc Vanleen,
elle entend Trump qui dit 25 % de droits
de douan sur le continent européen. Que
fait ? le jour même, je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez, elle annonce 200 % de
droits de douane sur le Bbon américain
le jour même. Quand on voit ça et qu'on
est français, on se dit "Mais là, elle
se moque du monde." On sait qu'il visait
l'industrie automobile allemande et elle
tout de suite, qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?
Elle déplace le sujet en disant tout de
suite "Ah bah très bien, vous voulez
mettre 25 % en moyenne sur lieu" sans
même nous dire sur quel secteur, je mets
je double enfin je même plus je mets 100
200 % sur le bourbon américain. Et donc
là forcément les les les pauvres
producteurs français se disent "Bah
voilà, on va être le bouquin émissaire
de ce truc." On était censé ne pas être
touché. On était censé passer à travers
les mailles du filet et on a une
représentante allemande coup de sa
nationalité qui décide de déplacer le
sujet sur un autre secteur à mon sens
pour défendre les intérêts allemands
depuis peut-être Emmanuel Macron après à
la tête de l'Europe. Ouais.
Ouais. Est-ce que je peux vous couper ?
Revenons à notre ami allemand
qui va avoir la plus grosse armée, la
plus puissante armée conventionnel
d'Europe
avec un modèle économique qui risque
d'être compliqué mais ils vont avoir la
capacité d'émettre de la dette parce
qu'ils sont à combien d'endettement ? 60
70 % Ouais, c'est ça. Donc ils vont
combler leur lacune énergétique par de
l'énergie magique produit avec de la
dette. Ils vont se réarmer
et ensuite ils vont avoir une économie
moribonde
mais ils seront armés.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer
déjà copains copains avec les Allemands,
avec les les Polonais qui veulent la
même chose qui ont déjà une armée
extrêmement puissante les Polonais ?
Oui. Déjà on n'est pas obligé de
regarder en spectateur c'est-à-dire
qu'on n'est pas obligé d'attendre qu'ils
aient réellement mis en œuvre leur plan.
Je pense que voilà, on peut faire
confiance aux Allemands quand ils nous
disent qu'ils vont mettre un plan à
exécution. Donc je pense qu'ils le
feront et qu'ils le feront sérieusement.
Comment en tirer en avantage en tant que
français ? Je pense vraiment que la
période qui s'ouvre euh ouvre des
opportunités qui peuvent être immenses
pour la France si on sait les saisir. Je
crois avoir compris que ça se passera
pas soit Emmanuel Macron. Fa envahir
l'Allemagne tout de suite. Non non non
pas du tout. Ça veut dire qu'il faut
tirer profit de ce que Trump est en
train de dire à l'Europe. À mon sens,
Trump c'est l'Amérique éternel mais sans
masque. C'est-à-dire qu'il est en train
de dire haut effort fort ce que tous ces
prédécesseurs ont voulu avant lui,
c'est-à-dire se désengager du continent
européen, considérer que l'Europe était
des picassettes qui se nourrissaient sur
eux sans vouloir payer leur propre
défense, qui essayaient de profiter de
l'OTAN pour bénéficier du parapluie
américain mais sans contribuer. Depuis
Obama, on pense ça. Et depuis Obama, les
États-Unis veulent un désengagement de
l'Europe, avent appelé le grand pivot,
se retourner vers la Chine en se disant
"Nous, nos intérêts stratégiques sont
plutôt là-bas et contre eux, sont plutôt
dans le Pacifique que vers
l'Atlantique." Donc se tourner pourquoi
? Parce que votre lecture sur ce
basculement. Ma lecture c'est qu'ils ont
considéré le continent européen comme un
protectorat depuis laissez tomber les
Européens, ils sont cuits. Il y a 1600
GW à l'année. Pas pas pas pour moi. Moi
justement, je me bat pour qu'on soit pas
cuit. Mais non mais chacun a le droit
d'avoir ses lunettes roses. Mais vous
aussi lunettes moi. Mais vous vous
battez pour ça. On fait une chaîne en
français avec un public français. On
essaie de les éduquer, de continuer à
apporter
prendre. C'est oui bien sûr que c'est
vrai. Vous vous battez et c'est pour ça
que tout à l'heure je disais les gens se
battent à leur manière et il y a pas que
la politique hein. Moi c'est pas ce que
je faisais, c'est tout récent. vous à
mon sens, vous êtes aussi un des
combattants qui se bat pour l'intérêt de
la France, l'intérêt de de géopolitique,
stratégique, économique et cetera. Donc,
on se bat tous pour ça. Parfois, on peut
être un peu dépité quand on voit le le
la pente que ça prend. Qu'est-ce que
pour la France ? mon temps euh mon
énergie euh
le d'un point de vue plus matériel et
sans doute plus futile, mais euh euh une
situation financière que j'aurais pu
avoir par ailleurs. Euh je démarrais une
carrière euh
bah c'était tracé quoi. Je sortais dans
la botte de l'ENA, j'étais magistrate à
la Cour des comptes. Bah vous connaissez
la suite pour des parcours comme cela.
Donc j'étais tranquille, si on peut dire
euh ma tranquillité parce que parfois on
n'est pas tranquille quand on est dans
ce dans ce monde-là. Euh sans vouloir
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé en 2022,
mais j'ai vécu avec les paparadis en bas
de chez moi tous les jours un à
harcèlement véritablement harcèlement.
Donc ça ça je pense que je suis prête à
le sacrifier parce que je pense que ça
en vaut la peine. Donc on n'est pas
forcé de regarder l'Allemagne se
réarmée, la Polène serait armée sans
rien faire. On a les on a les moyens
chez nous. Vous avez précisé tout à
l'heure la plus grande armée
conventionnelle. Bah nous on a un atout
qu'ils n'ont pas et qu'ils n'auront pas.
C'est le nucléaire. C'est notre atout.
Ils n'auront pas la bombe nucléaire.
Quand on voit quand on voit Emmanuel
Macron
discuter avec les Polonais. Euh ouais,
je sais ce que vous allez dire. Euh sur
euh sur ce point-là. Donc Emmanuel
Macron, on lui fait pas confiance à
chaque fois qu'il parle de partage parce
qu'on se dit finalement il a pas assez
de comment dire d'épaisseur dans son
dans son dans son nationalisme. Je enfin
le mot le mot jeux Oui. Disons quand il
a pas de laure de pas demander à nos
assemblées de légiférer autour de ça de
de stocker nos bons nucléaires en
Pologne ou d'aller mettre ça sur des
avions en Pologne. Vous avez remarqué
qu'il avait déjà un petit peu reculé là
dans son émission récente. Il recule, il
avance, on connait tout, je suis
d'accord avec vous. On lui fait pas
confiance. De toute façon, je pense
qu'il ne se passera rien dans ces deux
prochaines années. Je pense qu'il a pas
les moyens, il a pas les manettes, il a
pas la légitimité. Je peux me tromper
mais je pense que de ce point de vue-là,
il se passera pas grand-chose. En
revanche, je vois ce que nous ouvre
comme perspective historique l'élection
d'un Donald Trump. Je disais tout à
l'heure, c'est l'Amérique éternelle sans
masque. Il dit en réalité ce que
disaient tous les autres avant lui et je
pense que le fait qu'il le disent peut
nous permettre nous d'enfin ouvrir les
yeux au reste du continent. Quand je
vois que les Belges, les Italiens et les
Allemands continuent d'acheter des F35
après l'élection de Donald Trump, je me
dis que c'est sans doute nous qui avons
mal fait les choses et qui n'avons pas
su leur expliquer cette histoire de
devenir nous la France le protecteur
entre guillemets, le grand frère ou le
parapluie comme l'ont été les Américains
pour notre continent du reste de
l'Europe, c'était la vision gaiolienne.
C'est ce que de Gaul veut faire. C'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il va signer le
traité de l'Élysée avec l'Allemagne en
1963. Quand il signe ce traité, son
objectif c'est de dire aux Allemands,
"Bon, très bien, vous avez euh bénéficié
de l'aide américaine, du plan Marchal,
depuis 45, les Américains sont chez vous
et cetera. Maintenant, cette période est
terminée. C'était une parenthèse. On va
se retrouver entre européens. Nous, on
fait la paix, la paix pour de vrai. Et
maintenant, nous la France, on accepte
de devenir votre protecteur. Il avait il
avait voulu l'arme nucléaire pour la
France pour ça, pour se dire "On sera
leader du continent, on prendra le
leadership militaire du continent parce
que tous les autres n'auront pas cet
outil qui nous permet de peser parmi les
grandes puissances." Là encore,
visionnaire. Visionnaire qui investit
des moyens, du temps et et qui prend un
risque géopolitique d'assumer vouloir la
bombe atomique
à ce moment-là. Donc on est en 63. Je
sais pas si vous avez lu les mémoires de
gens Monai. C'est vraiment passionnant
parfois de lire euh euh des gens qu'on
considère comme des adversaires, sur
lequel on entend plein de choses, agent
de la CIA et cetera. Qui dis ça que
Jean-Méie est un agent de la CIA ? Bah
c'est tous les golistes qui disaient euh
Monnaie c'est l'agent de la CIA. Mais
alors quand vous lisez son livre, au
moins c'est clair, il l'assume. C'est un
agent des Américains mais il le dit.
Donc au moins c'est lui qui le dit. On n
pas besoin de colp porter des ragots.
Donc quand vous lisez ses mémoires, vous
vous apercevez de ce que lui voulait
faire. Lui, il voulait vraiment que
l'Union européenne devienne une sorte de
colonie, il employait pas ce mot,
vraiment une forme de protectorat des
États-Unis. C'était sa sa vision des
choses. Il pensait que c'était comme ça
qu'on évoluerait dans un même monde
commun avec des intérêts communs et
cetera. Et donc quand de Gaul signe se
ce traité avec les Allemands en 63 qui
dit qu'en gros la France prend la place
des Américains dans la protection de
l'Allemagne, vous voyez le geste fort.
Ça veut clairement dire on est les
leaders du continent, on est maintenant
les grands frères et tout repose sur
nous.
Jean Monet Manigance dans la nuit auprès
des autorités allemandes pour que le
traité soit changé inextrémiste. Et le
lendemain matin, le général de Gaul
découvre que le préambule du traité de
l'Élysée dit que le traité n'est valable
que sous réserve de l'alliance que les
Allemands ont déjà avec les Américains.
En gros, tout est saordé. Et c'est là
que de Gaul sort cette phrase qui est
devenue très connue quand il dit "Les
traités valent ce que valent les roses."
Il fann en un instant et tout ne repose
que sur la confiance qu'on leur
accordait. Une phrase comme ça très
forte et sur dans lequel il dit en fait
c'était qu'un bout de papier. Ils se
sont moqués de moi. C'était mon grand
dessin. On a négocié pied à pied et puis
à la fin en une nuit tout s'effondre et
ils font le choix des Américains. Et à
ce moment-là, il est vraiment dépité. Il
change totalement de politique de
Gaulle. C'est à ce moment-là qu'il
commence à se désengager de l'Europe si
on peut dire et à vouloir faire alliance
avec des plus petites nations. Il va au
Mexique, il fait son discours Manoen la
mano, il va au Québec et il dit "Vive le
Québec libre". Donc c'est à ce moment-là
qu'il change un peu de politique en se
disant il nous faut une puissance, il
nous faut être les grands frères de
quelqu'un. Ça passera pas par
l'Allemagne puisqu'on a compris qu'il
nous trahirait toujours avec les
Américains. Ça passera avec d'autres
nations. Bref,
aujourd'hui, on a les États-Unis qui de
même vous imaginez si Degol était là, il
dirait "Mais quelle chance ! Si moi ça
m'était arrivé, j'aurais su en tirer
parti bien mieux que vous". On a
peut-être pas ce qu'il aurait dit. On a
les Américains qui d'eux-mêmes disent
"On ne veut plus vous protéger" et ils
le disent presque en nous insultant en
plus. Non, ils disent ils disent autre
chose entre les lignes. Ils disent "On
veut 4 % de votre PIB."
C'est ce qu'ils disent, non ? Ouais.
Mais vous pensez pas que le fait par
exemple qu'ils disent "L'Ukraine, on se
désengage, voilà, on a plus envie, on
vous aide plus et cetera, ils sont en
pleine guerre, ils seengagent." Vous
pensez pas qu'on pourrait dire aux
Allemands et aux Italiens, "C'est
vraiment sur eux que vous voulez compter
pour toujours ? Pensez juste à votre
peuple, à votre nation. Vous voulez
vraiment faire reposer votre survie en
cas de guerre sur des alliés qui vous
disent les yeux dans les yeux." Nous,
c'est purement commercial, c'est juste
financier. Donc maintenant le du jour au
lendemain, on peut partir, il y a une
majorité qui change, on s'en va. Est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que des voisins
qui sont sur le même continent que vous
peuvent avoir finalement plus de choses
à à proposer et à échanger avec vous ?
Et c'est là qu'à mon avis, on devrait
être intelligent et en tirer profit pour
réaliser ce que voulez le général de
Gaulle, c'est de dire "Alors, dès
maintenant, vous arrêtez d'acheter des
armes américaines." C'est anormal que le
Danemark, alors même qu'il entend que le
Groenland est menacé continue d'acheter
des armes américaines. Et vous, vous le
savez, je l'entends beaucoup dans ces
émissions. Dès lors que vous achetez une
seule arme américaine, vous n'êtes plus
souverain. Ça ne dépend plus de vous.
Dès lors que vous avez une pièce
américaine dans une seule de vos armes,
genre une catapulte sur un porte-avion.
Exactement. Là, vous n'êtes plus
souverain. Par exemple, vous savez que
les Britanniques ne peuvent pas appuyer
eux-mêmes sur leur bouton nucléaire.
Mais c'est normal, c'est les
britanniques. Bah voilà, ça ça s'appelle
ne pas être souverain. Nous, on peut de
la première à la 1 million pièce notre
arsenal nucléaire c'est nous. Donc nous,
on peut. Si demain on veut tirer, on
tire. Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Donc dans dans notre doctrine nucléaire,
on veut répondre, on peut répondre. Oui.
Oui. Tiré dans le sens de la doctrine
nucléaire française he pas tirer dans un
éclair de folie.
Donc oui, évidemment que la souveraineté
ça a un prix. Ça coûte cher. Ça coûte
cher de vouloir produire. Alors avant de
partir dans le sujet très important de
la souveraineté technologique qu'on va
traiter juste après, je voudrais qu'on
vienne à le basculement américain.
Américain. Pourquoi ? Comment ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils anticipent selon vous ?
Comment ils l'anticipent et à quelle
échéance ? Et quelles seront les
répercussions ? Les répercussions sur
nous, sur le monde, sur eux, sur eux
même d'abord. Est-ce qu'ils anticip ?
Pourquoi je je vais prendre 1 minute 30
et je pardon à Merci je demande une euh
pardon à la communauté. On va faire de
la prospective et de l'expérience de
pensée du jus de cerveau là. D'accord.
Donc en gros, on ne sait pas si le
prochain dieu de l'intelligence artif
artificielle sera chinois ou américain.
Ces deux
ces deux grands blocs se donnent les
moyens de jus d'électricité et d'énergie
en anticipant en construisant des
réacteurs, en construisant des barrages
un peu partout en construisant des
centrales photovoltaïques et un mix
énergétique sous stéroïdes des deux
côtés.
case de chis d'un côté et on en passe
pour pouvoir fiouler,
donner à manger de l'énergie au prochain
dieu. Tout à fait. Composante
industrielle de l'autre côté.
Semiconducteur. Exactement. Donc nous
l'Europe, on verra ça plus tard. Mais
pourquoi ils font ça ? Et on s'attend à
quoi ? Parce que on sent ce qui se
dessine, l'Europe dépessée pour laisser
à ces deux blocs du temps de monter en
puissance en technologie.
Ouais.
Je vous réponds euh en vous en vous
citant les premières pages du livre que
vient de sortir Julian. Oh non ! Julie
Anoda en poli donc l'auteur du M du
cremelin qui vient de publier un livre
qui s'appelle l'heure des prédateurs.
Tout n'est pas fantastique, c'est sans
doute pas son meilleur mais il y a une
page intéressante où il explique une des
théories, il peut y en avoir plusieurs,
qui explique pourquoi dans l'histoire on
a connu des grandes périodes de paix,
soudain des grandes périodes de conflit
et pour lui ça s'explique par la
décorrélation entre le coût offensif et
le coût défensif. Je m'explique. Si une
attaque coûte beaucoup moins cher que le
fait de se défendre de cette attaque,
alors l'histoire va entrer dans de
grandes périodes très béliqueuses. Si
par exemple pour attaquer un pays, ça
vous coûte très peu cher, mais que ce
même pays pour se défendre, il doit
mettre des des tonnes de moyens face à
vous, alors l'intérêt d'attaquer va être
très fort. Ça coûte pas cher, c'est
facile et en plus se défendre est
difficile. cyberattaque.
C'est exactement là où je voulais en
venir. Si à l'inverse euh vous avez un
coût de l'attaque qui est prohibitif,
attaque nucléaire, c'est énorme. ça nous
coûte des milliards de de de continuer
de moderniser notre arsenal nucléaire et
cetera, mais un coût de la défense qui
pour le coup est très peu cher, alors
vous allez rentrer dans des périodes
plus pacifiques où finalement puisque ça
coûte si cher d'attaquer et si peu cher
de se défendre, vous n'avez pas intérêt
à attaquer. Je vous donne un exemple
dans des dans des faits récents. Vous
avez du sud Liban des drones qui peuvent
partir pour attaquer le territoire
israélien, des drones qui vont coûter
200 dollars et pour contre-attaquer,
pour les intercepter, vous avez les
Israéliens qui vont envoyer des missiles
patriotes qui eux coûtent 2 millions.
Bah là, vous voyez à quel point si vous
étiez au sud Liban et que vous aviez un
intérêt géostratégique à attaquer
Israël, forcément l'alignement est
parfait. Vous payez 200 dollars, ils
doivent payer 2 millions, vous les
épuisez à force. On arrive dans un monde
où vous pourrez avoir une attaque
gratuite,
0 € un cœur qui peut mettre un pays par
terre avec simplement son ordinateur.
Donc un intérêt à l'offensif extrêmement
puissant puisque vous n'avez pas besoin
d'une masse énorme de moyens. griller
quelques étapes mais on a compris
l'idée. Ouais, je pense qu'on a je pense
qu'on a compris l'idée. Donc je disais
si l'offensif coûte très peu cher et que
le défensif coûte très cher, on est dans
des périodes béliqueuses dans l'histoire
parce que il y a un intérêt fort à
attaquer pour une nation. Elle dépense
pas beaucoup de ressources, elle peut
obtenir beaucoup. Si vous avez au
contraire une défense euh qui euh qui
coûte euh très peu cher face à une
attaque très chère, période plus
pacifique, ça coûte trop cher
d'attaquer, autant commercer, vivre dans
un monde paisible et ne pas se prendre
la tête avec des guerres qui vont nous
ruiner. Voilà pour résumer cette
histoire. On arrive dans une heure, il
donne il donne des des trucs plus
concrets sur les bases de soutenabilité
de nos sociétés thermo-industrielles en
terme énergétique de ressources parce
que donne pas d'exemple. Juste un
détail, on rentre dans un monde de
rarfaction quand on voit les États-Unis
donner des permis pour aller récupérer
les nodules polymétallique à 4000 m de
fond avec des grosses moissonneuses
batteuses quand on les voit vouloir
prendre le Groenland.
Si on peut juste sur sur ce sur ce point
précis, c'est quelque chose que
j'entends beaucoup et notamment chez
chez certains ingénieurs qui peuvent
être médiatiques, Jean Covici et cetera.
Quand on quand quand on parle de pic
énergétique, les gens ont l'impression
que soudain, il y aura plus d'énergie,
qu'on va plus trouver euh qu'on va plus
trouver de de matière premières, qu'on
narrivera plus à produire. Et donc
parfois certains de bonne foi entrent
dans une perspective très décroissante
où ils se disent "Bah finalement, il
vaut mieux arrêter de produire, arriver
dans l'air de la sobriété mais avec
parfois des conséquences heureuses." Euh
alors que franchement, je vois pas que
qui nous propose un modèle heureux de de
sobriété parmi ceux qu'on connaît. Ça
arrêtaé de manger du comté. Enfin bref,
on rentre pas dans leur folie parce
qu'ils salissent même les idées qu'ils
veulent défendre. Euh
ce modèle-là, Europe écologie des ver
citez les moins, citez-les moins. Euh
donc rappelons quand même aux gens qu'en
réalité ce que ça veut dire ce fait
d'atteindre un pic, ça veut pas dire que
soudain on trouve plus de pétrole ou de
gaz ou qu'on trouve plus. Ça veut juste
dire qu'en réalité, voilà, au bout d'un
moment, ça va coûter cher d'extraire et
qu'on peut arriver à un moment où ça
coûtera peut-être plus cher de d'obtenir
cette ressource que ce que cette
ressource va nous apporter en terme de
croissance.
On nen est pas sûr qu'on va arriver à un
moment d'épuisement total. Ni vous ni
moi. En tout cas, il y a beaucoup
d'études qui sont très contradictoires.
Donc je pense que puisqu'on ne sait pas
si véritablement il va y avoir un
épuisement de la ressource, on peut
uniquement penser si on fait de la
prospective en terme de risque. Combien
est-ce que ça nous coûterait s'il y
avait un épuisement à ce moment-là ?
Quel est le risque de tout miser sur
cette énergie-là plutôt que celle-ci ?
comme on enfin comme on pourrait dire
trivialement, il faut pas mettre tous et
tout dans le même panier. Et dès lors
qu'on commence à penser en terme de
risque, je pense qu'on peut davantage
avancer que dans une perspective très
angoissante que nous promettent certains
à savoir on arrive au pic, il faut tout
de suite changer de modèle. Je peux vous
proposer une même deux même trois 4 5
Merci. C'est trop gagné avec moi ça.
Combien de de baril de pétrole le monde
consomme par jour ?
Je ne sais pas, j'aime bien ces
questions. Mais dites-moi, dites-moi les
réponses quand même. Non, non, je donne
pas les réponses. Je suis pas là pour
donner les réponses. Mais pour les gens
qui écoute, ils vont se demander. 104
millions de baril par jour, c'est la
dernière réponse que je donnerai.
Combien de cuivres ? Combien de tonnes
de minerais pour extraire de l'uranium ?
Combien ? Dites-moi. Je ne sais pas. Je
sais pas. Je vous pose la question.
Quand vous voyez les Belges revenir sur
le nucléaire, les Japonais revenir sur
le nucléaire, les Indiens, les Chinois,
les Américains, les Français, bon tout
le monde. Hm hm.
Le robinet du l'extron du nucléaire.
Ça va devenir problématique. Alors, je
pose une question. J'ai pas terminé.
Donc là, en terme de capacité
énergétique à coût correct pour donner
2200 calories à la population par jour.
Hm hm.
Ça va devenir compliqué non ? Alors
parce que si si on si le baril de
pétrole il passe à 350 dollars, le kilo
d'engrais pour aller faire des tomates,
ça va être compliqué. Ouais. Euh je vous
pose une question. Est-ce que vous savez
combien de stock d'uranium on a en
France et pour combien d'années on
pourrait tenir ? Alors ça tombe bien
parce que c'est notre sujet. On a été
voir on a été voir, on va le dire aux
gens. Comment on va on va le dire aux
gens. On va vous écoute. C'est quoi
votre source ? Donc c'est 10 ans. Vous
avez appelé Arnaud Mondbourg. Dites-moi.
Non. Et je vous pose la question.
Quelles sont vos sources ? Mes sources ?
Bah je je lis la littérature
scientifique, j'essaie de voir mais
c'est quelle source ? Donc pour vous
c'est pas 10 ans. Non mais je vous pose
la question quelle est votre source ?
Bah enfin pour le coup c'est dans des
dans des livres que j'ai lu. Là j'ai lu
le livre des grands illusionnistes. Un
livre écrit par Géraldine Vosner qui
cite ça. Donc oui je je Pour vous c'est
pas 10 ans. C'est non pas 10 ans. Non.
Alors combien d'années ? On garde ça
pour nous ou non ? Non, je pense que ça
vaut c'est important pour nourrir la
discussion. C'est beaucoup moins de 10
ans. Très bien. Donc on a des stocks qui
peuvent durer plusieurs années. Pourquoi
je vous dis ça ? À mon sens c'est 10
ans. Quelqu'un vous donne une réponse ?
Pas du tout. Il est en train de me
montrer Astrid mais c'est un autre
problème. Ça va mettre 15 ans. D'accord.
Très bien. Donc pourquoi je disais ça ?
On a des stocks d'uranium donc qui
peuvent nous permettre de d'obtenir
cette énergie nucléaire. À l'inverse,
quand on regarde les alternatives, c'est
pour ça que je vous disais tout à
l'heure, il faut plutôt penser en terme
de risque, de probabilité et se dire
plutôt que euh donc on arrête tout, on
arrive à la décroissance parce que euh
on n'est pas certain d'en avoir pour le
restant de nos jours, parce que certains
disent que finalement c'est pas 10 ans,
parce que ceci et cela.
Plutôt que de se dire ça, pensons en
terme de probabilité que quelque chose
advienne de risque quel faisons des
calculs avantage risque et comparons au
reste. L'uranium, on a des stocks. Donc
certains disent 10 ans, vous vous dites
moins. En tout cas, on a des stocks. On
sait que l'uranium c'est pas ce qui
prend le plus de place à stocker. C'est
pas ce qui est le plus difficile à
stocker. Si on compare au gaz
typiquement, alors là euh bah peu de
stock, ça prend une place énorme à
stocker. On doit l'importer de pays avec
lequel on est en bien plus mauvais terme
que si on regarde les pays dont on
importe l'uranium, Kazakhstan, Canada,
ça va un peu mieux. Arrivait plus à
fournir. Ouais. ça va un peu mieux euh
avec ces pays-là qu'avec par exemple
l'Algérie. Donc imaginez que parce qu'on
se dit euh qu'on n'a pas envie euh de
dépendre de cette matière première là,
alors on se met dans la main de bien
d'autres matières premières plus
onéreuses, plus difficiles à stocker
avec des pays avec lesquels on s'entend
moins bien. Est-ce que sous prétexte que
on n pas du stock pour la vie d'uranium,
alors on devrait se mettre dans la main
bah du lithium, du gaz algérien. Enfin,
vous voyez, on arrive à des absurdités à
la fin où finalement parce queon est en
train d'essayer de trouver des défauts
au nucléaires, on va se porter sur les
énergies intermittentes. Et parce que
les énergies intermittentes ne peuvent
pas tourner sans, on va avoir besoin du
gaz, des centrales à charbon, une
absurdité où finalement à la fin on est
bien plus dépendant, bien moins
écologique, bien moins compétitif. ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher pour les gens
alors qu'on a devant nous celle non pas
qui est parfaite, non pas qui ne
comporte aucun risque, non pas une
énergie où on se dit jusqu'à la fin de
nos jours et jusqu'à la fin de
l'humanité, on est sûr qu'on aura de
l'uranium. Personne peut dire ça,
personne peut vous dire ça. Mais on sait
dans l'état actuel des connaissances que
c'est le calcul le plus rationnel de se
dire que si on compare tous les risques,
c'est celui qui emporte le moins.
Ensuite, si on est techno optimiste ou
si on est tout simplement optimiste, on
voit le projet ITER à Cadarche. Je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure que j'avais audité
le commissariat énergie atomique. Donc,
j'ai été à Cadarche, j'ai vu ce projet.
Si on a un peu d'optimisme sur ça, mais
ne misons pas dessus et restons quand
même rationnel, alors on peut se dire
qu'on aura peut-être demain une énergie
infini grâce à ce projet, grâce à la
fusion nucléaire. Peut-être ne misons
pas tout dessus, on est encore loin de
la commercialisation du fait de pouvoir
pas cher. Énergie infini est pas cher et
enfin pour le coup vraiment le projet
qui redonne confiance dans le fait qu'on
puisse continuer avec un modèle
d'énergie infinie et pas cher quand on a
une société immature.
Immature dans l'emploi de l'énergie,
vous le savez, on est une société de
transformant. Qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire par immature ? immature dans le
sens où euh est-ce qu'on va s'amuser à
faire de l'obsolescence contrôlée encore
des années ? Est-ce qu'on va s'amuser à
faire On a tous utiliser euh
l'expression et passe-moi l'expression
mais acheter des merdes qu'on va jamais
utiliser ou qui ne servent à rien.
Continuer à vouloir plus vite, plus
loin, plus fort, plus vite, plus loin,
plus fort. Donc avoir de l'énergie bon
marché dans une société immature, c'est
pour aller où ? Vers quoi ? Mais
qu'est-ce qu'une société mature ?
une société qui arrête de se faire la
guerre peut-être. Non, sans doute. Sans
doute. Mais c'est ça a rarement été
corrélé à la maturité, à la culture.
Vous savez, les gens étaient tous
surpris que l'Allemagne des philosophes
et des scientifiques été était la plus
béliqueuse. Je sais pas s'il y a
vraiment moins une corrélation entre la
maturité d'un peuple et ça.
Je parle pas en terme société
capitalistique immature. Hm hm. Bon,
c'est un autre débat. On viendra voulez
dire société de consommation qui
consomme à l'excès, qui achète et qui
jette ce genre de truc. Fast fashion,
enfin tout ce dont on parle en ce
moment. Envoyer des retraités, faire des
croisières en Arctique. Ouais, c'est
intelligent. Ouais, je comprends ce que
vous voulez dire. Non, bah franchement,
je vais pas vous dire oui. Euh peut-être
peut-être qu'on sortira de ce modèle par
écœurement. Je crois pas qu'on en
sortira par la contrainte, l'échec, les
subventions, on en parlait tout à
l'heure. Ça me paraît vraiment être des
expédients. Une fausse manière de se
donner l'impression qu'on règle le
problème. En réalité, on gaspie toujours
plus d'argent public, mais je me dis
qu'on en sortira peut-être par
l'écœurement. Et je pense que quiconque
a est allé en Italie euh dans des
endroits magnifiques, visiter des musées
bondés où il pouvait même pas approcher
le moindre tableau parce qu'il y avait
70 personnes qui faisaient des selfies
devant, euh voit très bien ce que ça
peut vouloir dire cet écurement. C'est
pour ça qu'il faut aller au Danemark.
Ouais. par exempleemark ou qu'il faut
jamais aller en Italie au mois d'août
mais voilà on on en vient déjà sans
doute à changer nos habitudes quand on
voit je sais pas pas besoin d'aller en
Italie d'ailleurs, si on va au Louvre,
si on va dans des musées français et
qu'on s'aperçoit que pour voir la
Joconde il y a des lignes et des lignes
et puis toutes les nationalités qui sont
avec leur perch selfie oui il y a un
côté un peu un peu un peu un peu
écurant. Quel avis ? Ouais, pardon,
c'est moi. Quel avis vous avez sur les
gens qui balancent des des de la soupe
sur des toiles ou qui se collent les
mains ?
Bah,
des profanateurs euh qui tout à l'heure,
je vous disais profane une vitre
blindée, hein. Ouais. Et il profane des
œuvres de l'humanité. C'est leur but
d'ailleurs, c'est de choquer par cette
action de profanation. Ils se disent "On
va mobiliser l'opinion publique parce
qu'on touche à quelque chose de sacré."
C'est ça une œuvre d'art. Quand on voit
une œuvre d'art exposée dans un musée
qui nous a été légué encore une fois par
des siècles et des siècles, nous a été
transmis jusqu'à mériter d'être exposé
dans un musée et que les gens payent
pour venir la voir. Quand ces gens-là
jettent de la soupe sur des tableaux et
des et des œuvres d'art, leur objectif
c'est nous choquer, nous faire voir
quelque chose qu'on aurait sans doute
pas vu. Mais que pense-t-on de leur
combat quand on voit ça ? Sincèrement,
je vous disais tout à l'heure, parfois
ils salissent les idées qu'ils veulent
défendre. Moi, je peux pas avoir
d'estime pour quelqu'un qui imagine qui
va donner envie à qui que ce soit euh de
de trier ses déchets parce qu'il a jeté
de la soupe sur un tableau. Ce serait
quoi la la bonne politique pour
sensibiliser Sarah Knafo
à l'écologie ou à tout je suis très
sensible autrement. La la bonne
politique à mon sens, c'est la défense
du beau. Je crois je crois beaucoup à
ça. Je crois que en France, on n pas
seulement un patrimoine architectural,
on a un patrimoine naturel magnifique.
C'est on s'aperçoit qu'on a de la chance
parfois quand on va dans d'autres pays
ou je veux pas dire du mal de nos
voisins, mais quand je dois aller à
Bruxelles pour aller au Parlement
européen, il m'arrive très souvent de me
dire "J'ai quand même de la chance
d'être française, d'être née dans ce
pays-là."
Euh il a des trucs sympas en Belgique.
Il y a des Oui, il y a des trucs sympas.
C'est vrai, il y a des trucs sympas mais
on n'est pas subjugué comme on l'
moindre village français. Et je veux pas
comparer pour pour dire du mal d'eux. Il
y a il y a aussi de très jolies choses
et d'ailleurs dans dans toute l'Union
européenne, dans toute dans sur tout ce
continent magnifique. Mais bah disons
que moi j'ai grandi dans un département
qui n'est pas beau. La scène
Saint-Denis, ça n'est pas joli. Vous
avez de beaux endroits, vous avez
évidemment la basilique à Saint-Denis,
mais quand vous voyez le reste, d'abord
c'est un département qui est très
moderne. Donc il a été construit dans
une année où il y avait une chute du
goût esthétique.
En des années où il y avait une chute du
goût esthétique, on était devenu assez
utilitariste dans nos manières de voir
l'architecture.
C'était cette phrase de le corbusier qui
disait "Rome se musée des horreurs." Et
il dit que c'est horrible pour lui parce
qu'il y a des statues partout, des
places et des fontaines et pour lui
c'est quelque chose d'inutile. Lui avait
une vision très utilitariste de
l'architecture et il disait que pour lui
l'architecture idéale c'était celle d'un
avion parce que très épuré, on a mis
uniquement les meubles qui avaient
besoin de s'y trouver. euh tout est à sa
place et euh il y a pas de fioriture,
pas de moulure, pas de décoration, pas
de cheminée, rien qui ne sert à rien.
C'était sa vision de l'architecture et
c'est cette vision qui a vraiment gagné
dans tout la prègerre. C'est ce qu'on
construit presque partout. D'ailleurs,
si on peut citer une des un des rares à
mon sens défaut de vision du général de
Gaulle, c'est sur cet aspect esthétique.
Il a contribué parce qu'il pensait que
c'était la modernité à à accepter
l'enlaidissement du pays. Et on a tous
ces images en tête. peut-être loger les
gens. Non, c'était pas forcément pour
loger. Je pense à je pense à d'autres
trucs. Par exemple, j'ai travaillé à la
préfecture de la scène Sennie. Si vous
mettez ceux qui écoutent sur Google
image préfecture de la scène Si, vous
allez voir ce que je veux dire. Vous
allez avoir ce bâtiment, cette vision
d'enfer construit en réalisme soviétique
atroce, béton noir et cetera. Quand vous
regardez la défense, quand vous regardez
aux abords de de la moindre commune
française, ces zones commerciales,
Conforama et cetera. Vous voyez ce ce
comment dire cette cet enlaidissement de
la France. Ouais. D'autres marques,
c'est pas pour c'est pas pour
stigmatiser Conforama. Euh mais quand
vous voyez ce ce déclin du sens
esthétique, moi c'est quelque chose qui
me frappe beaucoup. J'avais discuté avec
un avec un architecte un jour qui me
disait si aujourd'hui on veut
reconstruire des bâtiments osmaniens ou
des bâtiments taille de pierre style 17e
et cetera, on peut pas le faire. C'est
ce sera pas possible sur le marché.
D'une part, ça coûte trop cher, ça prend
trop de temps. On a plus de gens qui
savent le faire rapidement parce qu'on a
pas assez de monde. On aurait pas assez
d'artisans qui savent construire comme
ça. Et ça me fait penser à une idée, je
vais finir par ça sur ce sujet. Ça me
fait penser à une idée, c'est qu'il y a,
je crois, dans notre époque
une grande prétention ou un grand
orgueil à penser grande mégalomanie, une
grande mégalomanie à penser que notre
génération
sait faire tout ce que les autres
générations savaient. mais qu'on a en
plus ajouté d'autres savoir-faire. On a
l'impression que nous on est dépositaire
de tous les savoir-faire ancestraux mais
qu'en plus on sait faire des choses
qu'il savaient pas faire. On nous en
plus on a l'IA, en plus on a l'iPhone,
en plus on a et cetera et cetera mais on
on est presque persuadé que quelqu'un en
tout cas sait faire ce que tous les
autres savaient faire. Et je pense qu'on
oublie qu'en réalité on a perdu
énormément de savoir-faire. Il y a
énormément de choses qu'on ne sait plus
faire. Tout à l'heure, je disais la
compétence nucléaire, on aurait vraiment
pu la perdre. Si notre folie
déconstructiviste du nucléaire avait
duré 20 ans de plus, on perdait la
compétence. Il y aurait plus eu assez de
gens en emploi qui pourraient former des
jeunes ingénieurs qui sortent d'école.
Dieu merci, il nous reste cette
génération transitoire qui va former les
jeunes qui arrivent dans la filière
nucléaire, mais on aurait pu la perdre.
ce ce cette architecture, ce sens du
beau et cetera, en majeure partie, on a
accepté de le perdre parce que on a on a
on a vécu dans une époque de mauvais
goût et d'utilitarisme architectural.
Bon, après, il est existe des poches, on
a vu Notre Dame.
Revenons au Chine, États-Unis,
intelligence artificielle, expérience de
pensée, jus de cerveau, ils vont où ? Et
nous on va rester dans le gay combien de
temps alors sans énergie, sans projet
énergétiqu sans ressources, sans
accession, ressources facile ? Ouais.
Alors sur la partie énergie, j'essaie de
pas revenir dessus parce que je vous en
ai parlé tout à l'heure. Je vous ai dit
que Biden par exemple, ça avait beaucoup
joué li fait de comprendre qu'il fallait
des centres de données très
consommateurs en énergie, ça a beaucoup
joué dans le fait qu'il disent aux
écolos maintenant vous arrêtez avec le
nucléaire, on va miser sur le nucléaire,
on en a besoin. Donc ça je mets je mets
de côté un chiffre pour que pour qu'on
les tous en tête, mais vous vous le
connaissez. 92 % de nos données des
données européennes sont stockées aux
États-Unis. Donc je pense que juste avec
ce chiffre, on comprend à quel point on
a perdu toute souveraineté, à quel point
vous avez raison de dire et nous
qu'est-ce qu'on fait au milieu du gay,
au milieu de tout ça pour donner un
exemple avec le blanc sein de nos
élites. Ah, totalement. C'est exactement
ce sur quoi j'allais venir. Pour donner
un exemple aux gens, sous Emmanuel
Macron, on a signé un projet qui
s'appelle le else Data Hub et qui
accepte de donner à Microsoft, Microsoft
Azure plus précisément, toutes nos
données de santé. Quel est l'objectif
initial de ce projet ? L'objectif, c'est
de permettre la recherche avec des
millions de données, métadonné de santé
qui vont être stocké sur un serveur et
qui permettront de trouver des
recherches beaucoup plus facilement,
d'entraîner une intelligence
artificielle avec. Ouais, a priori,
c'est bien, c'est une bonne idée. Il y a
beaucoup de médecins qui font ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils essayent de prendre
les données qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
acquises pendant toute leur carrière et
qui essayent d'en faire quelque chose,
de trouver des résultats. Il y a
beaucoup de enfin, je sais pas si dans
vos familles vous avez des médecins mais
presque tous les médecins qu'on connaît
ont déjà fait ça. Il noté sur leur
carnet. Voilà une corrélation entre euh
un monsieur qui fait qui se réveille à
telle heure le matin, est-ce qu'il est
en bonne santé à telle date ? Enfin, il
notaient énormément de choses et après
ils en tirent des euh des des euh
remèdes, des analyses médicales et
cetera. Et là, on se dit, on arrive dans
un monde, on peut le faire sur des
millions de données. C'est génial. Donc
a priori, on est content de se dire on
va faire avancer la recherche. Mais au
lieu de le faire nous-même, on l'offre
sur un serveur américain.
Vous savez et on le dit quand même pour
les gens qu'il existe aux États-Unis des
lois extraterritoriales qui permettent
notamment le cloud act qui permettent au
gouvernement américain d'exiger de
n'importe quelle société américaine de
donner toutes les données qu'il a en sa
possession si un intérêt américain
l'exige. Demain, vous pouvez avoir les
États-Unis, le gouvernement américain
qui se met à réclamer à Microsoft les
données de santé des Français. Et
pourquoi c'est gravissime ? D'abord, je
pense que tout le monde comprend bien
que ces données de santé, c'est à peu
près ce qu'on a de plus personnel, ce
qu'on a de plus de plus intime et à quel
point ça peut arriver à des risques
géopolitiques majeurs. On voit que les
Américains, ils sont totalement prêts.
On se souvient de Frédéric Pierucci,
enfermé dans les jaules américaines, à
peine arrivé sur le territoire américain
et juste après, les Américains nous nous
achètent. Euh cette filière d'Alstom
avec la bénédiction de nos élites, comme
vous le disiez, Macron déjà. Euh donc on
voit à quel point ils peuvent l'utiliser
pour leurs pour leur pour leur intérêt
propre. Par ailleurs, autre chose à
savoir et qui va peut-être faire
percevoir la la valeur et le côté
précieux de ce qu'on a donné. Les
données de santé françaises sont sans
doute les plus structurées du monde.
Avec un numéro de carte vitale, on a
tout. toutes nos analyses de sang, tout
ce qu'on a pu faire par le passé de
vaccins, toutes les je sais pas les
prises de sang qu'on aurait fait, les
dépressions éventuelles que certains
auraient fait, l'alcoolisme de certains,
les maladies, les avortements pour
certaines et cetera et cetera. Donc par
exemple, tout la vie d'une personne peut
se retrouver sur son numéro de carte
vitale, où il va, quel est son médecin,
à quelle fréquence, est-ce qu'il a des
problèmes cardiaques ? Est-ce qu'il a
une maladie qu'il veut cacher ? Est-ce
que et cetera et cetera ? prend du
temps, ça leur évitera de percer les
conduites d'eau usé de l'Élysée pour
savoir si Ouais. Pompidou avait un
cancer. C'est ça. En fait, on aura même
plus besoin d'aller par curiosité voir
ce qu'il y a sur le toit de l'ambassade.
On saura déjà qu'ils ont tout ce dont
ils ont besoin. En en en une demande
faite à Microsoft Azur, le gouvernement
américain peut dire "Tel politicien
français, je veux ça sur lui." Tel cadre
de telle entreprise, je veux ça sur lui.
Demain, par exemple, on arrive au projet
dont je vous parlais, à savoir devenir
le leader militaire du continent. On dit
aux Allemands, on dit aux Italiens, vous
devez acheter des avions français.
Demain, vous avez le gouvernement
américain qui peut dire "Donnez-moi
toutes les données d'Éric Trapier."
Voilà le patron de d'assauto, je veux
tout savoir sur lui. Et il nous
décrédibilise un patron. Il nous
déstabilise une boîte qui pouvait faire
concurrence aux boîtes américaines. Et
du jour au lendemain, il le fait. Il
peut faire chanter quelqu'un.
Ne faites pas le naïf, ça vous va pas
très bien. Donc par la naïveté de des
élites françaises qui ont offert sur un
plateau nos données de santé à
Microsoft. Et important de le dire,
quand on a donné nos données de santé à
Microsoft dans le casadre du ELS Data
Hub, donc il y a à peine quelques
années, soit Emmanuel Macron et Cédric à
l'époque était ministre, à cette époque,
il y avait pas que Microsoft qui
candidatait pour obtenir ce marché, il y
avait aussi OVH. Donc on avait aussi un
acteur, on avait aussi un acteur local.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on a dit à l'époque ? Et
d'ailleurs même Laaknil s'en est ému en
disant on constate que le gouvernement
français a fait le choix d'offrir ce
marché à un acteur américain. On le
regrette parce que ça va permettre des
ingér, ça pourra permettre des
ingérences étrangères, noir sur blanc
dans le rapport de l'accil de l'époque
2023.
Il y a eu pourtant un concurrent
français qui qui prétendait à ce à ce
marché et on ne l'a pas choisi. À
l'époque, le gouvernement avait dit OVH
est pas assez développé. Euh il y a pas
toutes les fonctionnalités.
Première chose déjà un peu bête et
méchante, on pourrait se dire bah
ce projet on veut le mettre en place à
peine maintenant. Si on avait attendu un
an de plus en disant à OVH vous avez 1
an pour vous former à ce qu'on veut. On
veut telle et telle fonctionnalité et
sinon ben on prendra la concurrence. Je
pense qu'il l'aurait fait. Deuxième
chose du hasard. Ils ont pris feu en
plus. C'est du hasard peut-être. J'ai
pas d'éléments. Deuxième chose, je pense
que là c'est un peu le serpent qui se
mort la queue. Nos entreprises ne se
développeront jamais si elles nous n'ont
pas le soutien fort de l'État, mais pas
par la subvention, par les marchés
publics. Et quand on regarde comment les
entreprises américaines se sont
développées, bah là il faut pas faire
l'idéaliste libéral. Elles se sont
développées par l'armée américaine, par
le gouvernement américain, par des
marchés publics parfois même surévalués
et surfacturés pour leur permettre de
vivre et de continuer de croître. Elles
se sont développées comme ça. Nous, on a
un modèle absurde. Donc, on en vient à
des solutions concrètes sur notre
souveraineté technologique. On vit un
modèle absurde en France où vous avez
une même collectivité, mettons l'État,
une région au hasard, la région
Île-de-Fance,
une mairie, enfin un département, peu
importe, une collectivité publique qui
le matin même peut subventionner une
start-up française, une entreprise
française en disant "Regardez, je fais
de l'innovation start-up nation, j'ai
donné un peu d'argent à un tel et un
tel" et qui l'après-midi dans son
attribution de marché public va faire
travailler son concurrent américain.
J'ai plein d'exemples. Donc je vais pas
les citer parce que j'ai pas envie de
gêner qui que ce soit, mais ça existe
tous les jours. Ça se trouve, vous avez
une région qui va dire "Je donne tant
d'argent à telle société qui édite des
logiciels et qui l'après-midi même va
dire "Mais pour tous mes services, on va
utiliser Microsoft."
Pourquoi vous leur donnez de l'argent si
vous croyez pas en eux ? À quoi ça a
servi de leur donner l'argent des
français, de l'argent public qu'on a
payé avec nos impôts si ça n'était pas
finalement parce que vous aviez un
minimum de foi dans leur capacité à se
développer, dans le fait que
l'entreprise était bonne. Il y a aucun
investisseur qui ferait ça. Vous
imaginez si vous êtes investisseur, vous
dites "Je vais donner 1 million à un tel
mais en fait je pense qu'il est trop nul
et que Microsoft c'est 100 fois mieux."
Si vous n'y croyez pas, vous ne donnez
pas. Vous rappelez de la petite musique
de l'époque qui disait "Oui, mais vous
vous rendez pas compte, les Chinois ont
des comportements prédateurs sur de
données, les Américains sont plus aptes
à les protéger. Ah bah ça c'est
fantastique. Bah là je dis l'air Trump
ouvre des perspectives parce qu'on a la
brutalité américaine sans masque. Il est
à découvert. Moi c'est ça ce que
j'apprécie dans son élection. Je me dis
enfin les Français vont se dire on a
toujours cru que quand les États-Unis
faisaient quelque chose c'est pas les
Français. Les Français les les les
élites françaises se sont toujours dit
pendant longtemps. Non je d'ailleurs
vous avez raison parce que je pense que
chez les Français il y avait toujours un
réflexe anti-atlantiste mais pas chez
les élites. Pourquoi un réflexe
anti-atlantiste ? Ils ont vu que la NSA
avait écouté nos présidents. Ils s'en
sont rappelés. Ils ont vu que les
Américains, bah ils aspiraent les
données un peu de partout. Ils ont vu
qu'on nous a empêché notre contrat de
vente de sous-marin à l'Australie, qu'on
nous a privé de milliards. Oui. qu'on
nous a privé de milliards et c'était pas
Trump, c'était Joe Biden. Ils ont vu que
quand Pierucci a été arrêté aux
États-Unis, c'était pas Trump, c'était
Obama, le gentil Obama qui voulait le
bien du monde et cetera. Donc je Nobel
de la paix. Prix Nobel de la paix.
Incroyable. Donc euh quand je dis "Nous
avons été naïfs, je parle évidemment de
la classe politique française." C'est de
la naïveté ou c'est de la forfaiture ?
Regardez-moi dans les yeux et dites-moi.
Ouais. Bah je pense que ça dépend des
gens. Je pense qu'il il y en a certains
dont on peut dire young leader, on peut
trouver la trace et cetera. Moi j'aime
pas accuser à tort sur ce genre de truc
hyper fort parce qu'à la fin bah vous
êtes en droit de me dire bah donner une
preuve. Quelles sont les sources ? Bah
voilà, quelles sont les sources ? Et bah
peut-être que vous vous les avez. Moi je
j'ai pas de preuve de quelqu'un qui
aurait été payé. J'ai entendu beaucoup
d'histoires et je pense que si c'est pas
sourcé, ça nous intéresse pas. Bah
voilà, sur Général électrique, peut-être
qu'on a lu les mêmes livres, peut-être
qu'on a entendu les mêmes histoires sur
Arabel, peut-être qu'on a entendu les
mêmes choses. J'ai pas de document à
l'appui. J'ai jamais eu, je sais pas, un
français qui m'a avoué les yeux dans les
yeux qu'il avait été payé par le
gouvernement américain pour nuire à nos
intérêts. Et peut-être le gouvernement
anglais. Peut-être le prochain scandale,
je pense qu'on a des indices. Vous voyez
ce que je veux dire ? On a des indices
peut-être que qu'on a pas de preuve ou
peut-être qu'elles sont pas sur la place
publique. Mais oui, bah quand quand on
lit certains livres sur certains
couples, sur des intérêts croisés, sur
le fait qu'il y ait des entreprises qui
étaient vendues aux Américains alors
qu'elles étaient stratégiques et que
certains se sont beaucoup enrichis,
forcément, on se dit là, il peut y avoir
matière à faire fêure, fortfiture et
pour beaucoup d'autres sans doute une
forme de naïveté aussi. un côté très
atlantiste de la classe politique qui
croyait en permanence que les États-Unis
voulaient notre bien. Et là, l'élection
de Trump vient dire brutalement si on
veut, en tout cas franchement à la face
du monde, chacun pour sa peau. Mais vous
partez du postulat que les élites
françaises comprennent ces sujets. Ah,
je pense qu'avec Trump là, ils sont en
train de comprendre non ? Par sinon, il
faut leur dire faut leur dire en chinois
sinon sans vouloir faire de mauvais jeux
de moi. Pas mal, pas mal.
C'est avec Trump, ils comprennent pas
là. Franchement, ils sont ils sont
sourds et complètement sourds. Non, je
pense qu'ils comprennent sont sour ou
ils sont juste crétins ? Je dirais
sourd. Moi, j'aime pas insulter les
gens. La chrétinerie hein, c'est une
chrétinerie hein. La chrétinerie est une
chrétinerie. Non, je pense que pour
beaucoup ils sont idéologues. Idéologu
enfermés dans un carcan dans lequel ils
ont été formés. C'est possible. Oui,
vous avez raison. Parfois, l'idéologie
mène à des stupidités, à des aberrations
historiques et puis après on on se dit
"Mais comment ont-ils pu être aussi
bêtes, aussi aveugles et cetera
Là, s'il peut les sortir de leur
aveuglement, alors il aura déjà fait un
grand pas. S'il peut contribuer à
relégitimer le discours d'une forme
d'égoïsme national. J'utilise le mot
égoïsme, il est chargé. Mais je pense
que chez lui quand il dit l'Amérique
d'abord, c'est ça aussi. C'est chacun
pour sa peau et sil peut permettre de
relégitimer le fait que nous on se dise
ça, qu'on arrête avec cette forme de
naïveté qui parfois peut conduire au
suicide vraiment au suicide au suicide
de nos intérêts, à l'autodestruction
pour euh pour pour utiliser un terme
moins fort à l'autodestruction. Alors
là, il aura fait il aura fait un grand
pas. Et d'ailleurs, vous remarquez,
chose intéressante,
qu'il est apprécié par les plus
souverainistes de tous. Moi, j'en fais
partie. Mon premier mon premier
engagement politique, c'était pour le
souverainisme. J'ai créé la première
association souverainiste de science P.
Euh c'est un sujet sur lequel je me suis
beaucoup battue.
Les plus sincères souverainistes
d'Europe ont vu d'un bon œil son
élection quand les plus atlantistes de
tous, ceux qui détestent le mot de
souveraineté, il se trouve qu'ils sont
aussi les mêmes qui détestent Donald
Trump. Est-ce que vous avez écouté le
discours de Gid Evens à concernant la
liberté d'expression ? Ouais, tout à
fait. Votre avis, votre point de vue ?
Mon point de vue, c'est qu'on n pas
attendu Jade Devens pour le dire de
notre côté chez Ronquêt. Donc c'est
évidemment des constats qu'on partage.
Je regrette les deux réactions extrêmes,
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont été subjugués
en disant "Waouh, c'est un discours
magnifique comme s'ils avaient jamais
entendu ça par le passé." On passe notre
temps à le dire he que évidemment on
n'est plus en démocratie quand ce n'est
pas la voix du peuple qui compte. quand
sur certains sujets le peuple s'exprime
à 1000 reprises pour faire comprendre sa
désapprobation et que pourtant on
continue qui a un problème et qu'on peut
plus prévaloir du beau qualificatif de
pays démocratiques. Je pense notamment
au référendum Bafoué de 2005 mais on
pourrait parler de 1000 autres sujets
comme l'immigration sur lequel il est
désormais clair que les Français ont dit
on avait donné qu'ils avaient donné leur
part et pourtant le pouvoir politique
continue de dire il faut il faut y
aller. On en accueille 500000 tous les
ans. ce que Emmanuel Macron a répété
lundi lors de son sa très très longue
émission. Donc de ce point de vue-là,
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait des constats
qui étaient assez sous antibiotique vous
aussi après ça ? Non, ça va. Non, parce
que prendre 3 heures de merde dans
lespans après il faut pour se préparer.
J'ai eu l'habitude, hein, je vous ai dit
vous avez fait mes études. Euh
donc
euh proche, vous allez pouvoir vous
baigner dans la scène avec un traitement
pareil, hein. Là, le système
immunitaire, il est taqué. Ça coûte très
cher he la baignade dans la scène. Vous
avez vu ça ? Euh donc Jade Evens des
constats que moi j'ai trouvé basique. Je
suis d'accord avec ce qu'il a dit parce
que c'est ce que je défends. C'est ce
que j'essaie de dire à longueur de
discours au Parlement européen. C'est ce
que Éric Zemour a dit en 2022
de manière à mon sens très très audible
par le peuple français. Donc cette
réaction de gens subjugués, j'ai pas
trop compris. J'avoue les les gens de
droite qui avaient besoin qu'un
Américain vienne à Munique pour leur
dire leur cas de vérité. Bon bah enfin,
il s'agirait de le voir soi-même. Et de
l'autre côté, la réaction qui l'autre
réaction qui m'a déplu, c'est les
réactions des Vierges des Far Rouché. Oh
quelle horreur ! Un américain vient nous
dire ça. Enfin, ça va, c'est on était
tous très contents quand Dominique de
Villepin à New York en 2003 est allé
dire ces quatre vérités au peuple
américain. Et on n pas dit que c'était
de l'ingérence. On n'a pas utilisé les
grands mots. C'est peut-être aussi
parfois une bonne chose dans l'histoire
qui ait des dirigeants euh au sein d'une
même civilisation, au sein de peuples
qui peuvent se ressembler dans leur
mauvais travers, dans les les enjeux
qu'ils sont en train de traverser, qui
puissent se dire les choses. Quand
Villepin fait la leçon aux Américains,
j'applaudis. J'ai adoré ce discours à
l'ONU. C'était très bien. Il leur
faisait vraiment un cours magistral.
Quand vous avez Kennedy qui d'ailleurs
corrélé à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur le le traité de l'Élysée
avec de Gaul quand Kennedy va à Berlin
pour dire ich bin ouais pardon pas
Robert Isbin Berliner quand il va dire
ça d'ailleurs juste c'est presque une
réponse à deux goin c'est de dire on est
chez nous ici c'est notre précarré et ne
pensez pas que vous allez prendre les
Allemands comme petit frère bref quand
Kennedy va à Berlin pour dirige Biden
anden Berliner qu'est-ce que c'est
incroyable c'est pire que Jay Devens il
arrive enfin c'est le protecteur qui
arrive sur son territoire, je suis
berlinois et qui fait un discours beau
discours qui a marqué l'histoire mais
personne n'a dit "Oh quelle ingérance
atroce, c'est horrible et cetera." En
tant que français, quand de Gaul va au
Québec et dit "Vive le Québec libre, on
applaudit des demains." Ça pour le coup,
c'est une belle ingérence du point de
vue canadien mais on applaudit parce que
voilà, on se dit c'était son rôle d'y
être et les Québécois s'en souviennent
avec émotion et ils se disent pas de go
a osé nous dire ça. Ils se disent "On a
un homme qui est venu qui a dit une
vérité aux Québécois. ça leur a
peut-être fait prendre conscience
eux-mêmes de certains enjeux ou alors
ils ont redécouvert des choses qu'il
savaient. Bref, donc ces deux réactions
m'ont un peu étonné de la part des
Européens. On embrasse fort les
Québécois, très fort d'ailleurs. Tout à
fait. Revenons à la Chine et aux
États-Unis, l'intelligence artificielle.
Hm hm. Là, on a éclusé le dossier
consommation énergétique. On a vu les
Chinois faire des réacteurs autorium
pour avoir encore un mix énergétique
encore plus robuste et polyvalent.
D'accord. Ouais.
quand ils vont avoir cette capacité de
calcul
gigantesque, tous les chiffrements vont
tomber, tout ce qu'on a envoyé chiffré
chez Pierre, Paul ou Jacques va vont
être interceptés. On va vers quoi selon
Sarafo et où va la France au milieu de
de ces deux titans qui souhaitent
prendre l'hégémonie mondiale ? Ouais.
Déjà les 50 prochaines années. Ouais. Je
commence par la fin déjà. Euh Fukuyama.
Non, c'est ça. Ouais. Fouuyama qui
pensait à la que c'était la fin de
l'histoire et puis l'histoire s'écrit
sous nos yeux. On a de la chance hein,
d'un point de vue intellectuel, on
assiste à des à des choses vraiment
magnifiques et on voit l'histoire
s'écrire sous sous nos yeux, pas
qu'entre les deux titans, mais même au
Moyen-Orient, même chez nous sur notre
continent. Enfin, on voit on voit des
choses que je pense la génération de nos
parents ne pensait pas qu'on vivrait.
Ouais.
à 31 32 ans de voir ça, d'avoir le
cerveau bien câblé, de voir cette
histoire.
Qu'est-ce que ça vous fait ? Ça c'est
une émulation intellectuelle juste. Vous
avez des enfants. Oui. Euh c'est pas
juste une émulation intellectuelle parce
qu'on est tous parties prenantes. On
n'est pas spectateur du monde dans
lequel on vit. Euh on est à l'intérieur,
on a des enfants, euh ils sont euh
dépendants de des décisions qu'on va
prendre. Donc déjà, je pense que ça doit
être quelque chose qui nous
responsabilise. Il peut y avoir quand on
quand on essaie de comprendre les enjeux
un aspect excitant dans le sens
intellectuel du terme, c'est-à-dire une
émulation, se dire "Waouh, ça s'écrit
sous nos yeux, on voit comme une partie
de de domino, enfin quelque chose qui
qui là pour le coup est stimulant parce
que soit on connaît l'histoire et on
voit les enchaînements et donc ça peut
être vraiment intéressant
intellectuellement, mais pour autant ça
doit pas devenir un jeu. C'est pas un
jeu. Parfois, il y a une forme de
légèreté. Je sais pas si on écoutait le
CI. Enfin, je trouve que parfois on a
des gens qui qui sont sur les plateaux
qui commandent ça. On a l'impression
qu'il commandent des matchs de foot.
L'Ukraine, la Russie, ils en parlent
avec une forme de légèreté qui parfois
peut paraître indécente. Donc quand on
dit émulation intellectuelle, faut pas
croire que pour autant ça soit léger. On
est responsable légè ou frénésie ? La
frénésie, ça c'est sûr. On sent une
frénésie. Ça bouge vite. Ça bouge vite.
Et en fait ce qu'il y a de peut-être
surprenant c'est que la génération de
nos parents, en tout cas des miens,
c'était une génération qui pensait que
l'histoire était fine. Vous avez cité
Fukuyama, on y croyait. Il y avait eu
Huntington, on le prenait pour un vieux
fou. On se disait "Non, c'est Fukuyama
qui a raison." À la chute du mur, c'est
fini. Les démocraties libérales, comme
on disait, ont gagné. L'empire
soviétique s'est effondré. Il y a un
modèle qui a appris le pas sur tous les
autres. Et ce modèle, croyait-on, à
l'époque, porte la paix, le commerce, la
liberté des peuples. Et donc euh il va
devenir de manière pérenne le la seule
voix de l'humanité et tout va bien se
passer. Il y aura plus d'histoire et
c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment-là qu'on
croit pouvoir tirer les fameuses
dividendes de la paix, désinvestir dans
notre outil militaire. Heureusement, on
a l'arsenal nucléaire mais pour le
reste, on a clairement désinvestis.
Quand le général de Villier avait dit à
Macron, "Dans peu de temps, la guerre
peut revenir sur le sol européen et on
est en train pour des raisons budgétaire
par ailleurs stupide quand on voit la
suite de l'histoire 1000 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires mais on a fait
partir ce pauvre général de Vil qui
disait la vérité prétendument par souci
de rigueur budgétaire son ridicule. Là
encore je disais tout à l'heure une
allocation irrationnelle des ressources
totalement irrationnelle. On donne de
l'argent pour l'égalité des sexes en
Irak, mais on donne pas de l'argent pour
notre armée qui n'aurait que 3 jours de
munition en cas de guerre de haute
intensité. Passons. Euh, je ferme cette
parenthèse. Donc, émulation
intellectuelle, oui, choc des Titans,
États-Unis, Chine, pas que ça, mais euh
néanmoins sans doute ce qui va dessiner
euh les années qu'on qu'on va vivre euh
nous nous tous. Euh si on regarde ça
d'un point de vue enfin quelle est
quelle est la logique de cet
affrontement, on s'aperçoit que dans
l'histoire, il est assez courant que les
deux grandes puissances du moment euh
s'affrontent quand il y a une puissance
émergente et une puissance déclinante.
La puissance émergente évidemment la
Chine, déclinante les États-Unis. Et on
s'aperçoit que la Chine en veut, qu'elle
s'arme. Alors qu'on a toujours dit que
bah dans le confuscianisme, il y avait
pas de guerre, que les Chinois ce serait
jamais euh une puissance militaire, que
c'était tout par le commerce et cetera.
Il y a des logiques dans l'histoire.
Peut-être même qu'ils le voulaient pas
mais ils y viennent et c'est la logique
de l'histoire. Moi, je pense qu'ils y
ont pensé et que on était un peu naïf là
encore. Euh donc sa première logique,
puissance émergente qui affronte la
puissance décline. Euh tout au long de
notre histoire, on l'a vu, à l'époque,
l'histoire se jouait beaucoup sur le
continent européen. Donc c'était la
France de Napoléon contre la
Grande-Bretagne avec la puissance de la
France de l'époque face à la puissance
industrielle naissante de la
Grande-Bretagne qui voulait affronter la
puissance d'entend. Après, on a eu
l'Allemagne qui était à son tour la
puissance émergente contre la grande
puissance britannique. Et si d'ailleurs
on observe ces exemples que je viens de
donner, on y voit aussi une autre
logique qu'on retrouve dans le conflit
chinues, c'est euh il y a un livre de
Carl Schmidth qui s'appelle Terre et mer
et qui explique comme la puissance une
puissance maritime très forte va
toujours être amenée presque malgré elle
en conflit avec une puissance maritime
très forte. puissance euh les États-Unis
évidemment puissance maritime énorme, la
plus grande de toutes qui a les deux
océans sur ces deux côtés et puis la
Chine, empire du milieu puissance
terrestre monumentale mastodonte. On
aurait pu dire aussi la Russie à
l'époque de la guerre froide contre les
US, aujourd'hui c'est la Chine. Donc ces
deux pôles qui s'affrontent, quelle que
soit la logique historique qu'on prend,
on voit que leur conflit est
inéluctable.
C'est ce que Obama a compris. Je pense
que d'autres avant lui l'avaient
compris. Euh c'est ce que même ce pauvre
Biden a entériné. Je sais pas s'il a
compris grand-chose mais en tout cas il
a entériné que c'était comme ça. Et il y
a eu ce fameux pivot américain. Les
l'Europe c'est derrière. Il faut
maintenant se tourner et mettre toutes
nos ressources vers le Pacifique. C'est
là-bas que ça se joue. Euh ça se joue
sur de multiples sujets évidemment. Je
pense que ce à quoi on va assister, vous
me demandiez ça, c'est un découplage de
ce ce duo qui se termine en duel.
sino-américain.
Je crois que c'était Warren Buffet qui
disait "Qu'est-ce que le capitalisme ?
C'est l'alliance de Walmart et du parti
communiste chinois. Walmart, la grande
enseigne euh le carrefour américain et
du parti communiste chinois." Il disait
en fait le capitalisme du du 21e siècle,
c'est ça, c'est l'alliance des deux. Et
là, on assiste, le Superug, c'est le
Ouais. le super. On assiste à un
découplage comme s'ils étaient
totalement imbriqués sur tous les
sujets.
L'un dépend de l'autre. Par exemple, les
États-Unis qui dépendent fortement de la
Chine pour importer évidemment, mais
aussi sur leur dettes très dépendants.
Et on a vu le marché des obligations le
jour où les Chinois ont dit "On va se
venger de l'annonce de Trump des 140 %
de droits de douane" et que se sont mis
à vendre la dette américaine dont ils
disposaient. Euh donc je pense que les
États-Unis étaient rentrés dans une
spirale vieille de peut-être 30 ans où
ils s'étaient totalement imbriqué à la
Chine et où ils avaient fait que tous
leurs intérêts étaient totalement soumis
au bon vouloir des Chinois.
production de téléphone portable, on a
parlé des semi-conducteurs, importation,
donc un modèle économique reposant quasi
exclusivement sur la consommation et
plus sur la production où le seul but a
été pendant 30 ans de faire baisser les
prix le plus possible. Et pour faire
baisser les prix, bah vous allez pas
faire travailler des Américains qui
exigent un certain niveau de salaire par
et de protection sociale et qui ont
certaines revendications. On les fait
pas travailler à n'importe quelle heure
ni n'importe comment. Euh vous qui
connaissez euh la Chine, vous allez dans
une usine chinoise. Euh on connaît pas
la Chine plus que ça. On n jamais
Pourtant l'ambassade nous a proposé
d'aller là-bas. Mais euh vous vous
sieriew, la chaîne, j'entends beaucoup
parler de la chaîne sur votre chaîne.
Tout à fait. Euh euh vous allez dans une
d'ailleurs recevoir un expert chinois
dans pas très longtemps. Très bien. Vous
allez dans une usine chinoise, je crois
pas qu'on puisse voir de de CGtistes.
Euh c'est ser pas Ouais. Donc fictif. Il
serait pas traité de la même manière que
chez nous.
Je pense qu'on les laisserait pas
bloquer Je pense qu'on les laisserait
pas bloquer le les trains aux horaires
de vacances si on peut parler comme ça
en Chine. Plaisanterie. Donc les
États-Unis ont totalement imbriqué leur
modèle et fait totalement dépendre leur
économie, leur technologie à une seule
nation la À une seule puissance Lion. On
va revenir sur le coup des grèves et des
trains parce que c'était gratuit. On va
y revenir. Allez-y, continuez le on va y
revenir. Euh donc des erreurs vieilles
de 30 ans ou peut-être euh encore une
fois aveuglement euh mauvaise vision de
ce qu' allait devenir l'économie. Je
parlais de la France tout à l'heure en
disant on a cru à la fin des usines, on
a cru à l'économie de service et on
s'est dit que c'était ça l'avenir, le
développement, que la future croissance
reposerait sur ça. On y a cru, les
États-Unis y ont cru et on voit nos deux
nations, mais globalement tout le monde
occidental, il y a des exceptions quand
même, qui est passé d'un modèle de
production à un modèle de consommation
où l'unique objectif c'est de vendre à
Bakou des produits en pensant que c'est
comme ça qu'on va défendre le pouvoir
d'achat des gens. Et là soudain, on a
Trump qui arrive. Vous croyez à ça ? Pas
du tout. Mais alors, pourquoi vous le
dites pas direct ? Les élites
américaines ont fait baisser les prix à
gogo pour contenter avec des slips à 2
dollars. Exactement. C'est une
catastrophe. Crois pas du tout. Ils ont
pu ils ont vous êtes plus rapide que
moi. Moi j'arrivais à la conclusion
maintenant. J'étais en train de dire que
Trump arrive après ces 30 années
d'erreur et que maintenant il commence à
dire droit de douane. Et là vous
entendez nos experts sur toutes les
chaînes infos. Ah les premiers qui vont
payer c'est les Américains. Vous
entendez ça toute la journée comme moi.
Les premiers à subir la politique de
Trump ça sera les Américains. Pourquoi ?
Parce que effectivement quand on
augmente les droits de douane, il y a un
objectif, c'est de renchérir les prix
des produits importés pour rendre plus
compétitifs les prix des produits qui
ont été faits chez nous. Donc oui, c'est
même l'objectif de faire monter les prix
des produits qu'on importe. Et ceux qui
ne voient que par le petit bout de la
lornette se disent "Ce sera une
catastrophe pour le consommateur
américain ou pour le consommateur
français si on fait ça demain chez
nous." Casse pauvre. Mais ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas voir, pauvre, riche, peu
importe d'ailleurs parce que même un
riche qui veut s'acheter une voiture euh
qui vient euh d'un pays et qui l'a
importé, il va voir le prix de la
voiture qui va force fortement
augmenter. Qu'il s'en cogn un peu, hein.
Le consommateur, parlons euh quel que
soit son niveau de vie, mais dire ça,
c'est ne voir chaque individu, tout ce
que tout ce que nous sommes uniquement
comme des consommateurs. C'est oublier
le travailleur, c'est oublier le
citoyen. Donc oui, l'intérêt du
consommateur peut être atteint si jamais
un produit importé coûte demain plus
cher. C'est clair que si demain on dit
acheter des t-shirt chez Zara, ça
coûtera plus 12 € mais ça coûtera demain
30 €. Bah oui, ceux qui allaient acheter
des t-shirts chez Zara vont devoir payer
plus cher dans une autre marque. Ou dans
une autre marque. Je dis je donne un
exemple. Et si le coût de la tonne
d'azote explose ? Ouais. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? Attendez, je finis juste sur ça.
Important. Euh si on considère les gens
que comme des consommateurs, alors on
aura toujours peur d'utiliser ces
remèdes-là et on se dira toujours, il
vaut mieux continuer dans notre roue. ne
faire comme politique économique et
comme seule politique économique
toujours baisser les prix en important
des produits, ne plus les fabriquer chez
nous parce qu'on narrive pas à être
compétitif par rapport à un pays comme
la Chine et quand bien même on
supprimerait tous nos codes, quand bien
même on baisserait les impôts, ce qu'il
faut faire impérativement en France de
même si on faisait tout ça, on
narriverait toujours pas à être aussi
compétitif qu'un travailleur chinois.
Bon, ça je pense qu'il faut l'admettre,
on n'a pas envie de vivre comme eux tout
simplement. même si on supprimait le
code de l'environnement dans son
ensemble, on ne serait pas aussi pollue
que peut l'être la Chine. Et on n'a pas
envie de vivre dans ce monde-là. Je
pense ni vous, ni moi, ni ceux qui nous
écoutent. On n'a pas envie d'avoir le
modèle chinois pour exemple. Donc alors
pourquoi on achète chinois ? Bah c'est
la bonne question parce qu'on a fait une
erreur. C'est-à-dire qu'on s'est dit
je je redis alors à chaque fois que je
dis on je parle des élites occidentales,
françaises, américaines. En
l'occurrence, je parlais des deux pays
qui ont fait cette même erreur, qui ont
désindustrialisé leur pays en se disant
ça vaut plus le coup de produire chez
nous. Chez nous, c'est trop cher. Le
seul objectif, c'est que les produits
soient moins chers. Puisque le seul
objectif, c'est que les produits soient
moins chers, il faut qu'on aille les
faire produire dans des pays où ça
coûtera moins cher. Donc des gens payés
au lance-pierre, pas de code, pas de
norme, pas de taxe. Enfin bon, pas de
taxe. J'ai tenté qu'on puisse parler de
taxe dans un pays communiste très
particulier. Donc euh ce modèle là, je
pense que là il y a il y a une fenêtre
d'ouverture pour qu'il se close. Trump
c'est ce qu'il se ferme. C'est ce qu'il
se ferme, si vous préférez ce mot. C'est
ce que Trump essaie de faire en mettant
des droits de douane sur les produits
importés de la Chine. Et donc là, les
gens qui ne voi que par le petit bout de
la lornette vous disent "Ah, le
consommateur américain va payer." Encore
une fois et j'en reviens là, si on ne
voit
les citoyens, les Français que comme des
consommateurs, on est perdu. Que devient
le pouvoir d'achat du consommateur quand
il a perdu son travail ?
À quoi est-ce que ça nous reviendrait de
pouvoir continuer d'acheter à 2 € des
produits si on perd son emploi, qu'on
est au chômage et que l'industrie dans
laquelle on travaillait n'existe plus ?
il y a plus de pouvoir d'achat et on
s'aperçoit que c'est une politique
totalement absurde sur laquelle on a
tout fait reposer qui dont aujourd'hui
les effets sont en train de nous sauté
au visage. Alors ça veut pas dire que ce
sera facile parce que c'est jamais
facile de revenir sur 30 ans d'erreur en
100 jours seulement mais je pense qu'on
peut en tout cas commencer que c'est la
vision stratégique en tout cas qui est
celle aujourd'hui des États-Unis. Je
sais pas d'ailleurs si Trump a été aussi
pointu dans sa réflexion que ceux que
j'ai pu lire et qui l'ont conseillé. Je
pense notamment à un homme qui s'appelle
Stéphane Miran euh Harvard, professeur
un peu plus de 40 ans, qui a été formé
par les conseillers de Rean, qui a écrit
un papier en novembre 2024 avant
l'élection de Trump, juste avant, dans
le dans le un papier dans lequel il
donnait toute la stratégie en réalité
que Trump est en train d'appliquer
aujourd'hui. Peut-être qu'il
l'appliquera pas à la lettre, peut-être
que d'autres conseillers prendront le
pas sur lui, je ne sais pas. Mais en
tout cas, quand on lit ce papier, on se
dit certains Américains ont compris où
allait le monde pour reprendre votre
expression du début, ont compris comment
est-ce qu'ils pouvaient reprendre leur
destin en main. Ça passe par retrouver
une économie productive,
réindustrialiser leur pays, reprendre la
main sur leur énergie, reprendre la main
sur leur monnaie. Et là, on s'aperçoit
de je crois tous les fondamentaux qu'on
a abordé depuis tout à l'heure, les
États-Unis seront pour nous un
laboratoire grandeur nature. Est-ce que
ça marche ? Est-ce que la Chine est déjà
plus forte que ce qu'on croyait ? Est-ce
qu'on arrive à remettre chez soi toute
une industrie tech ? C'est aussi
l'objectif, c'est même l'un des
objectifs majeurs, vous veniez sur ça
tout à l'heure. Est-ce qu'il arrive
demain à devenir plus indépendant ?
Est-ce que ce découplage finalement a
une chance de succès ou est-ce que la
Chine est plus forte que ce qu'on
croyait ? Est-ce que vous entendez par
découplage la multipolarité comme disent
les Russes ? Non, j'entendais par
découplage le fait euh d'être de moins
en moins dépendant euh d'une seule
puissance dans laquelle on a mis presque
tout notre destin entre ses mains. Et
nous aussi. D'ailleurs, vous connaissez
le le vieux proverbe de guerre
économique ? Un chômeur coûte plus cher
qu'un mort.
Waouh ! Vous comprenez ? Ouais. Pourquoi
? Pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils disent ça ? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi
un chômeur coûte plus cher qu'un mort ?
Bah parce qu'on doit continuer de payer
pour lui
alors. Alors dur. Ouais dur. Horrible.
Vous vous rappelez de Jackal qui disait
qu'il fallait euthanasier les vieux
parce qu'il coûtait trop cher. Dur ça
aussi. Non je me rappelle pas. Quel g
ilalie ? Ah bonne question. Je pense que
c'est ce que les gens lui répondaient
d'ailleurs. Attention parce qu'on
vieillit tous.
C'est très important qu'on garde nos
vieux parce que ça permet de combler le
fossé intergénérationnel quand il y a
des générations qui se laissent porter
par trop de bombenance facile et trop
d'énergie facile. Passons passons nous
la France au milieu de l'Europe au
milieu de cette dislocation géopolitique
mondiale drapé dans la l'étendard de la
vertu. On défend nos valeurs. Bla bla
bla bla bla.
Ils en sont où les patriotes ? Je ne
parle pas des nationalistes. Quand je
vois la droite Pierre, Paul, Jackes,
faire campagne de boutiquier, faire
comme un chin. Vous êtes de droite vous
? Non. Ouais. Les gens de la droite, ils
vont continuer de faire un peu comme les
autres partis politiques, c'est-à-dire
chacun sa petite boutique, chacun son
petit commerce. Hm. Chacun sa petite
chapelle, continue à faire vivre ses
petites équipes. Ouais. Comprenez ma
question ? Bah tout à fait. Alors
forcément, je me sens pas je me sens pas
visée et je partage votre diagnostic. Je
me sens pas visé parce que ben 81
Jacques reconquête, c'est le parti le
plus jeune. Nous, on a commencé en
disant justement on veut pas être comme
comme tous les les politiciens qui ne
pensent qu'à faire vivre la maison,
c'est pas le but du tout. Sinon, bah, je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure, on avait
tellement de choses plus confortables en
réalité à faire. Si c'est pour des
prébandes, pour une vie confortable et
cetera, c'est vraiment pas le bon choix.
Ni pour Éric Zemour qui gagnait
parfaitement sa vie, qui en terme d'ego,
d'orgueil était parfaitement comblé.
Bah, je pense que tout le monde se
souvient de ce qu'il faisait sur C News
par le passé et cetera, de son interview
sur Syerview. De son interview sur
Sinkerview. Euh 3 millions de vues euh
que vous l'aviez, c'est là où on s'était
rencontré d'ailleurs. Tout à fait. On
s'était vu pour la première fois. Euh et
euh et moi je vous ai dit, j'étais
franchement enfin j'avais rien à
demander de plus à la vie quoi. Pas de
rien en orgueil à chercher, pas de
moyens financiers enfin on espérait.
Donc euh si c'est pour la boutique, moi
je comprends pas. C'est-à-dire que je
ferai 1000 autres choses en fait si
c'était pour des intérêts matériels.
Donc si on le fait, oui, il y a quand
même une part de de sacrifice, ça peut
faire grandir lequant et j'ai pas du
tout envie de l'impression de donner
l'impression que je veux que les gens me
plaignent. C'est pas vraiment pas du
tout le cas. Au contraire, j'ai de
l'énergie, j'adore ce que je fais, je le
fais parce queil faut le faire et que
j'ai pas envie de faire autre chose.
Donc je cherche aucune compassion. Des
coups à prendre.
Bah oui, d'un côté on peut dire ça, mais
de l'autre voilà, il faut pas faire
causette quoi. On le fait parce qu'on
veut le faire. Euh moi je pense que ça
se voit que je suis contente de le
faire, que j'y mets l'énergie, que j'ai
pas envie d'être ailleurs. Donc voilà,
j'aime pas les politiques qui se
plaignent. Il y a tellement de gens qui
souffrent bien plus que je suis députée
européenne. Je connais plein de gens qui
qui aimeraient plutôt avoir ma vie que
des conditions plus difficiles
d'exercice. Donc je suis pas à plaindre.
Quoi qu'il en soit et Pierre Paul Jacou
quoi qu'il en soit la droite la droite
le monde politique même dans son
ensemble d'ailleurs tout à l'heure je
vous disais ils réfléchissent plus par
rapport au sondage que par rapport à
leur propre à leur propre conviction
s'il y en a en fait j'ai l'impression
que c'est quelque chose aussi qui est
passé presque totalement en dehors de de
la classe politique à savoir est-ce
qu'on réfléchit encore un peu au sujet
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment se pencher
sur quelque chose en se disant bah sur
ça je sais pas j'ai pas d'opinion voilà
les gens pensent ça en majorité mais moi
je sais pas encore. J'ai besoin de me
former avant de répondre.
Qu'est-ce que je pense sincèrement de ça
? Et je pense que si on se pose pas
vraiment cette question, si la seule
question qu'on qu'on se pose, c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire ? Bah, on
devient comme tout comme tous les
autres, comme toute la classe politique
qui nous conduit jusqu'ici, c'est-à-dire
dans le sens du vent, ne fait rien,
subit les évolutions du monde parce que
enfin, il faut quand même un peu de
courage par exemple pour dire "On
accepte que les prix des produits
importés montent." Je reprends juste cet
exemple. Il faut un peu de courage pour
dire ça. Il faut un peu de courage pour
dire le niveau scolaire aujourd'hui est
totalement déplorable et et il va
falloir faire beaucoup d'efforts, faire
travailler vos enfants dur. Vous allez
faire des devoirs tard le soir, il faut
un peu d'effort pour demander ça aux
gens. Je pense que est-ce que les gens
ils ont le temps de faire ça quand ils
bossent pour un salaire de misère qui se
tapent 2 heures de transport en commun à
retour qui se font virer leur bagnole
parce que elle est trop sale, trop
machin, trop ils ont pas les sous.
Ouais. Bahà, aujourd'hui, vous avez des
gens qui quand ils pensent à l'avenir de
leurs enfants sont obligés de faire ça
et ils en font même plus parce que
l'école ne le fait plus du tout. Nous,
on a des aspirations banales si vous
voulez. Moi, vous m'avez dit "Vous êtes
de droite". Je vous ai dit oui, mais en
réalité quand j'ai réfléchi, je me dis
je me dis de droite parce que tout le
reste de la société renvoie tout ça à la
droite mais moi j'ai des aspirations de
femme banale. Ne pas avoir peur quand je
sors dans la rue. vouloir que mes
enfants aillent à l'école pour apprendre
quelque chose, vouloir que les
professeurs n'aient pas de boule au
ventre en entrant dans une classe.
Vouloir être dans un pays où on peut
avoir un rendez-vous chez un docteur
quand on est malade. Ne pas attendre 9h
aux urgences. Vous voyez ? Enfin, tout
ça, si on parle de manière non
politisée, vous me dites "C'est pas de
droite, c'est pas de gauche, tout le
monde devrait vouloir ça." C'est banal
en fait. En réalité, quand j'étais
jeune, je savais pas que j'étais de
droite. 32 ans. Oui. Quand j'ai quand
quand je dis quand j'étais jeune, je
pensais à mes 15 ans dans le bus quand
je traversais la scène Saint-Denis et
que je me disais juste "C'est pas normal
de vivre comme ça." En fait, on s'y
habitue. Je m'habitue à mettre mon sac
en bandouillère, à ne jamais sortir mon
téléphone. Si j'ai mes écouteurs, je me
dis "Ah, je suis en train de chercher,
je vais me fairequiéter, c'est certain."
ne pas s'habiller comme on veut, garder
ses chaussures dans son sac parce qu'on
se dit il faut pas s'habiller comme ça,
c'est de la provoque. Enfin, tout ça,
toute cette accoutumance où on se dit
euh presque comme si c'était un
phénomène météorologique, ça nous est
tombé dessus, on peut rien y faire, on
l'accepte, on doit vivre comme ça. Et je
pense que c'est ça a été longtemps le
plus grand drame en fait, cette forme de
fatalisme. On doit vivre comme ça, c'est
presque normal. Et je pense que ce qui
fait du bien parfois, c'est juste de se
dire "On n'est pas obligé." Il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ne vivent pas
ainsi. Nos parents ne vivaient pas comme
ça. Ils ont eu de la chance. Euh c'est
il faut aller vivre en Corse. Ouais, en
Corse. Il y a encore certains villages.
Mais vous voyez, on en est réduit là. En
fait, moi je crois plus au aux solutions
d'évitement individuel. Pour vous donner
un exemple triste, euh vous avez
tous ces français euh qui a y a des
livres de Christophe de Christophe
Guilou qui parlent de ça. Tous ces
français qui vivaient en banlieu et qui
ont fui les banlieux pour aller vivre
ailleurs. Moi c'est mon cas par exemple
même si lieu pour des raisons
financières non pour des raisons
sécuritaires, pour des raisons
culturelles parce que la boule au ventre
tout simplement en fait voilà juste je
je le dis avec des termes pour le coup
assez pudique mais oui on a peur un peu
un peu un peu pognon de partir de vivre
de de bah c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire en fait c'est que ce qu'il a les
moyens de partir oui clairement ou mais
ce qu'il y a de triste c'est que
j'allais vous dire que c'est même pas
forcément des gens riches en fait quand
vous voyez les banlieux qui se sont
vidés c'est pas pour que que les gens
aillent vivre dans le 16e, c'est parce
que les gens sont allés dans ce que
Christophe Guil donc appelle la France
périphérique. Ça coûte parfois même
moins cher que les banlieux mais c'est
excentré. Vous avez pas de métropole à
côté, vous vivez dans un désert médical,
ce qu'on appelle parfois les zones
rurales ou le péri urbain, donc des
grandes zones pavionnaires qui coûtent
pour le coup parfois même moins cher que
la banlieue mais vous avez fait un
sacrifice et que vous avez accepté de
vivre loin de la ville. Et bah quand on
regarde l'histoire de France toutes les
années 50, c'est l'exode rural. Tout le
monde veut vivre en ville. La chanson
magnifique de Jeanferra euh la montagne,
il quittent un le un le pays pour s'en
aller gagner leur vie loin de la ville
où ils sont nés. Donc tout le monde s'en
va, tout le monde quitte sa campagne et
va vivre dans les villes. Et puis
soudain, si vous si vous si on regarde
l'histoire récente de France, vous avez
dans les années 2000 un phénomène
presque inverse où les gens ne
retournent pas dans les zones rurales
mais dans le péri urbain et donc il
quittent les banlieux. Et ce
phénomène-là dans les livres de Guilu,
il vous l'explique par "On se sentait
plus chez nous".
On avait peur, on avait l'impression
qu'on était plus les bienvenus alors
qu'on avait grandi ici et cetera et
cetera. Je vous dis, moi j'en suis
partie, mes parents ils sont, j'y
retourne tous les weekends, donc je suis
encore bah attachée et dans la réalité
de de ce qui de ce qui est devenu la
scène Saint-Denis. Pourquoi papa maman ?
Euh ils sont donc mon père chef
d'entreprise, il a été longtemps
commerçant et ma mère est est coach et
avant elle travaillait dans un
laboratoire. Coach euh coach sportif.
Non, pas sportif, euh coach euh de vie.
Ouais. Euh et euh et donc j'y j'y
retourne j'y retourne tous les weekends.
Ça aide à à connecter en fait. Bah
voilà, je sais ce que ce que vivent les
gens. Je raconte pas des choses
d'idéologue ou euh comme certains
parfois parlent d'immigration de manière
très désincarnée. Bah, j'essaie que ça
ne soit pas mon cas. Donc je vous disais
des gens qui ont tenté de fuir. Et
pourquoi c'était triste ? Je reviens à
ça. Euh Guiloui donc raconte cette
France, les banlieux, ils quittent les
banlieux parce qu'ils veulent fuir les
conséquences de cette folle politique
migratoire d'accueil où ils se sentent
plus à l'aise, ils se sentent plus en
sécurité, bref, ils ont ils ont le
sentiment qu'ils ne sont plus chez eux.
Ils s'en vont dans le péri urbain. Et
là, vous voyez un drame récent comme le
drame de Créol.
Vous voyez ce petit Thomas rugby man 17
ans, pas d'histoire, pas un gosse à
problème, rien. Enfin voilà, le garçon
normal de la France normale qui fait qui
fait pas d'histoire quoi, qui casse pas
les vitrines et tout. Et ce garçonlà
trouve la mort dans une soirée dans un
bal de village. Le truc le plus banal du
monde, personne pourrait imaginer perdre
son fils dans un bal de village à
Créole. Donc tout à l'heure vous disiez
ou alors vivre en Corse, mais je me dis
voilà, on en est réduit là en fait à se
dire il y a peut-être encore quelques
zones où on peut être en sécurité mais
finalement pour combien de temps ?
Est-ce qu'on peut y croire vraiment ?
Est-ce que des exemples comme ça
finalement ne nous disent pas non, il
faut un surceaut collectif, il y aura
pas de solution individuelle. Il faut
pas s'imaginer que on va essayer de fuir
euh dans telle telle rue de Paris, dans
tel village et que finalement les
conséquences ne nous sauteront jamais au
visage. Si vous vous êtes formé au sport
de combat, vous avez appris à tirer,
vous avez une bombe lacrimau dans votre
sac, vous avez un noun chakou dans le
sac à dos ? Non non non non non. Bah on
espère quand même ne pas avoir besoin de
ça.
Non mais oui, ça m'est arrivé plein de
fois de bah j'aurais pu en avoir besoin
mais mais non, je l'ai jamais fait
final. Vous êtes pour ou contre le port
d'arme ? Plutôt pour euh plutôt pour
plutôt pour en fait une une réforme
pénale qui nous on avait appelé ça dans
notre programme la défense excusable et
on disait qu'il y avait un droit à la
légitime défense. Par exemple pour
quelqu'un qui se fait braquer chez lui
dans la nuit et qui se retrouve à devoir
défendre sa famille. Je peux poser une
question ? Je suis désolé.
Imaginez-vous, il y a quelqu'un chez
vous, il a la dalle. Il a pas à manger,
il pense qu'il y a personne dans la
maison, il dit qu'il va se faire un fri.
Il y a quelqu'un qui rentre chez moi.
Ouais. Il rentre chez vous, il y a
personne. Il voit pas de lumière, il
crève la dalle. Il va dans la cuisine,
il se fait le frigo. Ouais. Vous lui
répondez au 12 au 9 mm. Moi perso.
Ouais. Non mais que vous avez compris la
situation. Ouais. Ouais, j'ai compris.
Est-ce que je Comment je le renvoie de
chez moi ? Oui. Bah imaginez-vous s'il y
a quelqu'un qui rentre chez vous parce
qu'il a faim,
est-ce que je mettre un coup de 12 c'est
une bonne idée ? Bah moi, je mettrai pas
un coup de 12 he je vous ai dit j'ai ni
d'armes ni enfin non je me vois je me
vois pas tirer sur quelqu'un
personnellement. Je pense que
c'est ce qu'on attend d'un d'un père de
famille non de défendre sa maison.
Quelqu'un qui a faim en principe dans
une société normale, il frappe à la
porte, il demande. Euh je pense qu'on
est quand même dans un pays où vous
appelez le 115 et vous êtes assez bien
lotifier, vous avez la soupe populaire.
Euh ouais ou pas ? Parce que parce que
c'est des dispositifs qui sont très très
pris. C'est d'ailleurs un gros problème
même pour ceux qui sont pour l'accueil
migratoire massif et qui se disent on a
plus les capacités même avec une vision
très très humanitaire. Enfin pass en
tout cas quelqu'un un homme bien qui a
faim, il rentre pas dans une maison par
infraction en prenant le frigo. Donc
oui, il mérite quand même qu'on s'en
défende. C'est un danger. Donc pour le
port d'armes, je vous laisse terminer.
Ouais, je disais la défense excusable.
Je pense qu'il faut donner au droit
donner le le droit aux gens de défendre
leur famille, de défendre leur maison et
sortir de la logique où finalement le
coupable serait celui qui se défend.
C'est aussi le cas pour la police, ça
s'appliquerait aussi à la police où vous
voyez des scènes ubuesques et
franchement qui font parfois mal au
cœur. On voit un policier qui pourtant a
son arme, qui a appris à tirer, qui est
mieux armé à tirer, qui tire cinq
cartouches par an. Tout à fait, vous
avez raison. Mais qui pour le coup est
en principe mieux éduqué au métier de la
sécurité que le voyou qu'il a en face et
qui a passé sa vie à crier. Parle de
quel policier ? celui qui sait faire
recruter avec 5 c de moyenne. Non non
non, je parle juste de leur capacité à
se défendre en principe de voyou qui
viennent les agresser. Et quand vous
voyez que ces policiers là ont peur, ils
sortent pas leur armes parce qu'ils se
disent en fait si juste je sors mon
arme, c'est l'IGPN ce soir, c'est la
garde à vue et puis enfin c'est c'est
l'prumiliation,
ils sont arrêtés comme des délinquents
quand bien même ils défendraient leur
vie. Donc vous vous pouvez être menacé
de mort. C'est déjà arrivé d'ailleurs,
vous avez des faits d'hiver où des
policiers se font tirer dessus et on
leur dit "Mais il a sorti une arme,
pourquoi vous êtes pas défendu ?" Des
gardiens de prison ou des gardien de
prison. Euh quand vous êtes dans la rue
et que vous êtes chargé du maintien de
l'ordre, en principe quelqu'un sort son
arme, ça devrait être un réflexe dans
n'importe quel pays. C'est un réflexe.
Vous prenez des pays civilisés, hein,
vous prenez l'Italie, c'est le cas. Vous
prenez l'Espagne. Bon, ils ont une
politique, ils ont une police un peu
dure, mais vous prenez n'importe quel
pays, quelqu'un sort son arme. Il est
évident que la police va sortir son arme
en retour. En France, ils ont peur. Ils
ont vraiment peur parce qu'ils se disent
"C'est moi qui vais prendre. Lui, il
sera libéré dans une heure et moi je
vais dormir en garde à vue et je vais
devoir dire à ma femme qui va me dire
"Mais pourquoi tu as fait ça ? Tu aurais
jamais dû tirer et cetera." Ils ont
vraiment peur et donc parfois au péril
de leur vie, cette cette peur panique de
de de la procédure qui va suivre peut
parfois les mettre en danger de mort.
Donc oui, pour la défense excusable.
On entend beaucoup dire que la France se
mexicanise.
Votre analyse.
C'est vrai hein. J'ai entendu Pierre
Noisa ce matin sur sur BFM. Brillante
Pierre Noisa qui est la tête d'une
société de cryptom de cryptomonnaie.
Brillante interview. Ouais brillante. 20
minutes de 9h à 9h20 ce matin chez pas
sur BFM. Ouais ouais de 9h à 9h20 pas
ça. Brillant. Euh sa fille a échappé à
un rat à la mexicaine. Terrible, on
entend fort. Elle est enceinte. Elle est
enceinte. Vraiment terri
et il y a un commerçant Nabil je crois.
Ouais. Qui l'a défendu à coup
d'extincteur. Héroïque pour le coup. Euh
mexicanisme. Oui, je pense que je pense
qu'on peut dire ça. Franchement, il y a
tellement de formules coupé machin.
Ouais. Euh ça c'est sur alors vraiment
surtout pour euh pour le secteur crypto
en ce moment, c'est vraiment cher payer
euh tout ce qui tout ce qui leur arrive.
Mais même d'autres hein, les homejacking
et même d'autres he même pas sinus on se
rappelle de Kim Kardashian c'est assez
vaste en fait dès qu'il y a une richesse
qui se perçoit un peu. Les influenceurs
qui mett qui montrent leur argent sur
Insta, certains youtubeurs euh qui qui
on a pas d'argent donc ça va.
D'ailleurs, financez-nous sur Tipi, on a
besoin de vous pour rester indépendant.
Ah quelle transition ! C'est fort, très
fort. Euh donc Mexicanisme, oui, on peut
dire ça. On peut dire ça, je vois
exactement pourquoi il veut le dire.
C'est ces pratiques de gangsters euh qui
séquestre, qui demande des des rançons,
qui coupent des doigts. Enfin bon,
vraiment l'atrocité. On se demande on se
demande comment on a pu arriver à un tel
degré de sauvagerie. Il y a plusieurs
autres phénomènes. On peut aussi dire
que la France se libise dans un certain
sens, c'est-à-dire c'est Liban. Est-ce
que si je suis déjà allée ? Non, mais je
connais un peu l'histoire du Liban. Mais
j'aimerais beaucoup. J'aimerais beaucoup
m'y rendre, j'ai jamais pu y aller. Se
Libanise euh le Liban, ce pays dont on
disait il y a à peine 40 ans que c'était
la Suisse du Moyen-Orient, un pays qui
connaissait une très belle croissance
économique, où il y avait vraiment une
belle harmonie entre différentes
communautés. Ça ça fonctionnait à ce
moment-là. Et puis soudain, un pays où
vous vous rappelez de la phrase de de
Gérard Colomb, il disait "Aujourd'hui,
on est côte à côte, demain on sera face-
à face."
Gérard Colon ancien ministre qui a lâché
son ministère socialiste. Donc un homme
de gauche socialiste qui a été ministre
de l'intérieur qui a été un le maire
historique de Lyon qui est décédé je
crois il y a de ou 3 ans et qui avait
dit cette phrase ça avait beaucoup
marqué parce que c'était un socialiste
et en fait lui il expliquait quand je
suis arrivée à la tête du ministère de
l'intérieur je pouvais plus nier
l'indéniable je pouvais plus être dans
le déni
soir des services. J'ai vu ce qui se
passait sur l'ensemble du territoire et
il est et c'est là qu'il ache cette
phrase qui est très dure et et
pessimiste. Aujourd'hui, on est côte à
côte et demain, on sera face à face. Le
Liban, c'est devenu ça et c'est
malheureusement aussi ce qu'on est en
train de devenir. Donc oui, on peut dire
mexicanise par les procédés qu'utilisent
certains gangsters. On peut dire
Libanise par la tournure que prennent
les événements et la communautarisation.
Moi, j'aimerais bien qu'on puisse dire
demain euh que la France prend un autre
modèle que le Liban ou que le Mexique,
un pays pas si loin du Mexique, le
Salvador. Euh exemple que je trouve
alors pour le coup, si on peut aller un
peu sur sur des solutions, exemple que
je trouve très frappant, si je peux le
raconter, je prends je prends 3 minutes.
Faites donc Vous avez un homme qui
s'appelle Naï Bouqueleé
qui prend la tête du Salvador. Il a 37
ans au moment où il devient président du
Salvador.
Pour y arriver, il fait une sorte de
pacte avec le diable. Donc Le Salvador,
pays gangrainé par la mafia. Des
gangsters qui pululent, qui occupent
tout le pays, qui soumettent l'économie.
Le moindre commerçant est soumis à au
désir desérat de de ces gangsters. Pour
vous donner un exemple de pratiqu, mais
c'est des pratiques courantes chez les
mafieux. Ils vont dans chaque boutique,
dans chaque commerce et ils leur disent
"Vous avez besoin d'un garde devant chez
vous ?" Le type dit "Non, j'ai pas
besoin d'un garde, je suis pas en
danger." Et dans la nuit, il est braqué,
les vitres sont complètement
plastiquées. Et donc le lendemain, il se
dit "Ah bah oui, c'est vrai que j'ai
besoin d'un garde." Et donc ils
soumettent toute l'économie. On a une
économie gangrainée, des prébandes dans
tous les sens. Bref, un pays mafieux,
Salvador. Et là, vous avez Bouké qui
arrive au pouvoir. Donc, je disais 37
ans, il fait un peu un pact avec ses
gangsters en leur disant "Je vous laisse
continuer les trafics notamment les
trafics de drogue, mais en échange, je
veux plus d'homicide." Faut savoir qu'à
l'époque, le Salvador est le pays
considéré comme le plus dangereux au
monde par tous les instituts
statistiques. Vous avez des homicides
partout. Si vous vous promenez dans la
rue et que vous avez une tête qui a
l'air d'être une tête d'un gang rival,
bam, des vitres qui descendent et on
vous tire dessus dans la rue, pas de
justice, tout est gangrainé. Euh, il
fait ce ce deal un peu moche où il dit
"Les trafics vous continuez mais les
homicides vous arrêtez." Top ! il arrive
à gagner grâce à leur soutien tacite.
Peu de temps passe et là une nuit dans
la capitale du Salvador vous avez d'un
coup 80 homicides, un chiffre énorme
pour une population plutôt petite. Et il
pour juste vous donner le degré de de
d'atrocité de ce que commettaient ces
gangsters salvadoriens, un de leurs
modes opératoires c'était de mettre le
feu à des bus scolaires et quand les
enfants voulaient descendre pour
échapper aux flammes, il les
mitraillent.
Et c'était une des manières de
traumatiser l'opinion publique pour
obtenir tout ce qu'il voulait de la part
du pouvoir. Prébande, justice pénale
totalement inexistante pour ne jamais
être condamné et cetera et cetera. Donc
c'est vous dire l'état du pays que prend
en main ce bouquellé. Et une nuit donc
80 homicides dans la même nuit et là
bouqueleté 10 c'est terminé. Le deal est
rompu. Vous avez voulu continuer de
jouer alors que je vous avais dit qu'il
y avait un pacte et que c'était la fin
des homicides contre les Salvadoriens.
C'est terminé. Et là, en 7 mois, ça
commence, le rêve commence. En 7 mois,
il construit 70000 places de prison.
70000 en 7 mois. Pour vous donner un
exemple, Emmanuel Macron, il a depuis 8
ans, il a construit 5000 places de
prison. Il en avait promis 15000. Il a
même pas réussi. Les rivins, ils en
veulent pas. Et mais est-ce qu'on doit
leur laisser le choix ? Vous savez qu'il
y a des rivrins qui veulent pas des
éoliennes et qu'on a créé un droit
spécial pour réussir à dire on va
imposer quand même des éoliennes qu'on
ait juste le même droit pour les prisons
que pour les éoliennes. Et je pense que
ça ira déjà beaucoup mieux. Et en
réalité, vous en trouvez des élus un peu
attachés au bien commun qui vous disent
"Mais mettez-les chez moi". Robert
Menard, d'ailleurs, c'est ce qu'il
disait à Macron. Il disait "Moi, je veux
bien, mettez-les chez moi." Et vous
savez, l'État français, il peut être
très fort quand il veut, droit de
préemption, ceci, cela et cetera.
Exproprié, exproprié quand il veut pour
construire des trucs aberrents. Et puis
là, soudain, ah mais non, les élus ne
veulent pas, c'est l'État qui veut pas,
ils veulent pas construire de prison. Il
y a une idéologie derrière, si vous
voulez, on y reviendra. Il y a des
circulaires, c'est très clair. C'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose de fumeux que
j'invente. Il y a une circulaire très
claire signée par Tobira. et qui dit au
juges "Ne mettez pas les gens en prison,
préférez toujours les peines
alternatives." Donc en réalité, on nous
fait croire on met pas les gens en
prison parce qu'il y a pas de place. En
réalité, on ne construit pas de place
parce qu'on ne veut pas mettre les gens
en prison. Et les les les modes
alternatifs euh dit les modes de
détention alternatif, bracelet
électronique, vous devez pointer au
commissariat et cetera sont préférés
parce que les gens s'imaginent que si
vous allez en prison, vous allez jamais
vous réinsérer. Mais comme si le seul
objectif de la prison, c'était la
réinsertion. Alors qu'en réalité,
l'objectif de la prison, c'est de mettre
hors d'état de nuire des gens qui sont
dangereux pour la société. C'est déjà
ça. Si en plus ça peut permettre de se
réinsérer, c'est du bonus. Mais
l'objectif primordial, c'est mettre la
société en sécurité. Je reviens à
Bouqualé parce que c'est intéressant
même sur la philosophie carcérale.
Déjà visité des prisons françaises ?
Oui, tout à fait. À Nanter J'ai même
fait des concours d'éloquences avec des
détenus à Nanter figurez-vous.
Incroyable, hein ?
Donc
bouquer 7 mois 70000 places de prison et
là il décide d'enfermer tous les
gangsters qui étaient en train de
s'aborder son pays. Tout le monde disait
que le le Salvador narcoétat fichu que
ça marcherait jamais et cetera. Un peu
comme le fatalisme en bien en France. On
s'en relèvera jamais. Nous c'est
impossible. C'est allé trop loin.
Imaginez ce que pensaient les
Salvadoriens. Pays ont brûlé des cararts
scolaires. Donc 70000 places de prison
et là il déclare l'état d'urgence au
Salvador et il se met à enfermer tous
les gangsters qui pourrissaient la vie
du pays. Vous avez des débats un peu
dans le monde occidental pour ceux pour
les rares qui s'y intéressent et qui
vous disent c'est pas un état de droit,
c'est pas démocratique et cetera. Nous
aussi, on a décrété l'état d'urgence.
Faut s'en rappeler quand même en 2015
après les attentats, l'état d'urgence,
c'est précisément la réponse du droit à
une situation exceptionnelle. C'est ce
que disait Michel Debré d'ailleurs quand
il prévoit les circonstances
exceptionnelles dans la Constitution. Il
dit "C'est parce que l'état de droit
existe qu'on a prévu dans notre droit
qu'on puisse y déroger dans des
situations qui le méritent."
Je ferme la parenthèse. Ce que fait
Bookellé et qui explique certaines
certaines critiques, c'est que pour les
gangstars salvadorien, il y a une
pratique qui vise à se tatouer partout
sur le corps les les exactions qu'ils
ont commises. Donc par exemple, ils ont
un symbole spécial quand vous avez
commis des crimes. Si vous en avez
dessiné trois, c'est que vous avez tué
trois fois. Quand vous avez commis des
viols et cetera et cetera. et il se tâ
tout tout ça sur le corps. Et donc ce
qu'a apporté Bouellé qui est critiqué,
c'est qu'il a dit "J'autorise la justice
pénale à considérer comme une preuve
recevable le fait de regarder sur le
corps des gens les méfets qu'ils ont
commis en observant ce qu'ils ont fait,
ce qu'ils ont tatoué sur eux-mêmes."
C'est ce qu'on lui reproche
majoritairement. Et en fait, lui dit
"Pne mentir de toute façon parce que les
gangsters n'autorisent pas ce genre de
mensonge. Il se contrôlent entre eux.
vous allez pas vous tatouer un faux truc
sur le corps. Donc ça sa manière d'y
répondre rapidement c'était de dire on
considère qu'il s'autodénonce en
réalité. Il a rempli cette prison et
alors conclusion, le Salvador est passé
en 3 ans du pays le plus dangereux du
monde au pays le plus sûr de tout le
monde occidental. C'est un pays qui est
aujourd'hui plus sûr que le Canada. Ça
fait 3 mois que vous avez zéro homicide.
0. Je pense que juste aujourd'hui à
Paris, on a battu le Salvador sur ces
trois derniers mois en prenant juste une
seule ville. Peut-être que même
aujourd'hui dans cet arrondissement, on
a battu le Salvador, je sais pas. Mais
quoi qu'il en soit, résultat
impressionnant. Vous avez Boulé qui a
été réélu. Le 18e, c'est très safe, il
paraît. Non, le 18e. Ouais, c'est pas
mal le 18e. Ça dépend des quartiers.
Vous avez Bouquellé qui a été réélu mais
de manière totalement triomphale. Il a
87 % de taux de popularité. Macron,
c'est 23 pour comparer euh pour essayer
de répondre à une à à ce que certains
pourraient dire. Vous avez donc eu des
élections il y a 2 ans, 3000
observateurs internationaux. C'est
colossal pour un petit pays. Ils
constatent tous régularité totale,
probité totale de l'élection, un
triomphe, un triomphe total. Bellé est
allé à la tribune des Nations- Unies. Il
y a fait un discours, j'invite les gens
à regarder parce que vraiment ça fait
réfléchir. Je dis pas que c'est le
modèle parfait qu'on va tout appliquer
mais ça fait réfléchir. Il est allé à la
Tribune des Nations- Unies et il dit
"Vous me reprochez d'avoir enfermé des
milliers de personnes, mais moi j'en ai
libéré des millions." Qu'est-ce que la
liberté dont vous vous targuez dans le
monde occidental quand les gens ont peur
de sortir de chez eux ? Qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire la liberté en fait ? Quelle
est la concrétisation, la matérialité de
tous les principes que vous défendez
quand vous dites démocratie, quand vous
dites état de droit, quand vous dites
liberté ? Qu'est-ce que ça signifie dans
la vraie vie quand les gens ont la boule
au vente dans les transports en commun
quand ils ont juste peur dans la rue ?
Et lui dit "Moi, j'ai libéré des
millions de mes concitoyens. Les
innocents n'ont plus peur et les
coupables ont peur. Voilà la vision de
la justice qu'il a eu. Résultat
magnifique. Question internet
souverainiste. Donc on propose la sortie
de l'Union européenne point
d'interrogation.
Euh c'est une question qu'on qu'on me
pose souvent. Euh une question que je me
suis beaucoup posée aussi parce que
c'est vrai que quand on est
souverainiste, la première question
qu'on se pose, c'est est-ce qu'on peut
avoir une souveraineté au sein de cet
ensemble qui s'appelle l'Union
européenne ? Je pense que en l'état euh
il est clair que non, que ça nous en
sert et cetera, mais j'espère que j'ai
réussi un peu à y répondre tout à
l'heure quand je disais j'ai dit tout à
l'heure nous sommes des victimes
consentantes. Euh il y a ce texte de la
boissie qui parle de la servitude
volontaire. Pour nous la servitude est
beaucoup volontaire. Je vous disais tout
à l'heure, les Italiens, les Allemands,
les Danois arrivent à défendre leurs
intérêts parce qu'ils y mettent les
moyens par des mesures très concrète.
Politique arrache très claire,
négociation des traités, des outtout sur
les textes quand il faut. Ils arrivent à
défendre leurs intérêts vitaux à chaque
fois qu'ils sont menacés auprès de de
l'Union européenne, des instances de
l'Union européenne et ils s'imposent.
Ils s'imposent non pas parce qu'ils ont
plus d'atout. Non, on peut pas dire que
le Danemark est plus d'atout que nous.
On peut pas dire que l'Italie est plus
d'atou que nous. On aurait pu dire ça
pour l'Allemagne, mais l'Allemagne n'est
pas le seul pays à réussir à tirer son
épingle du jeu. Ils y arrivent parce
qu'ils le veulent. Alors que nous, on ne
le veut pas. Ils ont gardé leur
industrie surtout.
Ouais, mais si on prend d'autres
exemples, je vous ai dit le Danemark, on
peut prendre la Hongrie qui arrive à
faire respecter ses frontières, on peut
prendre la Pologne. Alors là, c'est vrai
qu'il y a il y a une belle industrie
aussi, mais ils y arrivent parce qu'ils
se sont donnés les moyens sur des sujets
qui touchent pas forcément à
l'industrie. Quand vous voyez que Méloni
par exemple arrive à faire plier Vlen en
lui disant "C'est toi qui va payer mes
accords migratoires avec l'Albanie, avec
la Tunisie, elle arrive elle à prendre
de l'argent à une allemande. Elle est
assez forte quand même. On a une
italienne qui fait plier la Commission
européenne en disant "C'est toi qui va
payer pour ma fermeté migratoire." Tu
vas payer où ? Et bien, il y a forcément
un où. Bah en fait ce que j'essaie de
vous dire c'est que nous c'est pas tant
que comme on n pas mis cette condition,
on n arrive pas, c'est qu'on l'a même
jamais demandé. On est là à toujours
vouloir être les bons élèves. Je vais
pas revenir dessus plus longtemps, mais
je vais quand même répondre à la
question pour vous donner un exemple de
comment ça réfléchit au sein du Conseil
européen. Euh donc le Conseil, c'est
l'endroit où se réunissent tous les
chefs d'état. Euh c'est une des trois
instances principales. Donc les trois,
c'est le Parlement européen, là où je
suis, la Commission européenne présidée
par Vanderleyen et le Conseil qui est la
Réunion des chefs d'État. La France par
exemple se fait une gloire de je cite la
phrase que disent toujours les ministres
français on n' jamais été mis en
minorité au conseil.
OK ? Et quand on regarde pourquoi ils
ont jamais été mis en minorité, c'est
parce qu'ils se demandent toujours
quelle va être la majorité et qui vote
avec la majorité. Bah oui, c'est facile
dans ce cas-là. Enfin, c'est la poule et
l'œuf en fait. Bah on va demander ce que
veulent tous les autres et puis après on
va voter comme eux. On n jamais été mis
en minorité. C'est ça en fait le côté
bonne élève de la France, c'est on n pas
du tout envie d'être ceux qui vont
empêcher que l'Europe se fasse alors que
d'autres n'ont pas peur de créer des
crises. Pour remonter au général de Gao,
la politique de la chasse vide. À ce
moment-là, qu'est-ce qu'il se dit ? Il
se dit un homme d'état, c'est quelqu'un
qui n'a pas peur de créer une crise.
Tous les politiciens ont peur des crises
et ils ont surtout peur d'en être à
l'origine qu'on dise c'est lui qui a
jeté l'Europe dans la crise et cetera.
Deal quand il fait la chaise vide, il
sait qu'il crée une crise mais il le
fait en se disant d'une crise peut
naître quelque chose de positif. Moi ce
que je propose c'est qu'on accepte
demain en étant au pouvoir de mettre
l'Europe en crise sans être naïf. Je
respecte beaucoup les gens qui parlent
de Frexit. C'est pas un gros mot, c'est
pas un mot tabou. J'en ai beaucoup parlé
qui parlent de Frexit. Moi beaucoup de
gens qui me parlent. Il y a des gens
chez Reconquê qui veulent le Frexit.
Après, il y a d'autres gens que
j'apprécie, Florient Filippo et cetera
qui en parlent qui sont plus médiatiques
militants. La légende, la légende du
Frexit, c'est qui ? Euh, Philippo. Non,
c'est François Elino. Oui, aussi. Non,
ça fait ça fait partie des gens qui
réfléchissent. Euh c'est c'est pas c'est
pas mon option, mais je vais expliquer
quelle est la mienne. Accepter une crise
avec l'Union européenne. Je trouve que
parfois chez certains partisans du
Frexit, il y a une forme paradoxalement
de fétichisme du droit. C'est-à-dire
puisque le droit est tel qu'il est et
que il ne nous convient pas, il faut
sortir tout de suite parce que sinon ils
vont nous l'imposer. Et parfois il ne
voit pas qu'en réalité il y a toujours
un jeu entre le droit et la puissance.
C'est-à-dire des nations qui arrivent,
je vous ai dit le Danemark, à dire ce
texte-là, on le respectera pas, on peut
pas le respecter, c'est contraire à nos
intérêts, donc on le respectera pas.
Pren une amende. Pardon ? Est-ce que
Est-ce que on prend des amendes quand on
respecte pas les textes ? On pourrait
moi, ça me choquerait pas d'accepter une
amende. Mais là, ils prennent même pas
d'amende. Ils le négocient en amont. Ils
disent "On vous présente qu'on ne
respectera pas." Et c'est accepté par
les institutions européennes. Nous, on
n'essaye même pas. Ce que je dis, ce que
je leur réponds, c'est "Tentons d'abord
cette solution que personne n'a jamais
essayé." C'est quelque chose qui n'a
même jamais été envisagé par les élites
françaises qui n'ont même jamais tenté.
Donc tentons ça. Fixons première
première mesure à mon avis déjà la
première et je pense que là ça met
d'accord les frxiteurs, les non
frxiteurs, en tout cas tous les
souverainistes. Première mesure, il faut
savoir que dans notre constitution on a
l'article 55 qui dispose que les traités
internationaux ont valeur supérieure aux
lois. Cet article qui date donc de la
constitution de 58 avait toujours été
pris comme un article qui disait que les
traités avaient valeur supérieure aux
lois qui avaient été voté avant avant la
signature du traité. Et jusqu'en 1989,
on se dit si le législateur vote quelque
chose après un traité, même si c'est en
contradiction avec le traité, comme
c'est le représentant du peuple, c'est
cette loi-là qui doit s'appliquer et pas
le traité signé auparavant. Mais à
partir de 89, le Conseil d'État dans un
arrêt qui resté très célèbre et je pense
que pour le coup tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à la souveraineté
connaissent un arrêt qui s'appelle
Nicolo et où le Conseil d'État dit "À
partir de maintenant, on écarte toutes
les lois qui sont contraires au traité,
même si elles viennent d'être votées.
Même si le Parlement a voté une loi hier
et que cette loi est contraire à un
traité qui a été signé il y a 40 ans,
c'est le traité qui prime. basculement
total de notre vision juridique par le
passé qui à mon sens signe la fin d'une
souveraineté juridique de la France.
Pour se faire, alors si ça peut un peu
rassurer des gens, il suffirait d'un
seul mot ajouté à la Constitution, un
trait de plume, une seule réforme
rapide. On ajoute à l'article 55 de la
Constitution, les traités primes sur les
lois antérieures. Une fois qu'on a dit
ça, le juge ne peut plus écarter des
lois sous prétexte qu'elles seraient
contraire au traité. C'est-à-dire que
demain, vous pouvez avoir l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat qui décide de
faire entrer en vigueur une loi qui
entre en contradiction même frontale
avec un traité européen et qu'on décide
de l'appliquer quand même. Ce que je
propose, que j'aimerais qu'on fasse,
c'est que un un président, une
présidente, quelqu'un qui arrive à la
tête du pouvoir demain et qui soit
authentiquement patriote disent à
Bruxelles : "Maintenant, nous sommes de
retour, nous allons prendre notre pays
en main. Il y a tel sujet à mon sens,
industrie, politique migratoire,
énergie. Il y a tel sujet qu'on
considère être d'intérêts vitaux pour
nous. On considère que tel traité, tel
traité et tel traité les mettent en
péril. On vous demande immédiatement de
renégocier ces traités, mais on vous
prévient tout de suite que dans
l'intervalle de la renégociation, on
prendra nos propres lois. Ça suffit. On
vous attendra pas. On attendra pas
l'unanimité, que les 27 soient d'accord
et cetera. Dès maintenant, on applique
notre propre politique. On garde les
forme en disant "Vous êtes libre de
négocier. Nous, on vous a on vous permet
de renégocier ça, mais d'ors et déjà, on
n'appliquera plus ça." Quand je dis ça,
euh certains frxiteurs se disent "Non,
nous, on préfère sortir et cetera, mais
si concrètement on peut en avoir les
bénéfices sans avoir le le coût, tout le
monde reconnaît qu'il y a un coût au
Frexit, le l'euro, nous on est dans
l'euro contrairement en Britannique. On
voit bien que l'exemple du Brexit a pas
été fantastique, qu'ils n'ont résolu
aucun de leurs problèmes ni économiques
ni migratoire, que toutes les promesses
du Brexit ont été déçues. Nigel Farad le
reconnaît. Il s'en plaint d'ailleurs. Il
dit "Oui, c'est vrai, l'esprit du Brexit
a été trahi. On n pas réussi à à
réaliser toutes les promesses qu'on
avait dit au peuple britannique que le
Brexit engendrerait." Ils ont une
croissance de combien ? 0,7. Ouais.
Franchement très faible et surtout ils
accueillent plus de migrants que jamais
alors que souvenez-vous tout le Brexit
avait été fait sur la fin du laxisme
migratoire. Ils en accueillent plus
qu'avant. Donc euh vraiment un désastre,
les taux de criminalité explosent. Vous
avez vu les horreurs avec les groomings.
Et enfin bon, il faut expliquer les
groomings. Euh ouais, bien sûr, c'est
euh des jeunes filles britanniques qui
euh ont été victimes de viol en masse
par euh des Indo-Paistanais que la
Grande-Bretagne avait accueilli. Et
alors là où le scandale est est reparu,
c'est que vous avez un homme qui
s'appelle Tommy Robinson et qui est un
influenceur britannique, on pourrait
dire. ultra droite. Euh moi, j'aime pas
trop ces ces termes. Je trouve qu'ils
sont très chargés. Euh mais un
influenceur britannique qui a remis le
sujet au goût du jour, qui s'est fait
accuser de diffuser des informations
alors qu'un procès était en cours, qui
s'est fait enfermer. Donc il est
aujourd'hui encore en prison, il est
dans les jaules britanniques et donc ça
ça a ouvert de très nombreux débats sur
l'impossibilité de parler euh de de ce
de ces faits divers. Sandrine Rousseau,
je crois, avait été mise euh face à ce
cette histoire en disant "Mais vous avez
des centaines de filles qui ont été
violées et vous en parlez pas." Non non,
c'est un sujet d'extrême droite et
cetera. Donc énorme sujet. Je ferme la
parenthèse. Le Brexit n'a pas réalisé
ses promesses. Donc il manqué un passage
là, pardon, je vous en prie, sur le
comment avait réagi la justice anglaise
en enfermant Tommy Robinson. Et s'il y
avait eu des cas qui avaient été
couverts par X ou Y personne. Ah oui,
par euh quelqu'un au sommet du pouvoir
même. Euh enfin ce qu'on soupçonne,
c'est que le Premier ministre
britannique d'aujourd'hui est au courant
était au courant et ne demandait pas
d'enquête et euh couvrait un peu cette
affaire en ayant très peur que ça fasse
monter comme d'habitude monter l'extrême
droite et en se disant que ce sujet
était tellement explosif. Ils ont peur
d'une guerre civile.
Je pense que tout patriote doit avoir
peur d'une guerre civile. C'est ce qui
peut arriver de pire à un pays. C'est
bah la l'autodestruction.
On doit tout faire pour pour éviter d'en
arriver là. Je pense que ça doit être
l'objectif de des gens qui aiment leur
pays. Les guerres civiles, c'est presque
à chaque fois dans l'histoire
l'assurance que des puissances
étrangères vont venir se greffer sur sur
ce conflit. On a rien à gagner. Je pense
que personne doit être euh parfois il y
a une forme de comment on appelle ça ?
L'accélérationnisme, les gens qui en
peuvent plus et qui se disent "Il faut
que ça pète parce qu'au moins il quel
peut-être que quelque chose de bon
ressortira." Moi je suis pas du tout
dans instruction créatrice, c'est ça.
Ouais. Moi ouais en économie ça peut
avoir ça, on peut le comprendre là. On
le comprend toujours pas là hein. Là
pour le pour le la destruction
créatrice. Oui. Alors dans l'économie ça
s'explique, c'est une théorie mais là en
l'occurrence à mon avis la la guerre
civile ne crée rien. Elle est créatrice
de rien. C'est le mal par le mal et ça
enfin moi j'y crois pas. En tout cas
c'est pas du tout ma mon étudié Ricardo
un peu ou pas du tout ? Oui ouais je
vous ai dit j'ai fait un peu d'économie
à à la merci beaucoup. Euh oui ouioui.
Les avantages comparatifs notamment et
donc sur la Grande-Bretagne, Brexit un
peu décevant pour le peuple britannique.
Je pense que ce que ça peut nous
apprendre, c'est pas que ah c'est
vraiment que les souverainistes avaient
tort et cetera, pas du tout. Ce que ça
peut nous apprendre, c'est qu'en réalité
le salut ne vient que de nous-même. Il
faut pas s'imaginer que parce qu'on a
une tutelle au-dessus de nous, alors
tout est de la faute de cette tutelle.
Nos problèmes, nous les devons à
nous-même. D'autres pays qui ont cette
même tutelle arrivent à s'en sortir
parce qu'ils se défendent. Nous, je le
redis, notre servitude est volontaire.
Il y a énormément de mécanismes qu'on a
nous-même créé et il y a parfois une
tendance de certains politiciens à
toujours se reposer sur l'Europe pour
faire croire que c'est pas de leur
faute. Je vous donne un exemple.
Parfois, la droite dit il faut supprimer
la ME, l'aide médicale d'État, donc
cette aide qui bénéficie au clandestin
et dont on soupçonne que ça crée un
énorme appel d'air parce que beaucoup de
gens viennent pour se faire soigner,
sachant que c'est gratuit, que le panel
de soin est très large et cetera.
Parenthèse fermé. Quand la droite dit il
faut supprimer la ME, certains répondent
"Ah bah non, c'est pas possible,
l'Europe nous l'empêcherait."
Alors pourquoi on est le seul pays
d'Europe à avoir la ME ? C'est quand
même bizarre. Pourquoi tous les autres
pays se font pas sanctionnés ? Nous,
jusqu'en 99, ça n'existait pas la ME et
on était déjà dans l'Europe et on éétait
pas sanctionné. Donc il y a parfois, je
trouve, une facilité à toujours se
cacher derrière la tutelle européenne
pour ne pas voir qu'en réalité les
solutions peuvent venir de nous-même sur
de très nombreux sujets qu'on peut
déroger, qu'on peut même déroger parfois
légalement. CF, Italie, Danemark,
Allemagne que par ailleurs contrairement
à au Danemark ou à l'Italie, on a une
certaine puissance en étant la France.
C'est ce que l'Allemagne a très bien
compris. Vous avez peut-être vu que
l'Allemagne avait fait plier la
commission sur les aides d'État en
disant on en a besoin pour notre
industrie et la commission a dit très
bien, on accepte qu'il y ait parfois des
dérogations pour les aides d'État en
matière industrielle parce que
l'Allemagne l'a demandé. Nous, on avait
même jamais osé le demander. Commençons
déjà par ça. Arrêtons de surtransposer.
Demandons à chaque fois des ajustements.
Poussons dans le bon sens pour faire
supprimer des choses. Je pense qu'en ce
moment, on engrange beaucoup de
victoires au sein de toute l'Union
européenne. Quand on voit la coalition
de de ceux qui sont allés en Ukraine la
semaine dernière, ce qui est frappant
pour moi sur l'image, c'est que tous ces
hommes tiennent tous sur des majorités
extrêmement fragiles construites de
briques et de broc sur des alliances
entre la droite et la gauche. des trucs,
on sent vraiment qu'ils font tous pour
s'accrocher au pouvoir, mais que
derrière il y a la une très forte montée
de parties très contestataires. Donc, on
engrange tellement de victoires qu'à mon
avis, ce grand mouvement aurait
aujourd'hui le peuple derrière soi. Et
encore une fois, laissons pas de porte
fermée, essayons ce que personne n'a
jamais essayé. Et si ça marche pas,
évidemment qu'il faudra rediscuter d'un
d'un autre moyen de reprendre notre
souveraineté. L'OTAN, on fait quoi ? On
en sort, on en sort pas, on donne plus
d'argent aux Américains,
on essaie de récupérer. Non, on fait
quoi ? Euh, donner plus d'argent aux
Américains, évidemment non. Euh surtout
pas quand on est français. Déjà que je
comprends pas que les autres euh
continuent de s'y soumettre, l'Italie,
les Belges, le Danemark, le les
Allemands qui continuent d'acheter
Américain. Je ne compte pas. Que la
situation est plus grave que prévue.
Servitude volontaire. Il se laisse
faire. Ils se laissent faire et ils ont
pas d'alternative présentée. Quand il
voit Macron pour eux c'est un président
faible. Il a plus de majorité, il a pas
d'assemblée. Le gouvernement c'est le
sien sans être le sien. Il parle même
plus à Baïou. Enfin, il fait des
interviews la fidèle Castro, c'est ça ?
Ouais. Euh ouais, il parle avec Thbo
Inshape. Il peut pas prendre de compte
d'opposants politique. Enfin bon euh
c'est pas faute de l'avoir invité hein,
de lui avoir envoyé des SMS.
Ah ça aurait été intéressant.
Dommage. Un jour peut-être. Vous allez
vous présenter à la présidentielle ? Non
non non. Le candidat de reconquête,
c'est c'est Éric Zemour. Je pense qu'on
a Pourquoi pas vous ? Bah pourquoi pas
lui ? Moi je pense que Pourquoi pas lui
? Ouais. Pourquoi pas vous ? Bah je vais
je vais je vais vous répondre. femme 32
ans avec le cerveau bien capelé qui
réfléchit à la vitesse de la lumière qui
veut qui veut envoyer ses idées.
Zemmour il Bah je pense que la la
différence peut-être qu'il a avec le
reste de la classe politique c'est qu'il
a d'abord une vision historique une
connaissance de l'histoire. Tout le
monde pense que c'est inutile
aujourd'hui l'histoire. Je me souviens,
il avait fait un débat contre Yannick
Jade et Yannick Jade lui avait dit "Mais
en fait vous voulez être prof d'histoire
Waouh ! Le niveau. Alors là pour plé
avec Jiscan, je lui avais tombé un
piège, il s'est bien planté la dernière
fois pour le coup. Preuve d'histoire
quoi. Donc d'abord il a une vision
historique. Je pense que cette vision là
est associée à sans doute des je sais
pas un don peut-être lui offre une sorte
de vista. Il voit des trucs que beaucoup
de gens ne voient pas. Il voit venir des
dangers, des défis, des trucs qui nous
attendent. Pourquoi il il se met pas
derrière vous ? Bah franchement pour moi
aujourd'hui ça n'a ça n'a pas de sens
parce que mais en première dame ça
aurait quand même plus de
Non vraiment pour pour moi euh il est le
candidat qui le plus différent de tous
les autres aujourd'hui sur la scène
politique. Euh franchement moi je vous
dis la vérité, j'y pense pas du tout.
Moi j'ai fait mon ma première émission
il y a 8 mois. C'est tout récent. Je
viens d'arriver. J'ai encore énormément
de choses à apprendre. Je me prends pas
ni pour la femme providentielle, ni pour
Jeanne Dark, ni que sais-je encore des
choses qui ont beaucoup existé à droite
où soudain les gens se sont dit "Moi, je
vais sauver tout le monde." Moi je crois
pas. J'ai encore beaucoup de travail à
faire. J'ai des preuves à faire. J'ai
voilà, il y a des gens qui ont voté pour
moi. Ils étaient 1lion3.
C'est ça donne une énorme
responsabilité. J'espère que je donne
satisfaction aux gens qui ont voté pour
moi. J'espère que pour les autres, ils
se disent que bah la prochaine foison
est bien employé. C'est ça. Bah au moins
que voilà, il y a peut-être une Gabjgie
en moins. Gab la Gabjie. Oui, d'ailleurs
bah j'allais y venir. Euh vous le
propose. Merci. Quelle transition. Euh
il y a notamment un sujet sur lequel je
me suis beaucoup engagée euh récemment,
c'est j'essae, j'ai une équipe pour ça
et on a encore beaucoup de peint sur la
planche de trouver au sein de l'État et
des administrations publiques au sens
large les endroits où notre argent est
le plus mal employé.
On essae ensuite, j'essaie d'en parler
publiquement, de mettre les acteurs face
à leur responsabilité.
Très souvent, ils me répondent en me
disant que je m que ce que je dis est
faux et cetera. Je vais vous donner
quelques exemples.
Et à la fin, finalement, j'ai
l'impression que l'opinion publique se
rend compte de l'étendue de du scandale
et que ça peut faire pencher la balance
dans un bon sens. Je vous disais tout à
l'heure, j'ai quelques petites fiertés
sur cette première année de vie
politique
concrète et il y a notamment pour les
électurs exactement pour les Français
même d'ailleurs, pas forcément pour mes
électeurs parce que ça va concerner tout
le monde. Il y a notamment un sujet que
j'ai abordé il y a maintenant quelques
mois, c'était l'aide publique au
développement. J'avais commencé en
disant euh qu'alors que nous manquions
de tout en France, que nous avions euh
des commissariats délabré, des services
d'urgence où on pouvait mourir en
attendant aux urgences, qui est tragique
pour la France, des écoles où parfois il
y a pas de chauffage en hiver, des
universités où on demande aux étudiants
de mettre leur doudounes parce que il
fait trop froid à l'hiver. Enfin bref,
un pays où on a l'impression
à la fois qu'on est les plus taxés mais
qu'on manque de tout que ce pays des
étudiantes qui sautent et des étudiants
des étudiantes qui saut
que on a se prostituente.
Ouais. Tragique. Et ce pays-là trouve
les moyens d'aller donner de l'argent à
la Chine en aide publique au
développement.
Quand je vois ça, donc je vois que de
2018 à 2020, on a donné 220 millions
d'euros à l'INE. Donner donner pas
prêter, donner de l'argent des euros en
loi en loi de finance. Le Parlement a
accepté qu'on donne de l'argent public
aux Chinois en aide publique au
développement. Donc nous qui roulons sur
l'or Crésus comme comme on sait, on a
tellement d'argent qu'on peut aller même
le le dilapider en Chine. On a de la
deuxè puissance économique du monde.
Quand vous regardez concrètement le
projet, c'est des projets euh de
développement durable dans la vallée du
Fing désolé je prononce mal,
des projets d'écologie devant tel ou tel
fleuve de la folie. Quand on voit que on
dépense des millions d'euros pour aller
décarboner le Costa Rica, vraie
histoire, je j'invente pas des
entitulés, la décarbonation du Costa
Rica, on prend de l'argent dans la poche
des Français pour aller faire ça. Pire
encore, quand on découvre qu'on donne
115 millions d'euros à la Jordanie pour
un projet qui s'appelle budgétisation
sensible au genre
au genre en Jordanie, donc on leur donne
115 millions d'euros. Quand on voit euh
qu'on a donné des millions d'euros à
l'Irak sur un projet qui s'appelle
égalité des sexes en Irak,
pire, combien on a donné ? Je crois que
c'est 60 millions celui-là. Je veux pas
dire de bêtises, c'était sur plusieurs
années, mais c'est plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros. Euh quand on voit
qu'on a donné 66 millions d'euros pour
les modes de cuisson propre au Sahel,
je vous assure que je n'invente rien.
Pour tous ceux qui écoutent afd.fr, FR,
c'est facile. Vous allez sur leur site
internet, vous regardez ça. Vous avez
fait planter le site internet la
dernière fois. Exact. J'ai fait planter
le site internet de la FD. Alors, les
mauvaises langues disaient qu'il
l'avaient fait planter volontairement et
d'autres pensent que avaient simplement
pas le serveur assez fort pour supporter
le million de téléspectateurs qui sont
allés sur le site de la FD. Euh, chacun
choisira. Donc, afd.fr. Si vous y allez,
n'y allez pas tous en même temps. Vous y
verrez tous les projets les plus hubesqu
les uns que les autres. Je dis ça, je
dis ça ben un soir, j'étais sur ces news
et le lendemain, le ministre de la
francophonie me répond en disant que je
m que c'est faux, que ce sont des prêts,
que c'est de l'argent qui fait rayonner
la France. le directeur général de
l'AFD, monsieur Réy Riou, pour ne pas le
citer, euh mais il a un profil très
politique, il a déjà pris la parole
beaucoup et cetera, donc je pense qu'il
sera pas euh effrayé si je le cite. Euh
dit aussi que je mens, il envoie un
communiqué à tous les salariés de
Mentiez ou vous mentiez pas ? Évidemment
que je mentais pas. Afd.fr c'est facile,
source officielle.
Mais ils ont prouvé eux-mêmes qu'ils
savaient que je ne mentais pas puisque
j'apprends la semaine dernière, c'est
dans Challenge, que Remy Riou se plaint
parce qu'il dit que par ma faute, il a
dû baisser le budget de l'aide publique
au développement. Et donc je vous
apprends, j'en suis très heureuse que le
budget de la République au développement
baisse de 2 milliards d'euros parce
qu'ils ont estimé que à cause de
l'urodéputé Sarah Knafo, l'opinion
publique était désormais opposée à ces
projets d'être public au développement
et que donc il fallait montrer l'exemple
et faire un effort. J'en suis très
contente. C'est vraiment pour moi une
belle victoire parce que c'est une
victoire pour les Français pour le fruit
de leur travail. C'est un tout petit
premier pas mais c'est déjà un résultat
concret. c'est 2 milliards d'euros sur
16 milliards d'euros par an pour
rappeler quand même les ordres de
grandeur. Donc c'est pas mal, pas énorme
mais pas mal. Un élément qui que je
trouve exaspérant et qui montre
l'hypocrisie, ils ils ajoutent là où
elle a réussi son coût, c'est parce
qu'elle a cité les intitulés des projets
et que les gens se sont rendus compte de
où leur argent partait en fumée. On n
pas envie de payer pour l'égalité des
sexes en Irak ou la cuisson propre au
sel. et ils ajoutent, "Bon, on va
seulement baisser l'aide publique de 2
milliards, mais on va en plus changer
les intitulés pour que ce soit moins
caricaturable."
Donc, il faut s'attendre. Il ont
peut-être ils ont peut-être baissé le
budget parce qu'en fait la France a
moins d'argent. Mais si seulement, ça
fait des années qu'on a moins d'argent
pour arriver à 100 à 1300 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires sous le seul
quinquena Macron.
1300. Bah maintenant 1300, vous avez vu
ça monte à une vitesse fulgurante là.
ces dernières semaines, on est passé, on
a pris plus 300 milliards en en 2 mois.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'exploitation des gaz de chiste ?
Est-ce qu'on peut légaliser en France ?
En tout cas, je suis pour qu'on ouvre le
débat euh sur la question déjà qu'on
cherche. Moi, franchement, je pense que
s'il y a il y a une seule conviction que
j'ai, c'est bah le côté très réflexion
qui repose sur la science. pas
d'anathème. Il y a pas de mots qui me
choquent. Par exemple, là je vous ai dit
gaz de chis, ça me choque pas aussi
qu'on réouvre la discussion sur les OGM.
Je pense que sur toutes ces questions,
il faut être capable de poser le débat,
non pas en terme, je le disais tout à
l'heure, de peur panique, on en parlait
quand on parlait du pic énergétique et
je vous disais, il faut plutôt avoir une
réflexion en terme de risque, de
probabilité que ces risques adviennent
et cetera. Si on pense que finalement il
y a un gain pour la société à à forêt à
utiliser du gaz de chist ou un gain pour
la société à utiliser des OGM, qu'on y
aille. Si on pense en pesant les
avantages et les risques pour la santé
publique euh et cetera et cetera, alors
euh dans ce cas-là qu'on qu'à la fin on
refuse et qu'on dise non, je suis pas
assez euh spécialiste pour dire
aujourd'hui les bénéfices dépassent les
risques. Je ne sais pas, mais je pense
qu'on devrait pouvoir ouvrir un débat
scientifique en France et avoir de la
donnée sur ça tout simplement. Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de l'affaire des eaux
minérales qui étaient en fait de l'eau
du robinet avec des bouteilles en
plastique, des eaux minérales filtrées ?
que c'est plus des eaux minérales. Bah
la tromperie,
on a couvert du moins le gouvernement.
Je parle comme vous maintenant.
C'est naturel non ? On c'est impersonnel
hein le trisè. Ouais mais il faut se
réapproprier.
Le gouvernement a couvert pour préserver
de l'emploi, préserver des taxes,
préserver le fait que certaines de nos
napéatiques ou nos sources étaient
polluées et que bon
ils ont fait ça pour quoi à votre avis ?
On sait qu'ils ont couvert, on sait
qu'ils savaient. H d'après ce qu'on a pu
lire, ça y ressemble beaucoup. D'accord.
Franchement, je sais pas. Euh, j'ai pas
la réponse à cette question parce que je
sais pas si quelqu'un savait ou pas. Je
pense que c'est un sujet intéressant
parce que ça montre aussi une tromperie
du consommateur.
Il y a il y a on paye un prix parce
qu'on s'imagine un certain produit. Je
pense qu'il suffirait de le dire. En
tout cas, si c'est les raisons que vous
évoquez à la fin, des bonnes raisons de
se dire les nappes fréatiques, a une
rareté de la ressource et cetera, il
suffirait de le dire. Moi, ça me
choquerait pas d'acheter une telle eau.
Si on me dit "lelle est filtrée, mais
c'est pas de l'eau, c'est pas vraiment
de l'eau minérale. Je pourrais même
l'acheter mais au moins qu'on mente
pas." Question internet. Comment vous
informez-vous sur les sujets de
surveillance pour en 2025 ignorer les
les programmes de la NSA révélé par
Snowel en 2013 du nom de XK Score de
Prisme. Ce dernier permettant à la
communauté du renseignement US de
piocher dans les serveurs des
entreprises US. Que pensez-vous de la
faire à Sange ? Que pensez-vous de
l'affaire Pegasus ? J'écoute Syerview
pour répondre début de la question.
Ouais, c'est vrai. Vous avez regardé
quoi de chez nous ? Franchement, j'en ai
regardé plein. J'ai écouté Mélenchon,
les deux parties et même et même il en a
fait un autre il y a 3 ans. J'ai écouté
Philippe Devilier bien sûr. J'ai écouté
Juan Branco, j'ai écouté Jean Covici,
non pas la dernière. J'en ai écouté
comment construire une guillotine, je
crois. J'ai écouté Jean Covici, j'ai
écouté les trois cryptros que vous avez
reçus. passionnant que j'aime beaucoup.
D'ailleurs, je crois qu'il y avait
Guspio à l'intérieur. Stratenchenko sans
doute Ouais, c'était aussi un Stachenko
aussi. Écosystème que j'aime beaucoup,
avec qui je discute, qui sont vraiment
très intelligents, bonne vision
prospective, pas seulement euh comme
peuvent les caricaturer certains
focaliser sur leur gain, le Bitcoin et
cetera. Pas du tout. Ça va beaucoup plus
loin en terme de philosophie. Ils
réfléchissent vraiment aux implications
monétaires. Enfin, je trouve qu'il y a
vraiment une une pensée chez chez ces
gens qui parfois dépassent certains
économistes que que je peux côtoyer.
Vous avez regardé Didier Castre ? Non,
je crois pas. On vous la recommande
chaudement. M'avait recommandé aussi
l'ambassadeur. Lequel l'ambassadeur ?
L'ambassadeur chinois que je vais
écouter. Ambassadeur chinois. Ouais,
c'est une masterclasse. Ouais, mais moi
je sais pas, j'ai l'impression que les
ambassadeurs ont tellement pas le droit
de parler que on se dit toujours langue
de bois. Ils sont très polis. Le
contream, il y avait il y avait dans un
dans un livre d'Albert Cohen, je crois
que c'est Belle du Seigneur, il raconte
son expérience à la société des nations.
Il travaillait à Genève dans l'entre de
guerre et il dit "Le talent des
diplomates, c'est de savoir ne rien dire
en plusieurs phrases." Ça me fait
vraiment penser à Macron. Question
Internet. Est-ce que vous est-ce qu'elle
a déjà alors est-ce qu'elle a déjà suivi
des cours de thermodynamique ?
Alors, j'ai pas suivi à proprement
parler de cours de thermodynamique. J'ai
fait un bac scientifique, SPMAT, après
j'ai fait des maths pour l'économie,
mais je m'y suis je m'y suis intéressée,
je connais pas aussi bien que je
voudrais, mais en revanche, je je ne
m'entoure que d'ingénieur. Donc à mes
côtés, c'est des équipes qui sont pour
le coup très scientifiques, formé à ses
raisonnements et bah j'aimerais s'il y a
des lectures à conseiller ou quoi que ce
soit, c'est vraiment des sujets qui
m'intéressent. Question internet quit
des déclarations choc de Zemour
également là pour choquer et faire
entendre sa voix. C'est acceptable là.
Alors euh
je suis pas certaine d'avoir compris le
sens de la question mais je vois répéter
si vous voulez. Non non non je c'est
c'est je me demande juste comment il a
voulu rédiger ça. Est-ce que ça veut
dire que lui trouve ça choquant ? Est-ce
qu'il veut dire que c'est bien ? Bon peu
importe, je vais répondre quand même sur
le fond.
Je pense qu'il a fait, j'en parlais tout
à l'heure, qu'il a fait véritablement
avancer les choses et je disais on a
peut-être pas encore mesuré tous les
effets de de de la campagne de 2022 sur
la lucidité de la France sur certains
des enjeux qui sont qui sont les nôtres.
Je pense notamment aux enjeux
identitaires, sécuritaires, culturel, le
l'aspect où va la France. Je pense que
c'est l'un des seuls le seul qui a osé
mettre au centre d'une campagne
présidentielle l'enjeu de que
serons-nous demain ? Quel peuple
serons-nous demain ? Où allons-nous ? La
question de la démographie, c'était
vraiment presque des sujets de tabou.
Personne n'en parlait. S'est fait
condamner ? Non, il s'est fait
condamner. Ouais. Malheureusement sur le
fondement de loi extrêmement politique
quand on voit pour vous donner un
exemple la décision de justice c'est une
décision de justice. Ouais c'est vrai.
On peut moi comme je suis député et
parlementaire mon rôle c'est aussi de
critiquer les lois puisque mon objectif
c'est de réformer les lois de les
refaire et cetera une immunité
h pas forcément. On peut dans d'ailleurs
on peut lever l'immunité. Ça se fait
assez couramment au Parlement européen.
On vote parfois pour les levées
d'immunité quand ça se justifie. Parfois
ça se justifie. Euh donc euh mon rôle
aussi c'est et et je pense que le rôle
de tous les politiques, ça devrait aussi
être d'être capable de remettre en cause
des lois établies. Sinon on bouge
jamais. Sinon il y a pas il y a pas
d'élection, il y a pas de réforme, il y
a ça sert plus à rien la démocratie en
fait si on n'a pas le droit de remettre
en cause les lois. Donc il se fait il
s'est fait condamner sur le fondement de
de loi que je trouve tout à fait
attentatoire à la liberté d'expression.
C'est notamment pour ça qu'un Tommy
Robinson est en prison aujourd'hui. Et
quand on regarde les termes qu'il a
employé et qui lui ont valu des
condamnations, par exemple, il y en
avait une sa condamnation définitive. Il
avait dit "La plupart des trafiquants
sont d'origine immigré." À l'époque où
il dit ça, c'est très choquant. C'est
2011, on est sous Sarco à l'époque mais
il dit ça sur un plateau, je sais plus
lequel, je crois, Chardisson. Et ça lui
vaut vraiment des anathèmes. Tout le
monde l'attaque à l'époque la l racisme,
enfin tout le monde se porte partie
civile et il l'attaque. Et euh et
aujourd'hui Gérald Armanin ministre dit
la même chose, Retaillo dit la même
chose. À longueur d'étude, on dit oui
bah c'est vrai en fait il y a une
surreprésentation dans les crimes et les
délits de certaines communautés et
cetera. Ça on n pas le droit de faire de
statistiques communautaires en France.
Non bah c'est pas des alors de
statistiques ethniques, on n pas le
droit. En revanche, on a le droit de
faire des statistiques qui reposent sur
la nationalité. C'est pas c'est pas une
ethnie. Donc, on a le droit de dire par
exemple les Afghans sont surreprésentés
dans les viols. Ce qu'on observe en
France, ce qu'on observe en Allemagne
sur la source.
La source c'est les sources du ministère
de l'intérieur pour le coup et du
ministère allemand pour ce qui concerne
l'Allemagne mais nous c'est des sources
vraiment officiel gouvernemental et
quand je vous dis que Darmanin le dit il
était ministre de l'intérieur il avait
source à l'appui un peu comme Colomb dès
qu'il est à la tête du ministère bah il
se dit en fait c'est indéniable je veux
bien être de gauche je suis au Parti
socialiste mais j'ai les choses devant
moi. Donc quand on quand on regarde
aujourd'hui ces surreésentations, on se
dit bah après tout, est-ce que on peut
avoir un raisonnement empirique là
encore qui repose sur des faits sourcés,
pas sur j'ai en tête que telle
communauté c'est des racailles ou je
sais pas quoi. Non, pas du tout.
Empirique, la Suisse par exemple, l'une
des plus belles démocraties, un des plus
beaux modèles démocratiques que je
connaisse euh a typiquement ce genre de
raisonnement dans leur loi. Donc je vous
donne un exemple. Vous voulez avoir un
port d'armes en Suisse ? Il considère
que si vous êtes d'une nationalité qui
est surreprésentée dans les homicides,
ce ne serait pas sérieux de vous
autoriser à avoir un port d'armes. Alors
au hasard, les nationalités bah il se
trouvent oui que français dans dans les
homicides en Suisse, non je crois pas
non. Bah ça ça fait caricature mais oui
c'est vrai, il y avait Algérien, il y
avait des nationalités comme ça. Donc
oui c'est des des sources car
surreprésenté, vous savez enfin évidment
sources de qui en Suisse ? de bah de des
autorités suisses euh surreprésenté. Ça
veut pas dire que euh c'est les
Algériens qui commettent le voilà, c'est
ce que j'allais dire. Surreprésenter, ça
veut juste dire si vous êtes 1 % de la
population mais que vous commettez 5 %
des crimes, vous êtes surreprésenté dans
les crimes. En principe, ça devrait être
assez proportionnel. Vous êtes peu donc
vous êtes peu présent dans à la fois les
crimes, dans les succès, dans et cetera
et cetera. On peut être surreprésenté
dans quelque chose de positif,
surreprésenté dans un peu stupide, non ?
la surre-représentation. Non, mais de de
d'exclure ceux qui souhaiteraient
détendre détenir une arme. Bah non, pour
le coup, si si vous vous dites, je vous
ai dit raisonnons en terme de risque, on
se dit pas que c'est idéologique, telle
nationalité, elle est nécessairement
ceci ou cela. Non, non, non. Si on se
dit il y a plus de risque quand on met
telle personne de par exemple, il y a
plus de risque de donner aux États-Unis
un flingue à un enfant dépressif qu'à un
autre. basique. On va pas se dire c'est
stupide, un enfant dépressif peut tout à
fait détenir une arme chez lui. Non, on
sait que il y a plus de risques. On a
déjà connu ça plein de fois dans des
lycée américains où bah ça à la moindre
contrariété, soudain ils ont envie de
commettre un massacre. Donc on se dit
pour le coup, ce ne serait pas
intelligent, ce ne serait pas de bonne
politique de le faire. Il y a des pays
qui arrivent à avoir ce genre de
raisonnement empirique. Moi, j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'on arrive en France à
dépassionner ces questions et à les
prendre sous un prisme pour le coup
vraiment voilà empirique, scientifique.
Euh quand on a observé et en plus nous
maintenant on a un terro d'analyse
important quand même 40 ans qu'on a la
même politique, la même politique
d'accueil et cetera. Donc on peut en
observer les échecs, toute proportion
gardée. C'est ça
la représentation des crimes et des
homicides par nationalité. Ouais.
Ouais, tout à fait. Euh donc voilà, ce
que ce que ce que certains ont pu
qualifier de choquant par le passé se
retrouve aujourd'hui à être consensuel.
Donc je vous ai dit, il a été condamné
pour de tells propos. C'était en 2011,
ça remonte a maintenant 14 ans. Ce qui
paraissait très choquant en 2011 paraît
aujourd'hui banal à une grande partie
des Français qui se mettent bah à se
dire "Oui, c'est vrai que il y a plus de
délinquence qu'avant et cetera et
cetera." Euh et par conséquent, je pense
que ça peut avoir une vertu.
des gens qui s'autorisent une parole
libre. Faut pas choquer pour choquer,
c'est ça n'a pas d'intérêt. La provoque
pour la provoque, ça n'a pas d'intérêt.
Mais il faut pas s'interdire d'employer
des mots ou de faire sortir des vérités
qui peuvent parfois paraître dur à
entendre, courageus à dire et cetera. On
en est où avec le Parlement européen et
la corruption de puissance étrangère ?
Il y avait pas une dame qui avait reçu
les sacs à main ? On avait été on avait
été visité chez elle, on avait trouvé
plein 500000 € en cache en cache dans
une valise et on a trouvé chez un
collaborateur parlementaire au Parlement
européen des sacs poubelles avec plein
de billets qui venaient c'était des
roubles qui énormes. C'était venu d'où
alors ? Ah c'est drôle, c'est très
marrant que vous disiez ça. Je vais vous
dire pourquoi. Ça venait du Qatar. Et
figurez-vous queen décembre le Parlement
européen a voulu nous faire voter un
texte. Il nous l'a fait voter
d'ailleurs,
qui visait à condamner la corruption
éventuelle de la Russie.
Bon, soit de la Russie en Europe, de la
Russie sur les parlementaires européens
et sur les institutions européennes.
Soit on est contre toutes les
corruptions, évidemment que tout se
condamne et cetera. Moi quand j'ai vu
ça, je me suis dit bah quand même c'est
la meilleure qu'on parle de la Russie.
Alors que il y a de ça 1 an, on a eu un
fait retentissant où c'était dans
l'enceinte même du Parlement européen
qu'on avait eu un cas de corruption. Et
ce texte-là ne le cite même pas. Je
dépose un amendement qui dit on veut
bien condamner toute corruption,
notamment celle de la Russie, mais dans
ce cas-là, condamnons ce qui s'est passé
dans nos propres rangs dans cet
hémicycle et où la vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée euh une Grec qui est qu'on a
qui présentatrice qu'on a retrouvé avec
cette valise de 500000 € en cash donné
par le Qatar. Et ensuite, quand vous
écoutez ces discours, franchement, je
vous invite à écouter, c'est presque
risible. Euh bah le Qatar, la plus
grande démocratie, on devrait s'inspirer
du droit du travail Qatarie et cetera et
cetera. Ça coûte cher euh 500000 € le
discours quand même. Et euh et et donc
je dépose cet amendement en disant "OK,
on condamne toute corruption bien sûr,
d'où qu'elle vienne et cetera, mais dans
ce cas-là, commençons par chez nous." Ça
s'est passé dans l'ensemble de ces murs
là. Donc condamnons la la corruption qui
vient du Qatar. Bah, je vous le donne en
1000. Toute la gauche a voté contre.
Toute. Heureusement, la droite a voté
avec moi pour cet amendement. Toute la
gauche s'est opposée. Là, vous dites
"Mais quelle est leur excuse ?" Comment
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'on ne veut pas
juste condamner la corruption Katari au
sein de cet hémicle ? Pourquoi ?
Incroyable.
Donc, vous avez raison.
Il y avait d'autres organismes de
corruption ou de soft power d'autres
puissance ou de choses comme ça ? Non,
du tout. Euh, j'ai pas de fait euh connu
en tête. Je pense qu'il y a il y a
beaucoup d'influences qui jouent. Sans
doute l'influence chinoise, peut-être
aussi l'influence turque qui continue de
bénéficier d'aide européenne euh parce
qu'elle est en procédure d'adhésion
toujours, ce qui est un scandale. Euh
mais j'ai pas de connaissance d'un truc
aussi gros de valise de billet carrément
trouvé. Je pense qu'il y a des jeux
d'influence, des gens qui invitent à
déjeuner des trucs comme ça sans doute
qui souvent offshore.
J'ai pas entendu mais peut-être. C'est
quoi votre patrimoine ? Pas pas très
important.
Je sais pas, il y a une déclaration de
patrimoine quand on Ouais, ouais, ouais,
vous pouvez voir, c'est public. Du coup,
vous vous rappelez pas du chiffre ? Non.
Euh, est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce que
votre invité peut-elle donner sa
définition du mot courage ?
J'aime bien ce genre de question. Euh,
courage, poser avec stacflation, hein.
Courage, ouais, je préfère stackflation.
C'est plus simple pour quelqu'un qui a
fait de l'écho. Non, courage, courage,
courage. C'est un mot magnifique. C'est
un mot qu'on emploie. On sait tous à
quoi ça renvoie. Le courage, c'est oser
faire des choses qui risqué, qui peuvent
ne pas nous apporter des ennuis où on se
fera pas forcément d'amis en le faisant.
C'est oser prendre le risque de de mener
une action, de tenir un propos qui
pourrait qui pourrait nous valoir des
ennuis. Question internet. Quelle voie
de sortie envisagez-vous au sujet du
conflit israélo-palestinien ?
Alors, je vais peut-être décevoir, mais
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de solution.
Je pense que ils sont voués à être dans
une forme de guerre longue euh
que la solution que à laquelle tout le
monde s'attend à savoir la solution à
deux états, c'est évidemment la plus
souhaitable, mais que dans une
perspective réaliste, aujourd'hui, je
vois pas comment elle pourrait être mise
en œuvre, c'est-à-dire comment trouver
quelque chose d'acceptable pour les deux
parties. Qui dirigerait l'État
palestinien ? Est-ce que c'est dans
l'état actuel des forces palestiniennes
à savoir le Has puisqu'il est en
position de force et dans l'opinion
publique et dans les armes, est-ce que
le Hamas laissera quelqu'un d'autre
diriger ? Est-ce que donc on aura deux
États qui vont cohabiter alors que l'un
des États a pour constitution la
destruction de l'autre ? C'est la charte
du Hamas, c'est la destruction de l'État
d'Israël, voilà, jusqu'à jusqu'à la
possession totale du pays. Enfin bref,
aujourd'hui, je vois pas une solution,
en tout cas moi, mais je suis peut-être
pas la plus la plus à même he de de la
trouver. Je pense que
bah, ils sont voués à se faire une
guerre qui sera très longue. Est-ce que
l'Europe et la France doivent
sanctionner Israël et mettre Israël sous
sanction ? Non, je crois pas. Moi, je
rentre pas dans ça parce que je me
souviens de pourquoi cette guerre est
est en cours. J'ai pas oublié le 7
octobre. Alors bien sûr, tout ne date
pas du 7 octobre, mais je crois que pour
Israël, il y a un enjeu vital euh
presque existentiel à montrer que ça ne
peut pas se produire sur son sol sans
que toutes les conséquences, à savoir la
détention des otages soient soient
résolu et je pense que c'est un
traumatisme qui va durer très longtemps.
Il en reste des otages dans Oui, il en
reste d'après les dire du Hamas qui dit
les détenir, peut-être qu'il mente. Mais
pourquoi il mentirait d'un côté alors
que ça pourrait arrêter la garder demain
? Donc oui, je pense qu'il qu'il en
reste s'il le disent que les Israéliens
le disent. Même Trump le dit, il en a il
a parmi la libération de l'un d'entre
eux la semaine dernière. Je pense
vraiment qu'il y a un enjeu existentiel
que ça laissera des traces pendant très
longtemps dans la confiance entre le la
population israélienne et son
gouvernement. Je pense que Nathanahou le
payera sans doute un jour. le fait que
ça ait pu arriver, qu' a pu avoir 1400
morts en une seule nuit, que c'est un
traumatisme pour un pays qui se croyait
fort, protégé. Enfin, c'est un peu
l'équivalent du traumatisme de la ligne
Magino. On se dit ça passera jamais. Et
puis en une nuit euh euh voilà, il y a
il y a ce qui se passe, des otages, des
morts, une fusiade dans un dans un
festival. Donc je pense que ça laissera
de grandes traces et que il y a eu un
enjeu existentiel à répondre et à dire
on peut pas on peut pas laisser ça impun
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ?
On pousse euh dans le sens de la paix à
un moment où euh pour la première fois,
j'ai l'impression depuis le début de ce
conflit, il y a un alignement européen
pour enfin prononcer le Mopai. Quand
Trump disait la paix il y a il y a 100
jours, il y a 3 mois quand il a été élu,
les gens disaient "C'est un poutiniste
parce qu'il parle de paix." Les gens qui
parlent de paix sont des poutinistes.
Vous devez vous souvenir de de cette
époque. Alle, on passe le 10e 17e paquet
de sanction là. Ouais. Sanction, ça veut
pas dire très paix, hein. Non, c'est le
contraire. C'est-à-dire que à mesure on
peut se dire maintenant il y a un
alignement, Trump demande la même chose.
Zlanski est en train de se dire ça
m'arrange plus vraiment, ça peut pas
durer aussi longtemps. La Russie a l'air
de de continuer d'avancer et
manifestement là, ils vont pas perdre de
mains. Donc maintenant que vous avez
deux parties importantes à ce conflit,
on sait que les États-Unis ont joué un
rôle majeur sans lequel la guerre
n'aurait jamais pu continuer. On sait
que l'Ukraine voulait entendre parler de
tout sauf de paix il y a encore quelques
mois. Et là, vous avez un alignement
C2-là. Vraiment, je trouverai à rebour
de l'histoire, totalement
contre-productif que ce soit les
Européens qui se mettent à alimenter les
volontés béliqueuses.
Euh, un petit coup de fact checking.
Euh, il y en a un qui me dit "Faux
sondage de 2011 concernant le si les
Français veulent rester favorable au
nucléaire. 42 % pour la sortie, 55
contre euh euh les échos."
Bon, passons. Je suis sûr qu'on peut en
trouver un majoritaire. J'ai vraiment ce
souvenir. Une question sur votre homme,
on s'en fout, on la passe quand même ?
Les bravo. Éric Zemour est-il un macho
quand on a pu comme on a pu le dépeindre
parfois, doit-il être déconstruit ? Est
est-il un homme est-il un homme à
s'investir dans les tâches ménagères ?
Ah oui, c'est un c'est un farceur. Bah
est-ce que j'ai l'air de d'être avec un
matcho ? Je sais pas. Enfin, à vous de
juger mon caractère et de dire si Ouais.
Voilà.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet qu'on a pas
abordé ensemble ? Ah, il y en a il y en
a 1000. Bah, choisis en deux, je dire
parce que là, ça fait 3h09 minutes. Non,
c'est vrai. Ouais, passe vite quand on
s'amuse.
Euh, vous êtes amusé ? Bah euh j'espère
euh j'espère autant que vous et ceux qui
nous écoutent. Non, il y en a plein sans
doute qu'on a pas abordé. Alors
qu'est-ce que ça pourrait être ? Le Mont
Saint-Michel, il est breton ou il est
normand ? Non, je déconne.
Pain au chocolat ou chocolatine. Euh
P Lu, l'Euro il va il va il va survivre
ou vous pariez sur que sur le fait que
l'euro va se dévaluer pour nous faire
une dévaluation compétitive pour masquer
le fait qu'on a pas d'énergie, qu'on a
plus d'industrie et que
on va on va dans le mur.
Euh est-ce que l'euro va survivre ? Bah
comme on prédit sa mort tous les ans
depuis que je suis née euh un peu après
ma naissance parce que c'est 89 c'est ça
? Non moi je suis dans 93
comme on prédit ça chute tous les ans.
J'ai pas envie de jouer à la collapague
et de collapse solague et de me tromper.
Donc je sais pas peut-être peut-être
qu'il va survivre c'est dur à dire. Et
ce qu'on va dévaluer bah ce serait
une sorte de drogue douce en fait. Et
c'est d'ailleurs un peu ce qui a été
l'euro pour nous, c'est on s'est endormi
euh on s'est endormi sur l'euro parce
que vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure,
notre dette, la soutenabilité de notre
dette tient beaucoup euh à notre monnaie
et tient beaucoup au fait que l'euro est
resté une monnaie crédible, notamment
longtemps grâce au modèle économique
allemand qui tirait encore l'Europe vers
le haut et qui créait un peu la
confiance des investisseurs. Et donc
nous, on s'est endormi pendant
longtemps. On a creusé nos déficits, on
n pas voté un budget à l'équilibre
depuis 1974.
On a creusé donc par conséquence logique
notre dette. On a continué à avoir des
dépenses publiques aberrentes. Je vous
en ai cité un seul exemple, mais je
pourrais aller beaucoup plus loin. On a
continué donc à dilapider de l'argent, à
miser sur la consommation plutôt que sur
la production et cetera et cetera. Et
l'euro nous a permis donc de commettre
toutes ces erreurs économiques parce
qu'on était endormi par le fait de ne
jamais le payer en terme de monnaie.
Donc aujourd'hui, tout l'enjeu pour nous
va être de se réveiller euh avec ce
bouclier qui est encore l'euro,
c'est-à-dire queon n'est pas encore en
en crash sur les marchés et les gens
continuent d'acheter de la dette
française envers et contre toute attente
alors que il y a manifestement pas
d'effort qui se profile avec ce
gouvernement. Mais quand un nouveau
gouvernement arrivera et le le plus vite
sera le mieux, il y a un véritable plan
de de redressement des finances
publiques à mettre en œuvre. C'est
exactement ce qu'avait fait le général
de Gaul en 58 avec le plan RUEf. Ça
prend de temps. En très peu de temps, ça
produit ses effets. Il coupe dans la
dépense. Il arrive à retrouver de la
croissance. Il engage un modèle
productif. Si on compare, pour pas que
je je donne l'impression de vous donner
que des exemples très vieux, si on
compare avec quelque chose de très
récent, vous prenez l'Argentine de
Miley. L'Argentine de Miley, quoi qu'on
en dise, il obtient des effets et de
manière assez spectaculaire et très
rapide. Il y a pas les États-Unis
derrière lui peut-être, mais en tout
cas, il y avait les États-Unis par le
passé et il ils y arrivaient pas. Et
vous voyez des années de péronisme, donc
vraiment un pays qui arrive presque à
nous concurrencer en terme de
socialisme. Euh, ils avaient les mêmes
titres de ministères que les nôtres.
Vous vous rappelez de la vidéo quand il
fait afuera fuera, il sort tous les
ministères. On a presque la même
panoplie de ministère inutiles qui nous
coûte une fortune et qui n'améliore
jamais ne serait-ce qu'un seul instant
la vie d'un seul français. Euh et donc
Miley remède de choc, il arrive avec sa
tronçonneuse. Alors c'est peut-être un
peu beaucoup et moi j'aime pas trop le
le côté folklore, c'est pas ce qui me
parle, mais il a un vrai raisonnement
écho. C'est un prof d'écho. Il arrive
avec des remèdes très forts et il
obtient des résultats même pas un an
plus tard. Il a presque tous les
indicateurs macros qui sont ouverts. Son
taux d'inflation est inférieur au nôtre
aujourd'hui, 2,78 % hier. admirable
quand on connaît les taux de d'inflation
de l'Argentine, c'était des taux à deux
chiffres quand il est arrivé au pouvoir.
Une monnaie qui se dévaluait
pratiquement même dans la journée. Euh
c'est ça ça enfin ça c'est une situation
qui rappelait presque l'Allemagne des
années 20 avec les gens achet du
placoplâtre pour stocker leur pouvoir
d'achat parce qu'ils avaient pas assez
de sous pour acheter de l'or. Donc ils
achetaient du placoplâtre. Bah ouais
terrible. Et donc là en plus on voit
donc il supprime dans la dépense
publique. Tout le monde lui avait dit
"Bon d'accord, ça va peut-être faire
baisser l'inflation. Il y a un effet
très inflationniste des dépenses publque
si vous voulez qu'on en dise deux mots."
Je pense que c'est aussi ce qui explique
le succès de Bitcoin aujourd'hui. Donc
il y a un effet très inflationniste aux
dépenses publiques. Certains disaient
"OK Mily, vu qu'il va s'abrer dans la
dépense publique, ça va peut-être
baisser l'inflation mais ça va faire
exploser le taux de pauvreté." Et là
miracle, on s'aperçoit que non seulement
l'inflation a chuté, mais en plus le
taux de pauvreté baisse. Donc pour le
coup, on s'aperçoit que tout le discours
socialiste qui visait à dire "Vous ne
devez vivre que dans la main de l'État,
ça n'est que grâce à l'État que vous
allez trouver votre moyen de subsistance
et cetera est presque battu en brèche
par encore une fois cette expérience
grandeur nature." Moi, j'aime bien quand
ce genre de de de petit miracle ou
d'expérience se produisent de notre
vivant parce que ça donne à voir aux
gens quelque chose qui leur donne de
l'espoir. Et et si je peux me permettre
cette incise, ce que je regrette le plus
aujourd'hui, c'est que j'ai l'impression
que pour beaucoup ont les Français pour
le coup, pas la classe politique, on
n'est passé d'une forme de dénialisme.
C'est-à-dire que pendant des années, on
s'est dit "Non, en fait
ceux qui disent ça, ils sont
déclinistes, ils sont pessimistes, ils
sont populistes et cetera. Le niveau ne
baisse pas, l'éducation n'est pas si
nulle, on a dit ça au début et cetera."
Ils sont passés de ce déni à soudain,
"Ah, en fait, notre situation est
tellement grave qu'on pourra jamais s'en
sortir." Et il y a pas eu de transition.
Il y a pas eu un moment où on s'est dit
"Bon, OK, en fait c'est grave mais on va
prendre des mesures et ça va aller." On
est tout de suite passé à c'est
tellement grave qu'on pourra jamais y
arriver. Et moi, j'aimerais en tout cas,
c'est l'objectif que je me fixe
modestement, c'est qu'on arrive à passer
aujourd'hui du fatalisme à l'espoir. Et
je pense que pour passer du fatalisme à
l'espoir, ça doit beaucoup reposer sur
du concret, de la méthode et pas de
l'esprouve politicienne comme les gens
répondent souvent quand on dit "Mais
comment vous allez faire pour je sais
pas résoudre le problème de la
délinquence ?" Par la volonté politique
? Les gens il répondent toujours ça
parce que j'ai du caractère, moi je
crois plus à ça. Les gens qui disent par
la volonté politique, je me dis il a
aucune idée, il a pas de mesure, il y a
pas de concret, il sait pas où il veut
aller. Donc je pense que l'espoir
aujourd'hui, on peut le donner aux gens
en leur parlant de choses concrètes.
C'est aussi pour ça que j'essaie
beaucoup de parler de chiffres, pour ça
que je m'entoure d'ingénieur, que
j'essaie d'être dans dans les faits dans
les faits et la méthode. Connaiss vous
connaissez le renoncement de
Saint-Pierre ?
Je finis par Moi, je sortirai de ce
monde où l'action n'est pas sœur du
rêve.
Question internet. Est-ce que vous
utilisez ces vrais problèmes entre
parenthèses dépenses inutiles entre
guillemets et fermez la parenthèse pour
faire passer vos idées
identitaires/idéologiques
?
Ah, je suis désolé, j'ai pas vraiment
compris la question. Je la relis telle
qu'elle a été formulée. Est-ce que vous
utilisez ces vrais problèmes entre
parenthèses dépenses ouvrez les
guillemets inutile fermez les
guillemets, fermez la parenthèse pour
faire passer vos idées
identitaires/idéologiques
?
Ah ok. Est-ce que c'est un cheval de 3
Est-ce que c'est une stratégie ? Ah non.
Bah alors, j'ai choisi d'être magistrate
à la cour des comptes parce que j'avais
déjà en tête que je voulais être un
cheval de 3. Non non non franchement
non. C'est bah je disais tout à l'heure
qu'à un moment j'allais vous raconter
pourquoi il y a un côté frustrant quand
on est magistrat à la cour des comptes.
Du coup, j'en viens là et peut-être que
cette personne comprendra à quel point à
quel point c'est sincère. Donc quand
j'ai choisi d'être magistrate à la Cour
des comptes, c'était en en 2000, c'était
début 2020, c'était juste après la crise
des gilets jaunes. Et quelque chose
m'avait frappé au moment des gilets
jaunes. Euh j'avais j'avais tir de LBD
40 en pleine tête comme dans un régime
autoritaire. Ouais. Bah ça c'est clair.
En plus j'en j'en j'en ai fait partie.
J'en ai fait quelques-unes et cetera.
J'étais dans le Bernne, je vous ai dit.
Donc j'étais sur les ronds-points les
vrais dans le cœur de la France. Après
quand je suis rentrée à Paris euh bah
j'étais sur les Champsélysées plusieurs
fois et cetera et quelque chose me
frappait. En plus, moi j'étais enfin
comment dire, je me sentais dès l'heure.
J'étais en train de finir ma scolarité à
Lena, il y avait une sorte de je
rentrais en cours le lundi, j'étais avec
des gens qui étaient tellement
différents. Le le dimanche, j'étais avec
les samedis, j'étais avec les gilets
jaunes. Enfin bon, voilà, chacun chacun
évolue en gardant sa cohérence entre
plusieurs mondes. Euh et quelque chose
me frappait à ce moment-là. Donc je vous
disais, j'étais dans ma sortie de Léna,
je devais choisir l'institution dans
laquelle j'allais j'allais sortir.
Est-ce que j'allais choisir Bery ?
Est-ce que j'allais choisir la
diplomatie, la préfectorale ? Et à ce
moment-là, donc quand vous sortez de
LENA, il y a un classement et vous
choisissez selon votre classement le
poste dans lequel vous allez aller. À ce
moment-là, quelque chose qui a quelle
place ? Bah, généralement, on dit pas
son classement, mais j'étais dans ce
qu'on appelle la botte. Donc, en gros,
c'est les postes qui sont bien classés
et qui nous permettent de de prétendre à
ce qu'on appelle les grands corps. Il y
en a trois. Les grands corps, c'est
l'inspection générale des finances, ce
qui a pris Macron, le Conseil d'État.
Euh voilà. Euh et la cour des comptes.
La Cour des comptes, c'était
l'institution dans la que présidait
Philippe Ségain, dans laquelle était
Marie-France Garot. Euh feu Philippe
Séin, feu Marie-France Garot. Feu
Philippe Séin. Deux deux personnes que
j'ai que j'ai beaucoup aimé. L'une que
j'ai eu la chance de connaître,
Marie-Fance Garot, Philippe Ségain, que
j'aurais rêvé de connaître mais je n'ai
pas eu cette chance.
et et donc quelque chose me frappait au
moment des gilets jaunes. C'était le
moment où j'étais dans mon choix. Je me
disais qu'est-ce que je vais faire ?
Qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de faire ? Et
cetera. Et quelque chose me frappait,
c'était que j'entendais très souvent
parler de la Cour des comptes dans les
ministères avec mes copains
fonctionnaires, enfin dans les dans les
milieux de la haute fonction publique.
Mais au cœur des manifestations des
gilets jaunes, c'était l'institution qui
était le plus citée. La Cour des comptes
a dit ceci, il y a tel Gabji, la Cour
des comptes a dit cela et cetera. Et je
me suis dit en fait cette institution
c'est peut-être l'une des dernières qui
n'est pas entachée. Il y a comme c'est
comme le juge de paix où les gens se
disent la cours des comptes on sait
qu'on peut croire. Les recommandations
de la cour des comptes, on peut on peut
les passer à l'AS. Ah bah justement
c'est là que j'arrive au côté un peu
frustrant. Donc sur la partie constat en
en revanche, tout le monde se dit on
peut les croire et en plus je pense
qu'il y a un côté c'est pas Robin des
Bois mais c'est voilà des gens qui sont
des magistrats qui sont au
fonctionnaires. Certains ont fait l'ENAT
et pourtant leur métier c'est de taper
sur l'État et c'est de dire là ils
dépensent trop là ils font n'importe
quoi avec votre argent. C'est un peu le
chénon manquant entre l'opinion
publique, le peuple et l'administration
qui sinon ferait tout en cachette. Et
donc là au milieu, il y a une
institution qui dit "Moi, mon rôle c'est
de tout vous montrer." Et donc de faire
des rapports. On dévoile tout ce que
font les administrations. Là où elle
dépense mal, là où elle dépense euh
comment dire euh de manière non
efficace, non efficiente, là où l'argent
pourrait être mieux utilisé, quelle
politique publique
s'avère être un peu n'importe quoi, mal
géré et cetera. Et donc le sentiment que
j'avais à ce moment-là, c'est que
c'était peut-être l'une des dernières
institutions alors même que tout le
monde voulait jeter LENA, que c'est le
moment où Macron a hypocritement changé
le nom de LENA sans la supprimer. Mais
donc à ce moment-là, je me suis dit
finalement, c'est quand même le l'un des
derniers bastions de bah de probité,
d'endroit qui a un vrai souci de de
l'intérêt général, de l'emploi de
l'argent des gens et cetera. Et donc
j'ai choisi cette institution.
J'ai choisi cette institution. Il y
avait un bruit.
Il y a quelqu'un qui veut qu'on sorte.
Euh j'ai choisi cette institution, j'y
ai appris énormément. C'est une fenêtre
de vue sur l'État, sur l'administration
publique qui est extraordinaire. On peut
tout voir, on a des pouvoirs de
magistrat, on a des pouvoirs d'enquête.
Donc, on peut tout demander aux
administrations, leurs documents.
Parfois, on peut se rendre euh sur les
lieux, avoir des bureaux sur place, y
rester pour essayer de comprendre
comment les choses se jouent. Ensuite,
on fait des rapports et là, on arrive à
la partie un peu plus frustrante, c'est
que dans ces rapports, on fait donc des
recommandations. On dit à l'État arrêtez
de dépenser ici, faites plutôt ça comme
ça, réorganisez-vous comme ceci et
cetera. Mais ces recommandations n'ont
pas de force exécutoire, c'est-à-dire
qu'elles peuvent pas entrer en
application immédiatement, tout
simplement parce qu'un magistraturait
décidé. Pourquoi ? D'un côté, on peut se
dire c'est n'importe quoi, nous on
travaille et on voit ce qui se passe mal
et cetera. D'un autre, si on essaie
quand même de comprendre la raison, vous
avez des gens qui dépendent du
gouvernement qui ont été nommés par un
président de la République qui a été
élu, qui représente le peuple, donc la
démocratie.
ces gens-là qui qui sont qui revêtent la
légitimité démocratique et qui agissent.
On peut considérer que c'est normal, que
ce ne soit pas le rôle euh d'une jeune
femme qui vient d'avoir un diplôme euh
de l'ENAT euh que ce soit pas à moi
d'aller leur imposer euh sinon on
appellerait ça la technocratie qui
existe d'ailleurs dans notre pays. Mais
on se dirait c'est quand même n'importe
quoi. Vous avez un ministre qui
représente x euh partie de la
population, le président l'a nommé et
vous avez des technocrates qui peuvent
décider du jour au lendemain de lui
empêcher de sa politique et cetera.
C'est pour cette raison que les
recommandations de la Cour des comptes
n'ont pas euh ne peuvent pas s'imposer
d'elles-même. Mais le côté très
frustrant, c'est qu'on voit des
aberrations et qu'on peut pas les
corriger. Par ailleurs, on a un devoir
de réserve. Donc quand on est à la Cour
des comptes, on peut pas aller raconter
partout ce qu'on y voit. On peut pas
dire aux gens non mais il faut qu'on
agisse, il se passe quelque chose de fou
et cetera. On ne peut dire que ce qui
est publié dans le rapport. Quand on
publie quelque chose dans un rapport,
c'est collégial. Donc tout le monde a
son mot à dire et cetera avant que ça
passe. Bref, euh c'est une fenêtre de
vue exceptionnelle, mais finalement pour
ce qui est des moyens d'action, je suis,
j'avoue euh sans vouloir y revenir
indéfiniment, beaucoup plus satisfaite
quand je m'aperçois qu'avec une
émission, on a réussi à gagner 2
milliards d'euros sur l'aide publique au
développement. Ça c'est je suis c'est
non c'est le ministre c'est pas mon
interprétation c'est mon c'est ma
lecture. Question de nounours.
Bonsoir
nounours. Pourquoi ? Ouais c'est c'est
l'ours.
Une bête pour aller chercher des
sources. On l'embrasse fort d'ailleurs.
Bonsoir. Pourquoi êtes-vous allé à
l'investiture de Donald Trump ?
Euh alors d'abord parce que j'y étais
invitée euh que c'était dit invité comme
Anouna ou vous étiez invité genre invité
invité euh bah je sais pas comment était
invité à Nouna mais moi j'y ai été
invité pour le coup par l'administration
Trump. Euh vous avez reçu une petite
enveloppe par l'ambassade américaine ou
avant l'ambassade américaine ? Comment
ça s'est passé ? Euh plus prosaïquement
par email. J'ai reçu une invitation donc
qui a invité à la cérémonie
d'investiture et qui a invité votre
email comment ? Euh bah alors si on
refait l'histoire avec un tout petit peu
de recul, euh j'ai euh j'ai fait un
discour lancé la campagne de Trump. Moi
non j'ai pas les moyens. Euh j'ai
j'avais fait un discours sur
l'intelligence artificielle au Parlement
européen et ce discours euh on l'avait
traduit en anglais par Lia et et je ne
sais par quel miracle de Twitter X le
discours s'est retrouvé à faire un mini
buzz aux États-Unis et donc il a
commencé à tourner un peu dans des
sphères anglophones et donc à cette
occasion euh pas mal de de je sais pas
de d'entrepreneurs de la tech m'ont
écrit sur Twitter en disant bravo pour
ce discours. J'ai remarqué d'ailleurs à
cette occasion, même si on aurait pu le
deviner que pour eux l'Europe était
vraiment le symbole absolu de tout ce
qu'il rejetait. On était on était en
pleine campagne de Trump, ça devait être
au mois de septembre 2024 mais je pense
que c'est facile de retrouver ce
discours là. Et bon voilà, mini buzz et
les gens se sont vraiment dit "Ah quel
symbole de de la la réglementation à
outrance, cette Europe qui accroche les
bouchons aux bouteilles. Enfin, vous
voyez comme les les gens se moquent un
peu de nous dans dans les autres pays.
Et donc euh mini buzz, je j'entre en
contact avec pas mal de gens qui se
trouvent à être des entrepreneurs de la
tech et qui par ailleurs euh étaient de
plus en plus séduit par le discours de
Trump, notamment du fait de l'arrivée
d'Elon Musk. Et parmi ces gens euh un un
jeune homme qui s'appelle Jacob Elberg
que j'ai connu à cette occasion et qui
maintenant est devenu ministre de Trump.
Donc il est en charge de la croissance
de l'énergie
et de l'environnement.
Et ce garçon là donc on a on a un peu
échangé et ensuite il m'a invité donc
aux États-Unis. Je suis allée à
l'investiture, c'était pour le coup
vraiment intéressant. J'ai appris
énormément de choses. J'ai euh surtout,
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure un peu
du Bitcoin. Je pense que c'était la la
meilleure rencontre n'était pas
politique. En fait, c'était avec Michael
Sailor. Donc il m'a invité chez lui. On
a discuté très longuement. Ça ça va vous
ça va vous faire sourire la discussion.
Donc on est resté peut-être 4h ensemble
et la discussion sur les 4 heures à a
porté pendant 3h sur le nucléaire.
Donc c'était on a parlé du Bitcoin
forcément puisque c'est quand même le le
gourou mondial du Bitcoin. Alors lui
pour le coup si vous lui demander son
patrimoine, on fait tous pas le figure.
Euh franchement j'ai oublié le chiffre
mais c'est colossal. C'est plusieurs
centaines de milliards je crois. Enfin
vraiment c'est énorme.
et en Bitcoin. Et donc Sailor euh très
belle rencontre lui aussi pour le coup
pro Trump pour dire un mot un peu de de
l'investiture parce que les gens se
demande un peu comment ça s'organise les
États-Unis
vieux pays décentralisé qui a eu qui a
pour coutume depuis 200 ans, à chaque
fois qu'un président est nouvellement
élu
de faire une grande semaine de festivité
autour de l'élection du président au
cours de laquelle toutes les petites
élites ou toutes les élites économiques
politiques culturel du pays viennent de
tous les États-Unis, donc de chacun des
États viennent à Washington et il
organisent chacun sa cérémonie, son bal,
son brunch et cetera. Donc vous avez par
exemple
euh chaque jour chaque journal, chaque
presse qui va faire son propre brunch,
chaque secteur qui va organiser sa
soirée. Vous aviez la soirée de Uber, la
soirée de X organisée par Elon Musk et
pour la première fois la soirée des
cryptonnaies. Incroyable vraiment, je
pense que c'était la meilleure soirée,
la soirée des cryptos. Et c'était le
premier soir et Trump avait fait un
discours, il avait un peu énervé
d'ailleurs les vrais bitcoiners en
parlant de son même coin qu'il lançait
ce soir-là. C'est ça avait été un peu
mal reçu. C'est pas une petite arnaque
ça ? Non. Bah bah c'était un peu mal
reçu parce que ça faisait euh à la fois
jeu alors que pour euh pour ceux qui
sont vraiment intéressés au Bitcoin,
c'est pas un jeu. C'est pas des joueurs
de casino. Et en plus ça faisait
bénéfice personnel, ce qui est pas très
pas joli. Enfin bon, je ferme la
parenthèse. Et donc cette cette
investiture, OK, je vous ai passé les
détails de l'histoire américaine et
cetera. Ce que ce qui m'a le plus marqué
et ce qu'on peut en tirer en tant que
français. D'abord, ce que j'ai aimé,
c'est que dans son discours
d'investiture, en principe, dans les
discours d'investiture, quel qu'il soit
aux États-Unis, en France, n'importe où,
en principe, dès qu'un président a élu,
on remarque tout ce qui baisse d'un ton.
Il s'est fait élire avec des grandes
promesses en jurant au peuple qu'il
allait faire ceci ou cela. Et dès qu'ils
sont élus, étonnamment, parfois, il y a
une forme de
comme s'il reculait. Alors maintenant
que j'ai gagné, je vais plus vous
promettre tout ça parce que finalement
je vous ai un peu menti, c'est plus
difficile. Donc ils promettent toujours
un peu moins dès qu'ils ont gagné. Et là
Trump tout le contraire le jour J, je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez, il fait
son discours d'investiture, il y a Biden
en face de lui, il est à deux doigts de
l'insulter, il repromet tout, il fait un
discours hyper long pour le coup
Harissime dans l'histoire des États-Unis
de faire un discours aussi punch et
aussi long, pas formel le jour de son
élection. Et juste après, il arrive dans
une salle et on y était, il arrive dans
une salle où il y avait bah les
Américains qui l'avaient élu tout
simplement. Il pose un bureau au milieu
de la pièce, c'était une sorte d'arène.
Il pose un bureau qui est une
reproduction de du de son bureau à la
Maison Blanche. Et là, il a 30 décrets
et il les signe comme ça devant le
peuple qu'il a élu. Si vous aviez vu la
tête des gens, il y avait une forme de
jubilation où les gens vraiment presque
pleuraient. les Américains et c'était
des Américains enfin de de toutes les de
tous les États-Unis, ils étaient venus
en voiture du Texas. Enfin, vraiment
incroyable. Des vrais des des vrais
trumpistes heureux de cette de cette
victoire. Et les mecs pleuraient en se
disant c'est la première fois de notre
vie qu'on vote et que ça sert à quelque
chose. Ça sert enfin à quelque chose. Il
est en train de signer devant nous tout
ce qui a fait qu'on l'avait élu pour ça.
Et donc je me suis dit ce qu'il y a à en
tirer en réalité c'est que un, il faut
être prêt tout de suite quand on arrive
au pouvoir. Et de je pense que
maintenant et je le disais tout à
l'heure, il faut conjurer le fatalisme
par du concret et il faut montrer aux
gens que c'est encore possible. Sinon,
je pense que notre penchant naturel, ce
sera de se dire "La politique, ça sert à
rien. Plus personne peut changer les
choses. On est tombé tellement bas qu'on
y arrivera pas." Et c'est ce quoi je
pense que maintenant doit se situer le
combat. Il faut plus lutter. Tout à
l'heure, un monsieur disait "Est-ce
qu'il faut être choquant et tout ?" Non,
franchement, il faut pas être choquant.
Les Français sont lucides. Ça y est, on
les a convaincu. On regarde tous les
sondages. Alors, désolé pour celui qui
donnait 42 % au lieu de 51, mais on
regarde tous les sondages, on voit des
majorités écrasantes sur nos sujets.
Quand vous demandez aujourd'hui aux gens
sur tous les sujets qui sont les nôtres,
que ce soit la souveraineté, que ce soit
sur une forme de méfiance vis-à-vis de
l'UE, que ce soit euh sur les sujets de
l'immigration, de fermeture des
frontières, de justice fiscale ou
sociale et cetera, vous avez presque 70
% à chaque fois. Donc à mon sens, le
combat ne se joue plus. sur le fait de
convaincre les gens qu'on a raison, mais
sur le fait de les convaincre que alors
qu'on a raison, on peut encore changer
les choses et voilà comment on va les
changer. Les retraites, on fait comment
pour les changer ? capitalisation,
c'est un la le système par répartition
reposé sur Impact euh qui disait au
boomers, comme les appellent ceux qui
les aiment pas, "On va payer vos
retraites mais en échange, vous devez
faire une seule chose, des enfants." Ils
n'ont pas fait d'enfants, la génération
qui nous précède. Donc on a bah l'arbre
démographique qu'on connaît. On ne peut
plus,
on y arrive plus. C'est un système qui
est voué soit à ne plus se financer,
soit à exiger des Français des efforts
sacrificiels à intervalle régulier. Donc
leur dire à chaque fois il y a 20
milliards à combler, vous allez encore
travailler 2 ans de plus. J'ai cru que
vous ayez me dire qu'on allait réduire
la vie en en petite barrette verte et en
petite barrette jaune. Je suis pas jacat
moi. Euh donc soit leur dire tous les 2
ans. Ah en fait maintenant c'est encore
2 ans 64
70 jusqu'à quand ? Puisqueen réalité le
problème est démographique. Donc ça ça
marche pas. Donc à mon avis maintenant
il faut passer au système par
capitalisation. Les gens disent beaucoup
les Français sont attachés au système
par répartition. Moi je crois pas. Je
crois qu'ils y sont ligotés. Qu'ils ont
peur d'en sort euthanasie.
C'est très vague. Donc je dirais contre
à une question posée de manière aussi
vague. Euh pour en dire juste un mot.
Imaginez-vous, vous êtes à l'ostau, on
sait que vous êtes téraplégique
au dernier degré et en plus vous êtes
dans le coma. Ça fait 2 ans que vous
êtes dans le coma. Vous vous réveillez
et vous êtes en train d'écrire un petit
livre avec vos yeux.
Je alors je veux pas du tout faire
pleurer dans les chaumières ni raconter
ma vie mais c'est un sujet que je
connais vraiment pour le coup très bien.
J'avais un petit frère handicapé
thétrégique. J'ai jamais à aucune
seconde de ma vie pensé que sa vie ne
méritait pas d'être vécue parce qu'il
était tétraplégique.
Bah, je sais pas vous dire,
malheureusement, il ne il n'avait pas la
parole. Euh, donc je sais pas vous dire
à sa place, mais quoi qu'il en soit,
s'il avait pu le dire, que que puis-je
savoir malheureusement, s'il avait pu le
dire, j'en je ne sais pas. Donc sur sur
l'euthanasis, je vous réponds, vous me
dites pour ou contre l'euthanasie, donc
comme ça, je vous dis contre. En
réalité, ça existe déjà. On est en train
d'en enlever plusieurs gardes de fou,
d'en faire sauter les verrou et cetera.
Pourquoi ? C'est quelque chose qui me
fait peur à titre personnel, c'est que
l'euthanasie repose beaucoup sur la
liberté de choix.
prétendu de la personne qui va dire
"Alors, je veux mourir." Moi, je pense
que certes, on est libre, mais que notre
choix est beaucoup dicté par ce que nous
dit la société. Et quand la société vous
fait comprendre
que quand vous êtes par exemple cette
phrase, un légume, alors vous ne méritez
pas la vie. que quand vous êtes mourant
et en soin palliatif, vous êtes un poids
pour la société, que vous coûtez trop
cher, quand votre famille peut parfois
vous faire sentir que c'est un poids
pour elle, que c'est douloureux, parfois
pour des raisons très égoïstes, pas
envie d'aller à l'hôpital toutes les
semaines, angoissé de l'aspect morbide
et cetera. Franchement, je sais ce que
c'est he, c'est pas quelque chose de
gay, c'est un devoir, c'est pas facile.
Beaucoup aimeraient sortir de ce tunnel
et se dire "Je veux éviter toute cette
angoisse et cetera." Donc quand vous
êtes soumis à cette pression sociale,
familiale,
où est votre liberté ? Dans quelle
mesure est-ce que votre choix est
totalement libre quand la société vous a
fait comprendre de votre vivant et quand
la société nous fait comprendre à nous
qu'en réalité on devient un poids parce
qu'on est malade et dans quelle mesure
est-ce que finalement on a encore notre
libre arbitre quand la société nous a
mis en tête que l'euthanasie était
légitime et parfois même souhaitable
dans ces conditions-là ? Moi c'est ça
qui me fait peur et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je souhaite pas qu'on aille
plus loin. Je crois qu'on a trouvé un
bon équilibre dans la loi Léonetti.
Cette loi-là me fait peur. Je trouve
qu'elle va trop loin, qu'elle fait
sauter tous les verrous et qu'elle peut
mettre des choses dangereuses dans la
tête des gens. Vous avez déjà fait des
soins palliatifs dans votre famille ?
Bah oui.
Question concernant Trump. Vous vous
rappelez de la soirée des élections où
vous aviez un ancien ambassadeur en face
de vous ? Ah oui ! Ah bah mémoire ! Bah
qu'est-ce qu'il avait dit Pépé ?
Euh, on était sur LCI et oui, c'était un
ancien ambassadeur, je crois qu'il
s'appelle Charles Michel, on lui fait de
la pub. Euh, et il me disait,
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir.
Ouais. Il disait "Camala Haris a déjà
gagné." La présidente Camala, il parlait
comme ça, la présidente Camala. Je Mais
attendez monsieur, les bureaux de vote
sont même pas encore fermés, respectez
quand même le peuple américain. Et il me
dit "Mais moi j'ai déjà voté, j'ai voté
contre Trump et cetera." Mais vous vous
êtes pas les États-Unis à vous tout
seul. Et il me disant mais vous allez
voir
Camala a déjà gagné et cetera. Je mais
qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire ça ? Et il
me dit parce que Trump n'est pas
démocrate. Je attendez Trump n'est pas
démocrate mais vous vous parlez à la
place de tous les Américains. Vous
appelez président de quelqu'un qui n'a
même pas encore gagné mais qui n'est pas
démocrate ici. Et après en rigolant, je
lui avais dit bon OK Nostradamus. Et
quand j'avais dit OK Nostradamus euh
c'est là que cette ces petites séquences
étaient devenues un peu
avait beaucoup tourné sur les réseaux.
Comment ça se fait qu'on n pas vu, du
moins, on va pas dire on, comment ça se
fait que la classe médiatique,
diplomatique
et j'en passé des milleurs ? Ils ont pas
vu l'élection de Trump encore une fois.
Euh je pense c'est du déni,
c'est d'abord autant intoxiqués avec
leur propre couverture médiatique.
Ouais, je pense que quand on veut pas
que quelque chose arrive, on a tendance
à croire que ça n'arrivera pas. euh
d'abord penchant, humain, donc euh pas
pour les excuser, mais je pense qu'il y
a aussi euh ce cette forme
d'autoonviction. Deuxième chose euh
alors même que les sondages montraient
qu'il était fort quand même. Ça qui est
fou, c'est que ils avaient quand même
devant eux la preuve qu'il y avait une
dynamique euh certaine.
Euh il ils ont voulu sans doute
peut-être par idéologie aussi se dire
"Non, les États-Unis on les aime trop
pour que pour qu'ils fassent une chose
pareille et on revient à leur atlantisme
à leur atlantisme."
Ensuite, dans la conséquence qui est
quand même très surprenante, c'est que
ces mêmes gens qui se sont trompés sur
tout sont encore les mêmes qui
aujourd'hui euh nous disent parfois sur
le même sujet, "Ouais, il va se planter
sur ça, on est sûr, il a fait ceci, il a
reculé et cetera." Et on les croit comme
s'ils avaient comme si rien ne s'était
passé. Il y a une forme de pardon ou
d'oubli. On se on a oublié que ces mêmes
gens en réalité ne sont plus crédibles.
Ils devraient plus avoir le droit à la
parole sur le sujet. Ou alors on devrait
mettre un bandeau en dessous pour redire
la veille, il pensait que Trump avait
perdu. Euh plus crédible, on vous croit
plus. Est-ce que vous avez trois livres
à conseiller à notre communauté ou
est-ce que vous avez un autre sujet
qu'on a ça fait 3h38 là. On peut finir
sur des livres, c'est beau. On f
toujours sur des livres et un conseil
pour les jeunes générations. Donc trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté.
OK. Euh interdiction de conseiller les
livres de Zemour. Ouais, ça va. Euh donc
euh Ah, il y en aurait des dizaines.
J'avais créé une association qui
s'appelle Alexandre Aristote et qui sert
d'ailleurs de à à conseiller des livres
des livres aux jeunes gens. Euh donc euh
ça existe encore si les gens veulent le
voir. Euh donc trois livres, trois
livres. Trois livres. Euh je vais
essayer d'en donner pour pour tous les
goûts. Belle du Seigneur d'Albert Cohen
pour pour les plus les plus sensibles
d'entre vous. Très beau livre, très long
mais quand on quand on le ferme, on
regrette qu'il a été si court. Alors
qu'au début, on a du mal à s'y mettre en
se disant "C'est 1000 pages, j'y
arriverai pas." Magnifique livre sur à
la fois sur la passion, sur la passion
amoureuse, euh sur les relations entre
les hommes et les femmes, mais aussi, je
le citais tout à l'heure, un diplomate à
la Société des Nations très désabusé sur
euh la vanité, l'inutilité de ce métier
parfois et notamment dans les années où
il y est. Donc vraiment très beau livre.
Euh 2è livre, alors rien à voir, euh
Avril Brisé d'Ismaï Kadar, euh le plus
grand auteur albanais qui aurait sans
doute mérité un prix Nobel comme Kundera
mais qui ne l'aura jamais vu que on a le
prix Nobel que de son vivant et que
maintenant malheureusement il est
décédé. Euh donc Isma Cadaret, Avril
Brisé, livre magnifique sur euh le le
choc entre une société ultra moderne qui
est la nôtre et une société très
traditionnelle euh qui se réfugie encore
jusqu'à nos jours dans les montagnes
albanaises. Euh donc c'est un couple qui
vient de Tirana, la capitale et qui veut
aller faire un voyage de nos au cœur des
montagnes albanaises. Le mari emmène sa
femme. La femme au début a très peur.
Elle sait pas exactement ce qu'elle fait
là. se retrouve dans les montagnes au
milieu de de cette société qui commet
encore des des crimes d'honneur où les
familles s'opposent entre elles parce
qu'il y a eu un mort il y a trois
siècles et qu'elles doivent continuer de
venger le sang de leurs frères. Il y a
euh le le code de l'honneur albanais qui
qui prévaut et cette femme qui au départ
se demande ce qu'elle fait là et
pourquoi son mari veut l'emmener là. son
mari, je crois qu'il est auteur, donc il
a envie d'en écrire quelque chose, mais
elle elle sait pas pourquoi elle est là.
Et en fait à la fin euh enfin, je lui
raconte pas la fin d'ailleurs, mais en
fait à la fin c'est même lui qui
n'arrivera pas à la faire revenir à
Tirana. Et donc toute cette histoire,
c'est entre c'est le le tiraillement
entre bah voilà la modernité et la
beauté finalement de la tradition qui
peut nous faire peur au début.
Avril brisé et dernier
dur, c'est dur d'en choisir trois.
Alors, donnez-moi un verre de poésie.
OK. Euh Victor Hugo classique, on va
faire du français. Alors, ça s'appelle
le mot. Brave gens, prenez garde aux
choses que vous dites. Tout peut sortir
d'un mot qu'en passant vous perdites
tout, la haine et le deuil. Et ne
m'objectez pas que vos amis sont sûrs ou
que vous parlez bas. Écoutez bien ceci.
Tête à tête, porte-close en pantoufle
chez vous sans un témoin qui souffle.
Vous dites à l'oreille du plus
mystérieux de vos amis de cœur ou si
vous l'aimez mieux, vous murmurez tout
seul dans le fond d'une cave à 30 pieds
sous terre. Un mot désagréable à quelqu'
individu. Ce mot que vous croyez que
l'on n'a pas entendu que vous disiez si
bas dans un lieu sourd et soubre, court,
à peine lâché par bondissort de l'ombre.
Tenez, il est dehors. Il a deux pieds un
bâton à la main de bon soulier. Ferrer,
un passeport en règle. Au besoin, il
prendrait des ailes comme l'aigle. Il
fuit, il vous échappe, rien ne
l'arrêtera. Il suit le quai, franchit la
place et cetera, passe l'os bateau dans
la saison des crues et va tout à des
dédales de rue droit chez le citoyen
dont vous avez parlé. Il sait le numéro,
l'étage, il a la clé, il monte
l'escalier, passe entre arrière
ailleurs, regardant l' ma face dit "Me
voilà, je sors de la bouche d'un tel et
c'est fait. Vous avez un ennemi mortel."
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Lise des livres déjà.
Croyez en vous. Défendez vos idées et
pas celles des autres. N'ayez jamais
peur d'entrer dans la technique, de ne
pas croire ce qu'on vous dit.
Engagez-vous si c'est possible à mes
côtés si vous le souhaitez.
Aimez votre pays. Ne croyez pas que
c'est démodé. Bien au contraire. Et bah
basiquement essayer d'être des gens
bien. Sarah KnF. Merci. Merci.
[Musique]